Bye-bye, boo!
Everybody.
Hello.
Fancy seeing you here today.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome, welcome.
Hello.
Artist known as Minto.
Scary!
Time for some wintertime horror.
How long has it been since I've played a horror game?
I think I played so many in October that I was like, I
shouldn't touch anymore for a bit.
But this game has been recommended to me so many times that
I was like, okay, I have to try it, I suppose.
I suppose, I suppose.
But I'm going to be honest, you guys.
I think I've said this before, but for anybody who missed
it, I'm not really good with it.
These kinds of survival horror, they're like just not my
type.
They're like not my type of horror that I like.
So I'm kind of like...
That's why I haven't played it.
Until now.
Joy, welcome to Vumbushim.
Purple Vax, welcome to Vumbushim.
Thank you, bro.
Thank you.
Time to beat another game today.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Today is another longer stream, I think.
So, buckle in.
Or, you know, not buckle in.
We're just here to chill.
We're chilling, we're relaxing, you know.
Kodanoa!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much!
We're 20 months!
Thank you!
Happy, happy birthday!
Whoa, Vera, thank you so much.
I've been able to watch streams lately due to being really
busy.
Congrats on becoming an idol in your upcoming jazz concert!
Thank you!
Vera Land, thank you so much for those!
Yeah, I have my jazz concert.
Tickets should be up.
There will be announcement, I believe, today of when tickets
will be up for the jazz concert on Oshi Spark.
Twitter.
So, read the whole thing.
What do you mean read the whole thing?
What else are...
Oh, really proud of you.
Thank you.
we're here for moral support so i'll be good yeah i don't
know i guess like i always find these games more tedious
than spooky but this seems kind of spooky like the
atmosphere right now i don't know it's or rather it's spooky
at first and then it kind of loses the feeling but this game
is It's not so long, so maybe it'll be pretty good to hold a
knife.
I hope so.
Crokey, my below.
You're not crokey.
Wrong!
Wrong.
Wrong stream.
I'll dreamer.
Thank you so much for it, though.
We're so far.
Gifted.
Thank you.
Love the thumbnail art.
Yeah, we're kind of goffy today.
We're goffy today.
It's an unnerving game, that's for certain.
I see.
I'm excited to try it.
I mean, I can't say if I like it or dislike it unless I play
it, right?
So, congrats on upstarting art career.
Oh, thank you.
Exhibition on the Louvre.
Louvre me.
Steal me.
There's this guy that would, like, make songs about the
heist at the Louvre.
I'd be like the...
Two dudes who stole the painting at the Louvre were so
handsome or something like that.
Oh, also, Ducky, thank you for the offline don't know.
I saw it.
And yes, I don't know why you guys would make art based on
my drawings, but feel free.
For those that don't know, I made a sub account, like a sub
Twitter.
account to to to to just post art on but i just get i get
nervous i get nervous
because i have no confidence so um drop the link why just
just go find it on my twitter you can go find it there um i
don't want it to you know i'm not i'm not looking for it to
become like a explosion account it can grow naturally if
people like my art i was i've been drawing while watching
breaking bad so um yeah
been like, watch Breaking Bad Draw art.
Big bag!
Thank you so much for the part.
Get done!
Thank you!
Do a Walter White portrait.
Walter White fan art, yo.
It's normal to be nervous, but your art is super cute.
Keep it up.
Thank you!
Did you start season three?
I did.
I'm a couple episodes in.
It's one of my favorite games be liking me too thank you
thank you so much for the super chat for you to book i'm
looking forward a lot of people have really raved about this
game so i don't know maybe i'm just being critical of the
genre i'm so glad to be able to watch you live for once
tanuki senpo thank you welcome in yeah yeah yes i will watch
i will watch better call sol next i like that guy He's so
funny I like Saul Actually I want to watch more for him And
like the other bald dude Partner Everyone else is
frustrating me right now Like everybody It's kind of funny
because like everyone's Lives were like pretty chill Pretty
normal and then here comes Walter White and Jesse Pinkman
and they like Are screwing everything up These guys just
These guys are like so...
They're disaster children.
Played this through earlier in the year and had a blast with
it.
Good luck, Minto.
Thank you!
I guess we should get into it then, because it's gonna be a
bit of a longer stream, so...
New get- hold on.
I gotta turn on my controller again.
Welta.
Welta why?
What?
You will not be attacked?
Murder of crows.
Hard mode.
Resources are more limited.
Enemies are more aggressive.
Danger may be lurking around every corner in survival
horror.
Exploration mode.
Wait, this is for me!
Maybe somewhere can I find your art?
I would love to check it out.
I... I... I linked it in...
I have my own.
twitter account and then i posted the link to it there um i
don't plan on posting it on i'm trying to make it kind of
low-key so i don't want to like make a big post about it i'm
sorry today is my birthday malvo can i get happy birthday
shout out for you thank you very much happy birthday happy
birthday happy birthday
A few months ago, you recommended Q-Pot stuff as a gift.
Wife loved her Christmas present.
Thanks for the gift.
I'm telling you, I'm telling...
Wait, what did you get?
More $200.
Also, thank you so much.
Wait, thank you for the donut.
Thank you for taking my advice.
Wait, what did you get?
What did you get her?
Nice thumbnail.
Thank you.
Thank you, of course.
Happy birthday.
I recommend exploration mode if you struggle with survival
horror games.
It's not that I I got her one of the chocolate wallets Let's
go
That's not that I'm bad with survival horror It's that I I
don't want to be a baby about it You know I'm just like I
just Don't enjoy the genre Superton Oh Barry Let's go
Oh wasn't very long, so all right.
Yesterday you said that bald is beautiful and said that if
we were balding, you'd just shave it off, so today I went
bald.
My head is now very cold.
Should have waited for some...
You went bald!
Oh my god!
That's so awesome!
You went bald!
The survival horror aspect of this game is pretty lax.
Okay, we'll do it then.
I don't want to be a baby about it.
That's no fun.
Not getting attacked at all.
Only horror, no survival.
That's pretty much how I feel.
2025!
Oh my gosh, we only have like two...
Oh.
1990!
Grandpa!
Hello, Mito.
I was like you!
Must confess, I...
I...
Also went bald.
My name is Mara.
Okay, sorry, I have to read these now.
Mara Forrest.
Special Agent Forrest.
That's me.
Don't forget.
Okay, Mara Forrest.
Special Agent Forrest.
Don't mess it up.
Okay.
Everybody's going bald.
This is so awesome.
Sarah Forrest.
Hey, hey.
mess it up.
That's me.
Mara Forest.
What a the schnaz on her.
Oh my gosh.
I can't walk and shoot at the same time.
I just...
Okay.
I have no... Why did I bring this gun?
Why am I holding it if I have no bullets?
Mara Forest, I thought... Oh, it's a car.
It's a really nice car, but it's covered in trash.
I guess the owner doesn't care for it anymore.
Why would she do that?
Why would she bring a gun and no bullets?
Oh, bugs are trash.
They're old.
They smell terrible.
How to be Vodkaing today.
We're looking forward to watching later.
The trailers for this look so cool.
Also very cute art.
I will enjoy from a respectful distance.
It's considered me so cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
You're MGS Pro.
You got this boss?
Is this a sneaking mission?
Ooh.
We've got one bird left.
Can I knock it?
Can I knock this over?
No, I can only dance around it.
Mara Forest, afraid of cones.
Anything else?
Oh, wait, there's a what?
There's blood on the ground!
What happened here?
Leave it?
Yeah, we'll just leave the blood on the ground.
I think that would be wise.
It's chained up.
The padlock looks a little rusty.
It would probably break with enough force.
I better go open the trunk of my car.
Let's put on here.
There's something important stored in here.
Open it.
I was bald for four years, grew my hair out, didn't want to
deal with the barbers, and went back to bald.
I don't blame you.
I don't want to be bald.
Hair is so much work.
Even if it's like ghost hair even.
That's even the worst because, okay, as a ghost, my...
Okay, you know, like...
okay as a ghost my hair wants to instinctively like go in
front of my face like i'll wake up and i'll look like you
know like samara from the ring or something i'm sadako you
know like i'm my hair just instinctively because it's a go
because i'm a ghost it's just the ghost hair it just
instinctively wants to go in front of me so i have to like i
have to style it every day for you guys to look
When I'm, like, done, you know, it just wants to, right in
front of my face.
So annoying.
I want to be bald, too.
Minto pretty.
Stop it.
Getting all dolled up for her eyeballs.
Maybe.
Maybe I want you to guys to have a good impression of me.
I don't know.
It's my box of handgum.
Oh, we do have the ammo.
Take it.
What else we got?
I've had enough.
Oh.
We're not going to shut it?
Or...
It's my box.
I have enough.
Shoot.
Oh.
Oh, that's a reload.
Gosh, that was loud.
Sounds like so much work.
Your hair is really pretty, though.
Thanks for your efforts.
Of course.
Would you guys go to a crow-themed amusement park?
What's that?
It's a pocket light.
Looks like somebody dropped it.
Finders, keepers.
Exteriors.
Oh no, I might have to turn it on and off to hide, right?
What does that say?
It's a ticket booth.
I have no intention of buying a ticket.
Illegal activities?
You would!
Trash can.
It's full of trash.
Oh, reach in!
This is the most...
Oh, Medkit!
This is the most like, uh...
Survival horror thing ever.
Just reaching in toilets and trash.
Page from a magazine.
Oh!
Megabyte magazine.
Tips and tricks.
Okay, I've been doing RT.
The advantage of using RT is that it frees you up to use R
to rotate the camera.
Wait, what?
Is B not?
What about you?
It can rotate camera with R.
Oh, I get what they mean.
Oh, okay.
Also, the camera will face...
I was thinking of L.
I was thinking of L, not R.
Yeah, health kit in the garbage.
So sanitary, right?
Love that.
Especially this...
Who knows how long this theme park has been abandoned?
Camera will quickly face forward when you press R-B to use
your weapon.
Main gate.
Leads out to the public parking lot.
It's been blocked ever since they shut Crow Country.
This here's Crow Country.
And they met Kits.
full of trash I feel like I'm definitely going to get like
attacked in one of these trash cans I know how these games
work what is this whoa what is it I think of all things we
should be examining this
bathroom it's a door Oh,
that don't look good.
Oh, worst flashlight ever.
Doki Bird has a theme park now?
Oh, yeah, we can rotate the camera.
Ah, I see.
Okay, okay, I see how it works now.
Um, okay, RB at the ready.
What is this?
Wait, my head's blocking it, but there's something squishy
in there.
There's a blood on the ground.
Look at that, look at that.
Hey!
What's that?
It's a laser sight for a handgun.
Oh, sure!
Um, okay, we're about to get ambushed.
Box of ammo.
Okay.
What the?
Why do I have laser sight?
That's pretty sick.
I saw here there was a thing, yeah.
Vending machines and trash cans may provide you with
supplies if you're running low.
You can also get handgun ammo from the trunk of your car.
Which means we could just...
That sounds like we could just leave, no?
It's a urinal.
Doesn't look like anyone's cleaned it for a while.
Nasty.
Seems so convenient.
The urinal?
That's true, though.
Can I turn this off?
Agent Mara Forest saves the day once again.
How do I save in this game, by the way?
You hear that?
How's the audio, by the way?
It seems like it's quite...
Hold on.
Actually, it seems like it's quite low.
Audio is good?
Oh, okay, cool.
Who's talking?
Ugh.
What's this?
Money?
It's a toilet.
There's something in here, but I can't get at it.
It's blocked by a pile of old bones.
I can use my ID card.
That doesn't work.
Okay, I'll leave it.
Why can't I move the bones?
What is this?
A magazine.
Someone got skeleton eyes.
I hate when there's bones in my toilet.
August 1989 strange sighting at abandoned theme park
aspiring god the sound is so creepy I just want to say your
streams and vids make me happy lollipop thank you thank you
so much really appreciate it serves me if we're not chewing
my food you're just just clogging up your intestines and the
pipes.
I'm clogging up both pipes.
Aspiring paranormal photographer Arthur Mole sent in a
polaroid he took while exploring the abandoned amusement
park Crow Country.
Someone was getting frisky with a mothman.
They're boundless.
Could this thing possibly be real?
Or is it just another hoax?
Here at Beyond Magazine, we're not convinced.
Try a little harder next time, Arthur.
Okay, but what actually what is that supposed to be you know
what i was on arthur's side at first because i think it's
kind of you know i was on his side at first but now what the
heck is that even supposed to be it looks like a guy like
floating in the air
hmm what is that sound it's horrible
something's blocking it
i'm getting out of here okay I did not like that I just
realized oh my gosh I was treating this as like a pure like
you know PS1 survival horror with the fixed camera angles
but it's very nice that we can move it oh what's this we can
actually move it when shooting your bullets will do more
damage if you're closer to the enemy so attempting to shoot
enemies from far away will use up your ammo supplies more
quickly Oh, no!
Sleepy Coral, welcome back!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Hey, chill.
What is that?
Some kind of dead animal.
I can't make out any features.
What's in here?
Locked from the other side.
It's locked.
There's a bronze keyhole.
Alright, for the...
train.
That is explosive.
This is explosive barrel.
Oh, okay.
And this guy is a big crow.
Hello, Mr. Crow.
I'm looking for your boss.
Do you know where he is?
This is also explosive.
Interesting.
Very, very interesting.
Fortune telling machine.
You have ten credits remaining.
Would you like to hear your fortune?
Yes.
Talk to the tree fairy to enter the fairy pond.
It's a hint system?
Is this how I save?
No.
Metal pole?
A lot of crows around here.
You get 10 hints.
Wait, what did it say?
Talk to the fairy to enter the Wait, what?
I can't even remember.
Box of shotgun shells.
I'll take that.
Okay.
Give me a shotgun right now, baby.
Oh, this looks like meds, too, right?
Med kit.
I love ground med kit.
Humanoid enemies will take more damage if you get a
headshot.
Headshot also has a chance of decapitating.
Bonjour, mito.
Hope you're fine, by the way.
Very pretty, very black.
Oh, got a soda.
Kick it.
Wait for it.
A bottle of antidote came out.
My favorite drink.
You can quickly defeat enemies by exploding the red barrels.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Similarly, useful are the blue electrical generators found
on some walls.
Oh.
Staff memo.
I admit it.
I dropped the bronze key into the fairy pond!
It was an accident.
It wouldn't be such a problem if we made a spare.
Silver keyhole.
Okay, I'm just exploring everything right now first.
Staff memo.
Crow fact.
Did you know crows, ravens, and wolves are best friends in
the wild and work together?
Really?
Fairy pond.
Yeah, I want more Crowfax.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Also, Scratch, I hope you're doing well today too.
Thank you.
There's something wrong with the ventilator in the fairy
pond area.
What the heck is a fairy pond?
We think something might have crawled into the pipe and
died.
Don't run the ventilator.
And if you do, hold your breath.
Oh my god.
What?
No, heckin' away.
Oh,
there's an antidote right here.
How do I know what my health is?
I don't have, like, a...
Oh, I can back up using this.
Okay, that's my...
This is run.
There's a backpack here, even.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, what did I say?
1988.
It's empty.
Did someone lose it?
Interesting.
Someone's just setting up traps.
There's an indicator.
I don't know what button is for inventory.
Oh, here we go.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, we're okay.
It's LB for anyone curious.
What about this?
This looks like it's Breakable, no?
There was another one, too.
Fairy tale town.
2106?
That's just a box.
What's this?
Oh, yeah.
2106.
I think it's written in blood.
Is it a code for something?
Oh, I see that.
You're not getting me this time.
No, sir.
I wonder what the enemies are going to look like.
Well, this looks like it's from Adventure Time.
It's a giant mushroom.
It doesn't look very happy.
Is this a door?
Can't see a way to open it.
Well, here, the music is kind of picking up.
There's a guy out there.
What is this?
It's a keypad.
Oh!
Two, one.
Oh wait, there's no zero.
Just kidding.
I see legs!
Polaroid camera.
Checky!
I think it's broken.
Uh-oh.
Legs.
That don't look so good.
Mr?
Are you...
Are you possessed?
Talk.
Sir, what happened here?
What?
Who?
My name is Mara Forest.
I'm here to help.
They attacked me.
All I wanted was proof.
What's your name?
Arthur Mbal.
I just needed a better, a clearer photo.
A photo of what?
Who attacked you, Arthur?
Those things.
I don't know.
Those people, they saw me and...
Alright, stay calm.
You're bleeding quite badly.
Dang!
How long has he been here?
I should help him.
How?
I'm not a doctor.
What did you say your name was?
Mara.
Come on.
I think we should take a look at your leg.
Give him a healing item!
Ravens follow wolves to eat their carry-on, or lead wolves
to prey by circling over their prey?
Symbiotic relationship.
I guess I'm medkit, right?
What if it was poisoned, though, by the blood of the thing?
Thanks.
I should help him.
I still feel kind of bad.
Come on, let's move you to somewhere safe.
You don't look too heavy.
Okay, we're moving, Arthur.
Okay.
To my car?
Carther?
I hope he doesn't mutate in my car.
That would be pretty bad.
I moved Arthur to my car.
He'll be safe there for now.
He's gonna rob me blind?
I just stole that guy's food.
Some creature's gonna get mad at me.
Is the shirt in the thumbnail meant to...
Don't make fun of it!
Oh.
Did he leave?
Oh no.
This bloody pad.
Full of trash.
Large med kit!
Oh my gosh.
We were rewarded.
There's a note on the floor.
Tree lady.
I guess Arthur wrote this.
3184.
Okay.
Let's go do that instead.
Is it this one?
Tree lady?
Three, one.
Oh, I see her.
Fairy.
There's something in the tree.
It's a wooden carving of a woman.
She's facing the other way.
She's like moving.
She's got an idle animation.
What was it?
Three, one, eight, four?
She turned around.
I think I remember you have to talk to her?
There was some kind of phrase you had to say.
I don't remember what it was, though.
There... Wait, there was?
Oh.
I don't think I know this yet.
Wait, do it?
Do I?
The quickest way to Tolman's office is through the fairy
pond area, right?
problem is I forgot how to get the stupid tree fairy to move
out of the way I guess I need a code for the keypad and then
what I'm sure it was written down somewhere maybe in crow's
lounge okay we're going to the lounge baby oh my gosh you
guys I got to go into an airport lounge for the first time
in my afterlife coming home from Japan a friend had had an
extra like an invite and I was able to go in I was like,
whoa!
It was so fancy.
I was like, I kind of want to always have the lounge access.
What's it like?
It was nice.
I just kind of sat there and there were, there were like,
um, I kept getting some sort of drink.
I can't remember.
I think it was like a, like a, one of the, like a, like a
fruity water.
Yeah, they have showers in there.
And then there was a guy who made fresh ramen or udon.
And then there was just like so much food.
And I was like, this is craziness.
And it was free for me because it was my friend's invite.
But I was like, whoa, rich people's stuff.
I know.
I feel like royalty.
The lounge at Haneda is so nice.
comfy.
That's the one it was.
Hi, Mito.
Thank you for visiting Florida last weekend.
It was amazing having you in Doki there.
I was the Kagami Tishiro cosplayer who asked what's the
biggest animal you could take in a fight.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thanks for coming to see us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Do not enter.
Does that look like a lounge?
There's a med kit here.
Is there like an issue to picking up the med kits?
If I die, do I lose them?
Read the staff memos posted on walls around Crow Country.
In every save room, there is a book containing all the staff
memos you read so far.
Oh, that's nice.
What's this room?
Oh, theater.
It's a big door.
Let's think it's blocked from the other side.
She said 100 elephants because she's the strongest ghost in
the world.
Yeah, I Why not?
You can only carry so many.
Ah, I see.
When shooting, your bullets will do more damage if you're
closer.
Oh, I did read this one already.
Wait, what did it say?
Something to shoot.
We'll use your supply.
Yeah, yeah.
Human, oh, yeah.
Okay, I think there's an enemy beyond there.
Old cigarette machine.
I'm not allowed to smoke.
Okay.
Is this a save room?
I don't think so.
Happy birthday!
I also have to ask, do the monsters in this respawn?
Like how...
Let's just go for it.
Do they respawn like in other PS1 survival horror games?
Yes.
Some do.
Oh my god.
How do I shoot?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
Run away.
God, die already!
Okay, never mind, I'm leaving.
That was scary.
Oh, I'm dying now.
Ugh!
Never mind.
Oh, whoops.
It's this one, right?
I'm injured.
Oh, wait.
Let's see.
I'm okay.
They have tanky, right?
What the heck?
Okay, so it's be the shoe in a reload.
There we go.
Okay.
Can you aim up and down?
Oh, yes, you can.
Okay, yeah, you can.
Cosmic future coming summer 1990.
Here at Crow Country, we can't wait to share our optimistic
vision of the future with you.
Ooh, it was supposed to be finished this year.
happen.
Our dang park is overrun with zombies.
What is that?
I thought I was getting headshots on the guy, but maybe...
Oh no.
My depth perception strikes again, perhaps.
Hey, Ed.
When some good news?
I finally found a good site for our gold mine.
It's in Parra.
Northern Brazil.
Brazil mention!
Just like we wanted, there's a disused mine there.
The locals gave up on it years ago.
Uh...
It shouldn't be too much work to get it looking the part.
Marv.
Brazil.
Kick it.
What?
Monsters...
Wait, from experience, monsters don't respawn, but new ones
will spawn in rooms as you make progress through the story.
Got it!
Thank you!
Nothing!
Wait, what's he?
Hole in the fence.
Looks like it was done with wire cutters.
I think this is how Arthur got in.
Seems like he cut himself on the fence.
Oh, what a bozo.
Arthur, Arthur, Arthur.
We literally got in through the front door.
I mean, all I had to do was shoot it, but...
Medkit!
Wasting my precious medkit on Arthur when I needed it the
most.
Staff memo, if you're looking for the machine chain, one of
the swan boat people took it to fix a broken swan.
I told them not to take it.
And they took it anyway.
You can't reason with swanboat people.
So true.
Also, do I get like not...
Do I get melee weapons eventually?
I would like a melee weapon.
No!
I don't?
Did I look in this one?
I think I did.
I think I got the big...
Oh, bullets.
seriously not did i read this one let me check
yes the fairy tree so we need to figure out what she says or
what we need to say to her page from a magazine if you get
poison use an antidote as soon as you can large med kits
also contain antidotes but you might wish to use them
sparingly i see what is this oh this a jug.
Oh, there's something here, too.
What's in here?
It's a set of stairs.
The swan!
We found it.
It's been broken.
I want to know how to repair it.
A wheel.
Pretty sure it's broken.
This one looks intact, though.
It doesn't turn.
There's a strange mechanical swan head.
Do I need to put something in its mouth?
My ID?
There's a hole in the fence.
I can reach the edge of the water.
What's that?
Shotgun?
They're teasing me.
They're absolutely teasing me.
Staff memo.
So the eggs are going missing.
I think the kids are stealing them.
The Mara Forest ID.
Maybe he wants my...
Maybe he wants...
Maybe the Swan wants...
Uh...
Once...
to
open a credit card.
Luckily, it turns out you can use anything as long as it's
about the right size and shape.
Oh, it's for the egg, for the mouth.
It's weird.
I assume that the eggs were magnetic or something, but
apparently not.
What would be a similar size to an egg year?
If a swan breaks down, just take the egg out of its wheel
system.
Doing so, disables the radio signal and locks the wheels
until you can get the mechanic out to fix it.
I don't think I understand what this is.
Do you guys?
Do you guys know what kind of attraction this is?
Do you control the swans?
RC swan.
But then what do you do?
Do you avoid the baby ducks?
It's like a merry-go-go-go-go.
go around on water.
Newspaper.
The Atlanta Globe.
May 1986.
Crow Country Theme Park.
Opening soon.
Cancel your weekend plans with the in-laws and grab your
sunglasses.
A brand new theme park is opening just a few miles southeast
of Atlanta.
What is up with Atlanta?
Why is that place so stinking cursed?
You got the Walking Dead.
You got the country what why are things always happening in
atlanta i
mean i guess with the walking dead it's like the cdc but
still should be ohio
georgia is a different dimension literal twilight zone over
there like what's happening karma for being unwalkable that
sounds like a it's literally the walking dead they walked
everywhere, Berrybug I think it's pretty walkable it's not
called the driving dead
Sergeant, welcome to Mambujib Thank you the car commuting
dead explore a fairy tale town haunted hilltop an ocean
kingdom at country, which promises a day full of fun and
adventure for the whole family.
Lots of scary stuff happens in Atlanta, like Phantom Thief's
Revenge Concert.
Yeah, exactly.
The park is owned by one Mr. Edward Crow, a lifelong Atlanta
local and landowner.
Yes, that's right.
It appears he named the park after himself.
Okay, but that's not so unusual.
What?
We're going to shame Mr. Crow for naming the park after
himself.
but Walt Disney gets a pass?
Okay.
Sure, Jan.
Not much is known about Mr. Crow other than vague,
unsubstantiated reports that he is exceptionally wealthy.
Nonetheless, we look forward to seeing what Crow Country has
to offer when it opens its gates this summer.
Exciting.
Okay, so we gotta go get something that's like the shape of
an egg year.
I also need to learn how to aim so I can uh...
Did I open this guy?
Soda?
I wonder if a soda can will do!
It's kind of the shape of an egg, right?
Use item... Wait, where's my soda can?
I took it, right?
garbage.
I don't care.
We're in a horror game.
We use everything.
Take the antidote.
Mara threw it away.
I thought I literally found something.
You.
Oh, that was the club.
I juke that thing like crazy.
Oh, yeah.
Holy cow.
What about a cigarette?
No?
Guys, I'm scared.
This game makes me want to listen to Resident Evil 2 OST.
This game makes me want to listen to Resident Evil OST
basement.
Wow.
You can shoot bear traps and obstacles.
Thank you.
I think I might need to do that here because otherwise...
Oh, whoops.
I'm scared that I will...
Laser sight.
What was...
Okay, it's B.
Mara!
Mara, I need you to focus, girl.
Okay, we got it.
Awesome.
Alright, I wish I could save.
The aiming seems very sensitive.
I wonder if there's a way to change it.
Controls?
Grenade!
Quick 180 turn.
Oh.
Baby needs assist.
Maybe.
I do?
I'm gonna also change shoot reload.
Yeah, I think I would do better if I'm shooting with X and
I'll...
What?
I don't know.
You would think Metal Gear would make me want to shoot with
O.
I think this makes more sense though, right?
Raise weapon, shoot.
Reload, switch weapon.
Switch weapon.
Okay.
We'll learn that later.
Interesting.
I didn't see a...
Aim assist is recommended in top-down games.
I'm not gonna lie.
My depth perception in this type of stuff is like pretty
tricky.
But I'll do my best, you know.
Okay, let's go.
I hope he's not like waiting for me.
I can't also tell what the head is.
There were two of them, though.
I saw...
It'd be really nice about a shotgun.
Maybe?
Do I stomp him?
Stomp him!
No.
Oh, that thing's big.
Wait, guys.
That thing's pretty big.
Oh, I decapitated it.
Oh, I took it down.
Ah!
Let's go.
It's dead.
Ugh.
It smells so bad like an infected wound.
I feel bad killing it.
But I feel bad leaving it alive too.
And just...
Just...
Crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch.
Crunch, crunch, crunch.
Pretty spooky in here, guys.
That's why you're the best, boss.
I'm doing my best.
That's all I can do.
Wouldn't say I'm the best.
I'm just doing my best.
Did they come from a mummy's curse?
What was that?
It's a wooden crate.
There's a note taped to the lid.
Ship to Marvin Trumbull.
Brazil!
Content samples of geological interest.
I'm so sorry, Marvin.
We just doxed you.
I'm so sorry, I just doxed you, Marvin.
Open it!
What do you mean open it?
full of racks each one is embedded with pieces of shiny
metal metal is this a crate full of gold ore maybe not poor
Marvin glass it's a staff memo did you guys watch Apollo you
guys watch Apollo the bird when I recommended him if this is
your first time seeing me.
Hello.
I recommend a bird named Apollo.
His owners give him things and they're like, what is this
made of Apollo?
And he goes, metal.
Or glass.
Staff memo.
Can I ask why the dig site access is that cute little house?
Don't you think there's a chance that some kid would want to
go looking in there?
At the very least, let's keep it locked via the keyhole on
the mailbox.
I see it.
There's like a lot of sounds.
Oh, a vent.
Is there something inside?
I hear something, though, no?
I'm scared.
Nothing.
If you're using Deepak to move, you can do a 180 quick turn.
Okay, yeah.
Nice.
What's this?
Notebook.
Tolman's Records, March 21st, 19th.
1988 save room oh that's what i thought it might be awesome
you spin me into right bound baby right right monday morning
driving to work boss calls into my car radio he doesn't
normally do that something has obviously gone wrong intruder
alarm going off in the second unit boss thinks someone is
down there get to work check the security cameras someone is
down there he's Standing right by the pool.
All security doors down to the pool are locked.
Check security records.
Doors untouched since 6 p.m.
on Friday.
Alarm has only just been triggered.
I turn on the intercom.
Try to communicate.
No response.
But I can hear the sound he's making.
Something is wrong.
His clothes don't fit him.
Something is very wrong.
It's an ashtray.
I'm surprised this whole place hasn't burned down.
Also, this is like the coziest room ever, no?
Bookshelf.
Mining your own business.
Economics of the mining industry.
Joseph's got a sense of humor.
Oh, here it is.
Remember to get into the great pond, or the fairy pond area.
Say this out loud to the fairy.
Hear me, oh great fairy of fairest forest.
I'm pretty sensitive, so it won't work if you have an
accent.
Sorry, Diego.
Hear me, O Great Fairy, A Ferris Forest.
Would Phoebe like hearing that?
I think she would.
Magazine?
It's a collection of video game tips.
Oh, they did say that we would have the whole thing.
Oh, a map.
We got a map!
see it oh are we oh this is so nice oh and it even shows
where i am okay cool wait uh swan boats and then maybe maybe
that middle red to the left is the fairy pond or something
fireplace it's the flames, I feel something.
It's a curious mixture of hope and dread.
Maybe everything will be okay.
Maybe it won't.
Oh!
Save complete, baby!
What's this here?
Is this uh, there's staff notes, maybe?
Staff memos, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cabinet.
There's a keypad.
This one doesn't also have zero.
Huh.
Fires appear to be safe.
Safe points.
8008.
It must be.
State Court 185 Central Avenue, Southwest Atlanta, Georgia,
30303 United States.
Legal summons.
Oh my gosh.
I know some of you watching here are from Atlanta.
Go.
Go and go to this place.
It's Oshikats.
Terry, hello.
This is Oshikats, right now.
Dear Mr. Crow, I am writing to you in relation to the
incident which occurred within your theme park in July of
1988.
As you know, a 15-year-old girl by the name of Elaine
Marshall was injured.
Ooh.
I think she's the enemy.
The incident occurred within your premises, within working
hours.
As such, the Marshall family is holding you personal
responsible.
Your presence is required in court.
We expect to hear from you immediately.
Antidote.
I wonder how many I can carry.
Oh there's also a health kit.
Awesome, possum.
Oh yeah, what?
Oh sorry, what was it?
Hear me, oh great fairy of Ferris forest.
Okay.
Let's go do it.
I miss... I miss the comfy...
I miss the comfy room.
It was crawling, wasn't it?
Oh my gosh.
What?
Oh.
Oh!
That's some fancy shooting.
If I do say so myself.
Ah!
There's another one.
More!
Oh my god.
Please.
I have to lock in like crazy.
And stay dead.
You nasty critters, you.
What was that?
Oh my god.
There's creatures now.
Oh my god, there's creatures everywhere.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to talk to the great fairy if there's
critters all over the place trying to get me
uh hear me oh great fairy of fairest forest
welcome child will you protect our precious natural world
say i will i will the atlanta i booze you want the atlanta i
booze to go to court for ocean cuts do they have to do
something or can they just be visiting just visiting just
make it a little pilgrimage rooting tooting me toe shooting
i will follow me
climb through i'm at the fairy pond i think uh engraved
message those who seek the truth stare into the pure
reflective water of our fairy pond also am i okay i'm I'm
injured, but...
I'm not poisoned or anything.
I just didn't expect a...
Yeah.
Wait, so what did I say?
Enemies aren't actually very aggressive.
They won't chase you as long as you maintain your distance.
Oh, cool.
Thank you.
Zelda vibes!
I was like, it the same thing!
Those who seek the truth stare into the pure reflective
water of our fairy bar.
I'm looking.
It's filthy.
It's not pure or nor reflective.
Oh, what does this say?
Read the gameplay tips, post it on the walls, every saver.
Yeah, okay.
Maybe we've found most of these.
Staff memo.
So the guy who fixed the water filter did it by running it
through the air ventilation system.
If you run the filter pump behind the curtain, with the
incorrect pressure, too high or too low, it'll trigger the
ventilator.
Be careful.
You can tighten up the pressure using the valve handle.
Okay.
i wish they would give me less antidote more health control
box ventilator override do not touch
okay there's also in here
uh okay
we were warned about poison in the ventilator so true you're
right however i am aggressive and will Listen to this to...
JV!
Actually, I expect nothing less of you.
Where are we?
Okay, never mind, our map is kind of stinky.
You guys see that?
What's going on in here?
Ammo.
Reload?
Yeah, you guys saw the door, right?
Fire extinguisher?
Nothing's on fire.
What's it say here?
Who took the Ocean Kingdom restaurant?
Trident?
That thing is expensive!
And without it, we can't do the happy birthday sea monster
song!
Someone said they saw it in the Witchwood.
I'd go check, but that place gives me the creeps, honestly.
Fair?
Valid?
I think I will heal because our girl's looking a little.
Witchwood?
That wood.
I know you're behind there.
Oh!
It's a wall.
I can hear something behind it.
Is this also a wall?
It's a panel in the wall.
Whoa!
It's a model of a crow with rope.
The very last time I went to the theater with Ophelia, we
saw an action movie about a cybernetic man from the future.
I really, I didn't really get it, but she loved it.
She wouldn't stop talking about it.
CC, Terminator?
When did Terminator come out?
Hello, mean crawl.
I'm the crow now!
What am I stacking on?
I'm not stacking on anything.
I do have here, it's like a, it's like a, I'm not a
smoothie.
it a milkshake t2 would have been 1991 1984 oh then this
probably is about terminator got the mean kid thank you
eating spike eating bike tyson's hours thank you for super
giant i got to work designing this cyborg crow since i
thought she'd like it i was going to propose Oh, propose it
to Edward.
I thought he was going to propose with it.
Would you like a behind-the-scenes tour where you get to see
inside?
Yes!
Show me the animatronics.
I want to see the big guy.
I want to see the Peace Walker that was basically created by
the Imagineers.
I love endoskeletons.
I have to go Thanks for sticking around, Mobius!
Otamindo!
I was going to propose it to Edward as a new themed area of
the park After I lost Ophelia, I shelved the project Lost
Hal Wait, look closer I think the eye is made from a laser
sight Magnum laser Magnum laser Magnum laser Wait, what is
that for?
Shotgun shells.
Wait, so did that upgrade my gun?
How do I...
Doesn't seem like...
Doesn't seem like it upgraded.
Anything?
Did it?
Different gun.
Okay.
Watch for the metal bearer.
traps lying on the ground.
You can set them off from a safe distance with a single
handgun bullet.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Yes, we do know.
I'm afraid of... I don't know how to do this.
I'm afraid of setting it off and dying.
You know...
If you run the filter pipe behind the curtain with the
incorrect pressure, it'll trigger the ventilator.
Ventilator.
How am I...
How am I supposed to know?
The way Mara walks is so And look at her.
She's like, she's like, I'm a bad bitch.
And I'm going to take care of these things.
Can you move the curtain?
Oh, that's right.
Move the curtain.
Oh.
So it needs to be.
Well, it needs to be at the white.
I'm assuming, right?
Okay.
Oh, well.
Oops.
Oh!
What happened?
Ouch.
No, no, no.
I'm getting stuck.
Pull the lever!
Oops.
Oh, uh, I'm dying.
My bad.
Wait.
Oops.
Uh.
Oh.
I'm poisoned.
I kept getting stuck on the wall!
Uh, I think I'm about to die.
Get in the water!
Wait, can I fix it with this?
Oh my god, I almost died.
Wait.
Oh, we're fine.
I thought it was like one of those, like, oh, you just died.
I was ready to accept death!
I was accepting my fate!
Okay, we're gonna have to tighten it quite a bit then.
Alright, valve.
Tighten.
Yippee!
Okay!
I was ready to accept it.
I truly was.
Reflecting pool.
But I see this guy down here.
Do I...
Do I shoot it?
Or do I shoot... Is it this thing?
Right?
What does it say again?
Those who seek the truth stare into the pure reflective
water of our fairy pond.
Let's try the target first.
Oh, oops.
I can see it.
Alright.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
It's the fairy from the tree!
She's holding a key.
Bronze key.
Why did I?
I didn't become a ghost, avoiding poison.
Me too likely.
Oh, whoops, my bad.
What needed a bronze key?
Oh my gosh, there's so many things already.
Mara will talk to the fairy of the inspector.
I don't think so.
as soon as i leave here there's going to be lots of monsters
i think i'm going to heal again i'm scared of running out of
healing stuff maybe i should have done the large med kit
because it has the antidote in it too oh well we're fine can
you shoot the other thing the thing that this this thing i
think this it's so i think what it did is i shot this and it
bounced and hit this or something.
I don't want to, like, waste bullets, though.
I think we're okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alright, cool.
Stay away from me.
Stay back.
What is that?
Like, a pile of food?
What even is that?
Garbage?
Garbage monster?
I don't like that sound at all.
Oh, my God.
What the hell is that?
I'm just going to go the other way.
Uh, bronze key.
Uh.
There's a hole.
Doesn't work.
Let's turn off my light real quick.
Um.
Lanky boy.
Yeah, that guy is, uh...
He got some legs.
I wish I could move my camera upwards.
Like, I kind of hate you.
this.
You see, it's camping where I need to go?
Where am I, anyway?
I'm in here.
There's a few more doors down here.
Let's go check them out.
Oh, was it this one?
Maybe.
Bronze!
It was.
Oh.
What's going on in here?
What the heck?
Is it going to get mad at me if it hits me?
Oh no, they're above me.
Train gate.
Puzzle room, yeah.
Cute.
What is this?
A curtain.
It's a computer?
Oh!
Access to night.
There's a slot for a disc.
My ID!
No.
It's the sun.
The fire is crackling softly.
to the flames, I feel something.
Oh!
I'm gonna do a smile too.
Where is Shikari and Nozomi when you need them?
So true!
Just to say, there is no reason you have to defeat enemies,
but if you leave them, you may have a harder time traveling
around later on.
I don't like the sound of that.
They're literally like there's gonna be more of them later.
You will be overrun, probably.
What's this?
It's a train.
Oh, nope, it's a handgun ammo.
I like this vampire on the wall.
Very Nimi Nightmare Coden.
Edward Crowe, the Trailblazer.
Yeah, I'll just leave that there.
Tooman, the mole.
That's a grenade.
Wait, there's a grenade inside.
That has to be a grenade.
What?
Who are you?
Douglas Pike, the builder.
Natalie Crow, Autumn's Child.
The computer systems in both the railway room and the
dungeon now need the security disk to access.
Yes, I know it's inconvenient, but these are the new
regulations.
Shoot the glass.
It won't explode.
Well, I just saved, so if I die...
It's a grenade.
Grenade!
I've been thinking, can I shoot these two then?
I don't want to waste my ammo.
I can!
I've been thinking about it this whole time!
This is why I wanted melee.
So I could beat it up.
Orion's Odyssey, 1935.
Our grandest steam engine, elegantly combining all four
design styles.
During the war, it was used by the military to carry
artillery.
Tollman's records.
You see another grenade?
Wait, hold on.
I'll come back to this.
Oh, I see it!
How did you guys see that?
I thought it was part of the train.
March 23rd, 1988.
in the lab.
Boss is calling him the guest.
I told him that was in poor taste, but it stuck.
Do you want us to visit the courthouse after the stream?
Traffic kind of asked for it, though.
I'll go with my vid cosplay.
After stream, right?
I want you to hang around.
Did anyone look it up?
Is it a real address?
The devs were like, mmm, courthouse in Atlanta.
address.
It is!
Wait, you could actually go!
Oh, she gots.
That's crazy.
Offered guest food and water.
He took no notice of either.
I can't begin to describe what's wrong with him.
Boss doesn't want to call an ambulance.
He doesn't want to call anyone.
I suggested we shut down all root excavation.
Just until we work out what's happened.
Boss says we can't shut down just yet, so the machines are
back on.
I have a bad feeling.
I think we're about to make things worse.
Okay, so let's see what these things do here.
Train gate.
Oh, the Earl of Edgecomb.
A fine steam engine, beautifully combining the Arabella and
the and Bernadette design styles.
The Duke of Farnham.
1927.
A handsome steam engine, stylish combining the Arabella and
Delilah design styles.
There's nothing on them, but I also can't move or anything
when...
Okay.
So we have to get...
We have to get...
I'm so glad that it's unlimited saves.
Not like you have to find a cassette to save, stupid.
We have to get a disc for the computer.
Train room.
Oh, it says save.
Oh, that's nice.
Limited saves her.
It dies.
This puzzle cannot be solved until later.
That's what I thought.
so um but I'm also not quite sure what I need to do why are
swan oh swan boats circled because I need to still find you
think I could put a grenade in the mouth it's like an egg
right I
don't think it'll let me so
That sounds logical.
Oh my god, I don't like this sound at all.
Open from the other side.
Uh, oh, uh, everything else I could open.
Wonder if I could bait this guy and shoot him with the
barrel.
Where is he now actually?
Is he even still over there?
there's also see like i saw this one earlier there's
something in there hot dog indeed and then this thing oh
this was the hint thing that's right just imagine the
defunct land narrator voice describing this place yeah
oh i see him i see his little feet how is the bit rate in
this game by the way struggling a little okay if I beat him
over here there's this one it's good really okay cool oh my
god I feel like I need to what is he doing though okay I'm
gonna try and shoot him what's he doing oh my Oh my god,
he's so creepy!
What?
Oh my god.
Is he coming?
Oh, he's coming.
Let's shoot here.
Oh my god, please.
Where is he?
Sir?
Hello?
Is he coming the other way?
Is he baiting me?
Oh, oh lord.
He's right there.
Stuck on the house, I think, actually.
Actually, I think he's stuck on the house.
Oh, he's stuck on the house.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
God!
Don't look that way.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
He was too far away.
Um, I'm not very good at this, guys.
Uh, I think I might have missed out.
How, uh, I think I gotta bathe him, like, this way.
And turn around and do this.
Maybe...
Oh my god, wait.
Oh!
I got him!
Oh, I got him!
Oh!
Oh,
the music stopped!
Kick it!
And...
Nothing.
He was like looking in here.
Oh, he wanted me to use the barrels.
See, I need it!
I need it to come over here!
I knew he was camping.
I'm gonna go save.
I'm scared.
Save's coming.
It's fine.
She's gaming.
We're gaming, baby!
My man was literally made out of popsicle sticks, but that's
okay.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Okay, new area.
I'm gonna...
Oh, Medkit.
I'll take it.
I don't like the music though.
Why?
I killed the- there was no music after I killed a guy!
Haunted Hilltop!
Oh yeah.
We need another map for this area.
It's like I'm at home.
Obviously.
Yeah.
Why do I hear gunshots over here?
What's this say?
Signpost.
The dungeon?
Witchwood?
Wait, there was something in Witchwood we needed, no?
Haunted Manor, The Crypt.
There was something in Witchwood.
Excuse me.
You guys hear that?
The Trident.
wooden notice board.
Oh, there's a map.
Nice.
Okay.
We take those.
Oh!
Oh, you're like human, I think.
I'm not allowed to smoke.
Hello?
Uh, what are you doing?
Trying to get through this door.
Oh, right.
Is it locked?
Obviously.
Is there another way around?
It's possible.
Right.
I'll go have a look.
Have you seen any of the monsters about?
Please be careful around the haunted manor bookcases.
Read the book titles carefully.
In fact, it'd be easier if you just didn't touch them at
all, okay?
Ah.
Why do I hear banging over here too, though?
I think the sound design is just a little funky.
A little funny.
Kick it!
Uh-oh.
Do
it or not?
Okay.
It was...
Witchwood.
Is the one over...
Somewhere.
It's actually quite confusing.
Last bottles with red caps can be broken.
with a single handgun bullet.
Oh yeah, I have my grenade now.
I think I press X to use it.
Oh, just kidding.
Maybe I have to switch it out.
Maybe.
It's a real grenade.
Yeah, the handy barrel, but I don't know if I should...
Do those barrels respawn?
Because if I don't, I don't want to wait.
on a tiny guy like this, you know?
We'll have to aim first with it.
Oh.
Oh, I see!
Oh, like, aim like that.
Understood.
Oh, shoot.
Reload.
Woo!
It's scary.
What is that in there?
I can't tell.
Rapid fire.
I didn't panic.
I never panic.
You've been doing maintenance in the haunted manner, trying
to access Ocean Kitchen.
Kingdom.
Kitchen.
You'll need to crank the handle.
It's locked in the safe in the southeast utility corridor.
The code for the safe is something to do with the crypt, I
think.
Uh...
Okay, I need more ammo, don't I?
Oh!
He's hooting and hollering!
He seems like he hoots five times and then stops.
Is he supposed to be an owl?
He shaved more like a bell.
Oh, I probably have to ring it five times, right?
I imagine, to get inside.
Appleclaw.
It's pretty cute.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, guys.
Before we go into...
Well, let's try this area.
If it's spooky scary...
I'm gonna go save.
We're gonna go save, and then we'll go into the spooky
scary.
It's right there!
Okay.
We're fine!
I just need to hear the music and that'll be fine.
Hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo.
Which one should we try?
I'm thinking.
What was this one?
This looks like the crypt.
Spooky me to game it, let's go.
Mara even adds her sass to it when she tosses her.
grenades i know okay that's the crypt this must be the
haunted mansion oh manner sorry i wonder if that's
copyrighted then what's this one the witch and then the
dungeon no this must be the dungeon and then this is the
witch okay this is where we need to go for the trident okay
okay okay Oh, no!
Here's a witchwood!
It's a tent made of sticks.
Entrance is blocked.
It looks like it's just blocked by sticks.
I think we can get rid of that.
It's a face.
He's smiling at me.
I'll take it.
I couldn't move him.
I think he's fine where he is.
Oh.
Okay, interesting.
That's how we open him up.
Oh.
I'm just gonna run past you.
I think there's something...
Wait, what's this?
We had a complaint from a parent about the depiction of
alcohol in the mermaid cage.
Of all the things to complain about!
I told her it's not an alcohol bottle.
It's a bottle of highly corrosive acid that actually seemed
to placate her.
It doesn't open.
The dog is chasing after me, you guys.
The Deceptive Serpent Imprisoned for Crimes Against Nature.
1800 BCE!
Whoa.
When talking to NPCs, make sure you've seen all their
dialogue before moving on.
If you see a speech bubble, try talking to them again.
Oh, okay, cool.
Let's get to them.
The Deadly Mermaid Imprisoned For Crimes Against Nature.
Okay.
Oh, there's two of them.
The big bad wolf imprisoned for crimes against nature.
I don't know what I'm supposed to be doing here, but...
An iron maiden?
Wait, I can go in?
I'm somewhere.
What happened to me?
What is this?
I'm in the back rooms for real now.
The power switch for the...
The power switch for the four periphery elevators is in
Tolman's office.
Yes, that's the other side of the park.
Yes, that means you're in the wrong place.
Watch out for glass gas traps laying on the...
Oh, you can smash them from a safe distance.
Glass gas trap?
Oh my god, try saying that five times fast.
Glass gas trap, glass...
Magnum ammo!
Glass gas trap, glass gas trap, glass gas trap, glass gas
trap, glass gas trap.
Glass gas gas gas trap.
What was this one?
A cyclops.
I'm trying to see what this thing says on the table, but I'm
afraid of these little...
boogers.
These boogers chasing after me.
Oh, there's three of them.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What does it say?
I'll go up to stream.
Man, I request an...
Atlanta Hall for the squad.
You're not actually gonna go, are you?
I shouldn't ask how far away it is from you.
I guess people do live in Atlanta, huh?
If it's more than 10 minutes away, don't go.
7.
South American gold mine linked to local landowner reports
have emerged detailing the activities of a recently revived
Brazilian gold mine for the glass glass gas trap apparently
the site near the north coast of the state of state of para
is currently operating as one of the most profitable gold
mines in the Americas selling to at least two major
international companies but why you ask are we reporting
this in the Atlanta globe the person who writes these so
sassy too.
They're like, you might be wondering why am I riding this?
Well, actually.
They're so sassy.
It's recently surfaced at the gold mine in question is
actually owned by local landowner and businessman Edward
Crow.
Yeah, he's got an attitude.
They were like, yeah, he named the park after himself.
Most readers probably only know him as the eponymous
eponymon?
What's it?
How do you say that?
Eponymous?
Hippopotamus?
E-pony mouse?
Hippopotamus owner of the Crow Country theme park here in
Atlanta.
And indeed, it seems there has been some effort to cover up
Mr. Crow's connection to this profitable gold mine.
While eyebrows are certainly being raised at this
revelation, at least we finally discovered the source of
Crow's vast wealth.
Is this a puzzle here now then?
Am I supposed to do it in a certain order?
But I do not know the order yet, perhaps.
sheet.
Oh, computer.
I'm not good at computers.
Try anyway.
Okay, we don't have the slot.
Uh-huh.
This theme park is very interesting.
It's apparently a 21 hour, 21 hour drive.
I don't pass.
What do I miss the next stream?
What?
You're gonna pass?
Sounds good.
like the time of your life going to a courthouse in the
middle of a city that you have to drive 21 hours for this
thing they say that i can use this as well look at that guy
what is this one if you're doing maintenance on the haunted
oh yeah the crank handle and the safe wait what did it say
the code for the safe is something to do with the grip so
that's right
Let's try.
One, two, three, four, five.
Are you going to keep going?
We're in the haunted manor?
Dorak.
Oh.
Ghost!
He's so cute.
Where's the phone at?
Oh, is this it?
Hey!
Moshi Moshi.
You came back.
Who is this?
I'll admit, I'm glad to see you're up and about.
Oh, the tenacity of a youth.
He's gone.
Whoa, it's a window.
It's not real.
It's just a picture.
It hasn't rained in a while, actually.
Oh, another ghost.
Melody of the Dead.
By Allegretto Vivaci.
It's a little creepy.
Is it?
It looks like a skull emoji.
The clock needs regular one.
finding.
But please don't attempt it without the correct tool.
Do I die if I touch the ghost?
There's a lot of blood underneath him.
It's a coffin.
There's a vampire sleeping inside.
Did you know that you're cute today?
Kaboo!
Thank you!
Look closer.
Give him a little smooch.
He's not real.
Obviously.
He could be.
Tall wooden crates can be broken.
Wait, didn't it say not to touch the bookcases?
Can you make a cute sound?
Large cloak.
What is this?
Old painting.
Song in a cage.
Beowoo!
Painting of a demon.
An Andromalek.
Andromalek.
Glitch.
The undying.
Blamed for many deaths.
Between 1020 and.
1115.
Zekta.
Welcome to.
Oh, Bishop, thank you.
I refuse to put my hand in there.
Not happening.
Oh, come on.
I'm so curious about the ghosts.
And then I have to play something here, right?
My mom used to make me practice every day.
Oh.
Do-do-do.
Beep.
Wait.
Do-do-do-do.
Beep.
Do-do.
Do-do-do.
Beep.
Do-do-do-do.
Beep-weep.
Piano puzzle.
How.
Howl.
survival horror of them.
I'm so curious.
I'm going to touch it.
Oh.
Nothing happened.
Fortune telling machine.
Oh wait, we have another...
Harmony will fade by Alcuna Licenza.
Why is there a phone in here anyway?
Nah, well, thank you so much!
We're loved.
Why do you have to take you?
Ooh, ooh, ooh, thank you.
Examine the vampire game for fun dialogue?
That's what you get for trying to scare me.
The true evil, the one that you play the keys.
Yeah.
What if I just stand here?
Will I die?
Wait, what's this say?
Oh, this is the winding.
I'm afraid of lightning, you guys.
This part's scaring me.
Sorry.
It's scaring me.
I went to a place recently.
They had, like, a simulated thunderstorm.
But I was like, no.
I had to go, I had to leave.
I'm guessing the notes pertain to the pictures, but I'm not
quite sure.
Where are the clocks?
But these are all, like, song-related.
Wait, song in a cage.
C-A-G-E.
Wait a second.
Cage.
D-E-A-D.
Dead.
Fade.
Wait, okay, hold on.
C-O-G.
Oh, I got one.
Okay, wait.
Dead.
Oh, do I have to do it in order?
Oh!
Oh, this opens.
Climb through?
Oh my god, chill out.
Oh, sheesh.
Okay, I'm just gonna run.
I ain't got time to do it.
Oh, what the?
Who just shot?
Wait, what?
Oh, shoot.
No, no, don't come to me.
Hammer sponge.
like there should i should not this is why i don't like
survival horror games because i'm always like freaking out
about ammo there's a button between the pan a panel on the
back of the wooden crow house you can use it to access the
controls for the big animatronic crow okay gosh there's so
many memos to remember tolman's records march 27th 1988
alarm triggered at 2 15 a.m two more guests appeared in the
pool room.
This time, I made sure the cameras were running, so we have
proof.
They came out of the pool!
They were worse than the first.
Broken.
Wrong shape.
Falling apart.
I feel heartless describing them so, but I have no other
words for them.
Boss said we wouldn't be able to move them, like we did with
the first guest.
He spent 23 minutes trying to talk to them.
Then he shot them both.
Sorry, I thought I felt like I had...
Oh, my God.
I thought I had something in my throat.
Are you alright, ma'am?
My head...
Oh, she's turning.
I threw up.
Hey, it's alright.
Don't worry about it.
Can I ask, did something happen to you?
It only grazed me.
I thought I'd be fine.
I don't even know what it was.
My head is pounding.
My stomach is...
Alright.
You were attacked.
I feel...
Uh-oh.
She threw up.
I feel dizzy.
I have something that might make you feel better.
At least for a while.
Maybe antidote?
You should take this.
Her tummy is going crazy.
Thanks.
I think that actually helped.
Oh, I'm so rude.
What's your name?
Give her a bullet.
Here, ma'am.
I think this is.
This might help.
She's all she needs is some pep de obismo.
I'm Mara.
Mara Forest.
Agent Forest.
Don't get it wrong.
Don't get it twisted.
Don't you forget it.
Thanks, Mara.
Damn, woman is tall.
I'm Natalie.
It's Natalie Crowell.
What are you doing here, Mara?
I'm actually looking for your father, for Edward Crowell.
What on earth do you want with father?
you filed a missing persons report didn't you yes I did
you're the one you're who they sent yeah I'm agent Mara
forest but you're so what what about the man I spoke to on
the phone detective Harrison something detective Harrison
James he couldn't make it problem with his car so they sent
you instead yep This is your father's office?
He's not in there.
I've been out here for hours and I haven't heard a sound.
Oh, she obviously has not heard the zombie walking across
the hall.
Be that as it may, I'd still like to take a look inside.
Do you know how to get in?
Crow facts!
Crows remember human faces and sometimes leave you gifts
junk mostly when you feed it.
Yes, I did know that one.
I want to tame a crow.
So if I give Doki Bird some junk, she'll bring me stuff too?
How do I get in?
That's going to be difficult.
You'll need the key.
It's a big fancy gold one.
Gold key.
Got it.
And you'll have to turn off the electrified door handle.
How do I do that?
No idea.
It wasn't electrified the last time I was here.
Father must have only recently had it installed.
Does she remember your face?
I hope so.
Why?
What's he hiding in there?
Interesting.
Large med kit.
Let's go!
And what is this?
Chrome moved the electric battery charger to the southeast
underground level.
I know that means you won't have access to it anymore.
I think that was the idea.
hear like the buzzing of the thing is like me like this
you're supposed to be able to do this with the bad with the
bad guys right locker the door stuff oh boy it's nice what
about the there was another locker I saw um Some mobs and
stuff.
What's over here?
Oh!
I think this is where we came in earlier, no?
Yes!
Okay, cool.
I see him twitching up there.
You see that guy?
He's spawning.
He's camping the...
What's it called?
The locker.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm stuck.
I want to get this locker too.
We'll just do that.
Kick it!
Oh, wait, no!
I can't tell what's in these ones.
They're like bottles or something, but...
D-Pike, park operations.
That don't seem very good.
Um, Mr. Pike, are you okay?
Oh, shit, he's dead.
Whoa!
Rufus!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gift, and thank
you!
I guess he shot himself.
Should I call the police?
There's a handgun laying next to him.
I better not touch it.
Or I could take that.
Maybe she just has to kick it real good.
Kick it good.
Who is- is that your wife?
No.
Is this an alt?
Staff memo.
The following doors are now locked electronically.
Dungeon, Mermaid, Cyclops...
Oh!
Mermaid, Cyclops, Wolf Serpent.
Cryptophilia.
They can only be opened via the dungeon's computer terminal.
Oh, so maybe I can't.
She's single, yeah, I think so.
So it's not like a matter of me opening in this order, I
think.
But I'm going to take a picture of it anyway.
Sorry, I hit my mic with my, with my, uh, my phone.
Filing cabinet, well-organized.
funding for Cosmic Future, and we've halted construction.
He said it was just a temporary delay.
But I could tell when he's lying.
Something is seriously wrong with Edward.
He looks sick.
But at the same time, there's kind of a manic energy in his
eyes.
I asked Tolman about it, but he gave me the silent
treatment.
So whatever it is, I think they're in on it together.
I tried to spy on Edward and Tolman during their meeting.
It sounded like they were trying to talk to someone, a third
person in the room who wasn't talking back.
They were talking, like how you talk to a baby or a young
child, speaking slowly, using simple language.
What is going on?
There's a videotape.
This is a message for Edward Crowe from Douglas Pike.
Edward, we've been friends for over 30 years.
You entrusted me with the running of your theme park, a task
I have relished.
Hmm, relish.
You have always shown me kindness and always paid me well
for my work.
However, I can no longer remain silent.
Edward Crowe, your crimes have not gone unnoticed.
Peckled it.
Nor will your sins go unpunished.
As for Elaine Marshall, I hope she never forgives us.
For none of us deserve it.
Goodbye.
That's the end.
Kind of feel bad for him.
What's this over here?
Staff memo.
Damn, he's got...
How many pictures of his wife in a bikini?
Does he need...
Really getting that...
Those brain juices flowing, huh?
It's just sick.
Oh my god.
It's a wonder he died.
It's a wonder that he shot himself because he's just like,
Oh, my wife, my wife.
Maybe she's dead too though.
That would be pretty bad.
Edward had his office door electrified.
Decently high voltage too.
I turned off all the main power, but the door was still
electrified.
to a generator somewhere in the underground level is it
different from you and your oci come on i want you guys to
do this i want you guys to have photo frames of me all over
your office i'll put on a bikini if i have to actually my
mama is already miami mama has already drawn me in a bikini
so are you saying you don't have a lot of similar pictures
of your wives
yeah just have lots of framed photos of me in a bikini It's
a model of the Crow Country Park.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let me read that again.
It looks like there are four main areas and a few smaller
sections around the outside.
I'll take that.
Oh, my God.
There's four.
Oh, I was wondering what that is.
That's the blood.
Oh, my God.
Down payment for Minto bikini calendar.
I've only...
Yeah, no one sooner.
I would have made one for 2026.
We have her blessing.
Room review stream with...
I was thinking of doing another one recently, actually.
Maybe we can do one next week.
I'll put it in my calendar.
No one check it out.
You guys should have all clean rooms for the new year,
right?
So I feel like it would be good to do one next week.
Maybe.
Uh, wait.
Wait.
It.
Oh,
here we go.
Not all day.
There we go.
Okay, save.
Okay.
Yeah, about that.
You still have time!
Alright.
So we went in this room.
Do you think this thing is still...
actively patrolling?
I think so.
Okay, well we have that shortcut.
That led to...
Oh, this was the crypt room.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, what about this one?
Kick it!
Nothing.
Dang.
I read this.
Panel of the wooden crowhouse.
I don't even know where a crowhouse is.
My contributions were the mid-vikini calendar.
Hahaha.
Crow house.
What do the circles mean?
Does that mean that there's a puzzle that I have to solve?
I don't quite... Oh, wait.
What's this?
Is this a map?
Eastern utility quarters.
I'll take that.
Yes, indeed.
What is this?
Fatal error.
Elevator?
Oh, I don't want to do that.
Nothing happened.
Must be broken.
Okay, good.
She's gone.
And her throw-up is still here.
Nasty.
Um.
Did I open this one too?
Let's try it.
The fairy.
It's the fairy.
She's facing the other way.
Interesting.
Uh.
There's so many memos!
Can someone from maintenance please varnish the ocean
kingdom storage room door or else just replace the door
entirely?
It's made from really old wood and it's starting to crumble.
It's not exactly fire safe.
Oh, gridded!
Yeah, she didn't even clean up after herself.
You know what, though?
I think there's blood everywhere.
I don't think you need to.
This looks like a little stage.
There's a button.
Not working?
I think the curtain has to be fully raised first.
Oh, I see.
And then there's this part.
Pully.
Oh, okay, wait.
I think I want to go save real quick before we...
Because I've done quite a bit and explored quite a bit.
So I want to...
Run past our friend here.
Savings for quitters?
I don't care.
I'm a quitter then.
We've done so much, I don't want to do it all again.
I mean, it's really just a lot of reading, but you know what
I mean.
Oh my god!
Officer!
Excuse me, Miss.
You really shouldn't be wandering around here.
Why not?
It's not safe.
Would you like to?
me to escort you out?
Are you a police officer?
Police detective Harrison James.
I was supposed to be here hours ago, but some kind of some
kid broke into my car this morning.
Little punk slashed my tires, too.
It is Leonia.
They look okay to me.
No, they slashed my car tires.
I had to borrow the bike because I couldn't use my car.
Oh, right.
Duh.
I didn't catch your name.
Oh, right.
Sorry.
I'm Mara.
Aha.
So that's your car out front?
The 85 Fiesta?
Yeah.
How did you know?
Wait, how old were...
We're old enough to drive, I suppose.
I met your boyfriend.
He said he was waiting for you.
Oh, my God.
He's not my...
Never mind.
It doesn't matter.
matter.
You're blushing.
I just met this man!
No, I'm not.
Shut up.
Actually, Mara, maybe you can help me.
Wait, what if we didn't kill the creature out here?
Would we never see him?
Would he have killed the creature for us?
Did I do work for nothing?
Mara, maybe you can help me.
I was supposed to meet up with a woman.
A Miss Natalie Crow.
You haven't seen her around, have you?
Uh, as far as I know, she's early 20s, blonde hair.
I don't see why we wouldn't want to tell him.
Maybe he is the creature.
I think so.
I don't see why we wouldn't want to tell him.
Is it a snitch?
I don't know.
Can we trust him?
I think this music makes me feel like I can trust him.
This is like hymnbo music and all.
So one of my favorite games in last year, I'm happy to see
you playing Happy New Year, and I'm looking forward to
another year of fun streams.
Suki!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much for this over time!
You did tell her that you're a replacement for him.
That's true.
Well, we won't tell him then, you're right.
I thought I'd ask just in case.
I need to go find Miss Crowe, but I'm going to ask you to go
back to your car, okay?
It's not safe here.
You need to go home.
I agree.
Sure, I was just on my way out, more or less.
Glad to hear it.
You'll be safe now, okay?
I really didn't think he was going to show up.
Oh my, wait.
Phone is ringing.
Moshi Moshi.
Listen.
I had no idea what the roots were for.
How could I have known?
What roots?
What are you talking about?
There are seven in total.
And I cut them down.
Cut them open.
You cut them open?
What?
All but one.
We left one intact.
For prosperity, we thought.
What a farce.
He's gone.
Well, I guess it was a good thing we did come out here.
I just realized, or rather I remembered, that we can get
more ammo from our car anytime.
So if I do run out, we can just go grab some more.
Which, how much am I at right now?
15?
Not bad.
I think we're okay for right now.
These birds are persistent.
Just trying to eat whatever the heck this is.
I wonder how this guy is doing out here, though.
Wait, how do I...
Where did I come in from?
Oh, over here.
I didn't recognize it because I didn't know that I could
turn the camera at the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what's this?
Board of ticket prices.
This place used to be fairly popular with locals.
Crow...
Country.
Can I open this?
Oh, I already searched it, just kidding.
Let's go see how our buddy's doing.
Our boyfriend.
Alleged boyfriend.
Oh, he's so polite.
Hello.
How are you doing?
I'm okay.
Checking in on a friend.
Talk to Arthur when he's waiting in the car.
You get an achievement for it.
You can be honest.
Your leg hurts pretty bad, right?
Yeah, it's throbbing.
It feels weird.
And you have a headache and some kind of...
And feel kind of queasy?
How did you know?
I think that hurt you.
It hurt me too.
but still do i need to go to the hospital i yes i think you
should go anyway mara just sit tight all right you'll be
safe in the car
i think um what the heck is that sound
you hear that's creepy i think uh oh
the security camera is moving Someone is monitoring us.
It's quick too.
Yeah, it's quick.
Crazy.
Okay.
So it was kind of cool.
So something about the crow...
There was like a panel, etc.
Or maybe here.
To operate the crow.
Press it.
Whoa.
Control panel.
Crow walking sequence.
Let's see the other side.
Crow turntable control.
Okay, so DJ.
Oh, we can control which way he walks.
Go!
Nothing happened.
I think it's out of power.
Dang.
Wait, but he can turn.
Hmm.
Okay.
Is this person still over here?
Absolutely.
How are there just people walking around?
But there's also monsters.
Um.
But now that I remember that I can get stuff out of my bag.
Or my trunk, I mean.
Shotgun shells.
And.
Nice.
Where were we?
We were in here.
And we went through here.
Which I'm guessing.
This also opened up.
Which one was this?
Cage.
So let's try cage.
See?
Hmm.
They look like monsters to you.
What do you mean?
Oh, there's a mushroom.
I'm a little mushroom boy.
I'll use my mushroom magic to grant you a wish.
Tell me, what is it that you wish?
Uh...
What's that?
You want to improve the range of your flamethrower?
To each their own.
Wait, I don't have a flamethrower.
Wait, get the wish.
Wait, if I don't have...
Wait.
I don't have a flamethrower.
If I get one, will it still be?
Wait, you don't even have a flamethrower.
No wish for you.
Rude?
Okay, there was one other thing.
It was this one.
Fade.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
Okie dokie.
Well, um, only the one had the room so I guess we've
completed everything else besides this the mouth has a hole
but we won't put our hand in it crow fact a crow will
attempt to clean a trusted person's eyelashes with their
beak and get deeply insulted if they get rejected
well it guys
the bike is here I think we need to go back in here oh
my god did it get bigger did you grow wait what's this a
letter i miss this ah the courthouse of atlanta final
warning dear mr crow we sent you a letter 14 days ago and
i'm not heard back this is a serious matter that demands
your immediate attention you should know that Elaine
Marshall's family have appointed a lawyer.
Saul!
They called Saul!
The case against you is being prepared as I write this
letter.
Rout roll.
Wait, there was the bike, but there is no police officer.
Where did this go again?
Oh, to the...
We could try this because I saved, so...
Let's open.
Pull it?
Pull it again?
Okay, Mara, come on.
Mara, don't be like that girl.
Is it just him?
There's an alien baby in the audience tonight.
I thought he was looking at me.
I think he's infatuated with her.
Mara, you're a...
girl.
I think you need to use both hands.
Ma'am?
Oh!
Wait, I don't like that.
I thought I was gonna start the show.
That was one of my bullets.
Okay, reload.
She's facing the other way.
She looks so beautiful!
Okay, I think I gotta go down.
Oh my god, it's scaring me that thing.
I don't think I see anything else out there, though.
Just him.
Hopefully not.
I see some ammo, though.
Green woman.
Itachi!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I don't think he's a baddie.
I think I see the baddie down there.
Oh my god, and a phone ringing.
Shoot.
Now.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Okay, there is more than one for sure.
I see the other one.
Uh, where's the phone?
Let's just walk over that guy.
Hello?
Moshe, moshe.
The first guest emerged from the pool two years ago.
ago i've been thinking it must have been on purpose the
timing i mean two years ago 1988 it must have been some sort
of intersection a critical pivoting point if you will late
enough that we've developed the necessary infrastructure
early enough that we've well early enough so as to not be
too late This guy is talking in riddles.
Quit being so weird.
I'm going to kill these guys because they run at you and
they scare me.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, he doesn't run.
I think I got him, though.
The other guy ran at me.
Funky.
Funky little critters.
20 months.
Thank you, gentlebred man!
Thank you!
I noticed the seven seas mermaids use the same kind of
battery as the giant crow.
Not a great idea.
Those kinds of batteries aren't waterproof.
Those mermaids are going to need constant maintenance.
Walking stick.
No, like take...
Take...
Nobody needed to use that stick.
Why didn't you just take it out?
Hello?
Wait, so is this guy alive, or?
I don't think so.
Okay, there's some bullets here.
What is this?
Yeah.
Alright, what we got going on around here?
Trash can?
Apple.
A lot of apples here.
Very health-conscious people, huh?
It's the fairy.
Hello, thank you for helping me before.
I'd never have found that bronze key without you.
She's so cute.
Mara's kind of cute.
I thought I saw other ammo, but I was wrong.
Antidove.
This game does have a cool vibe, right?
I still don't know what this is.
You know what?
Let's check it out.
Tank of gasoline.
Oh, I wonder if I can, like, set this down and then have,
like, a portable explosion.
Very cool.
Did somebody kill it?
Or did it just die?
Me?
Wait, I...
Was that not my...
Wait, where'd this guy go?
Wait, did I...
Wait.
Oh god.
It's... I don't...
Well, it's dead.
I suppose that's all there is to say.
A valve.
Turn it?
Oh my god, cute!
She kicks her legs!
The more new rooms you explore, the more phone calls you
get.
The more dangerous the old rooms become.
Good luck.
Oh.
Freaky.
I don't know how I feel about that.
The kikis are so cute!
Where are we anyway?
I'm trying to think of what we need to do.
I guess we can go back to the crypt.
Oh, we went through the haunted manor, that's right.
So let's go!
Let's see where this leads to, first of all.
I think this is the theater.
Yes.
Let me know if you guys want me to like move anywhere
because I'm blocking too much.
I can like kind of actually I might like just do like a
little like that just a little bit more.
Hmm.
Minky should be bigger.
Move closer?
Sounds like a cat purring.
There we go.
Could you please move into our homes?
I mean, I could haunt your home.
It ain't not...
Mlem!
You want a mlem?
Thank you so much for the...
How can I...
How can I deny the people what they want?
If you want a mlem...
I can...
Okay.
Back to game.
Back to regular...
schedule the programming.
I think I'll have to go get some...
What's it called soon though?
Okay, let's go back to the crypt.
I will need to go get some water, I mean, is what I was
trying to say.
I don't like that I have to press to go down the stairs.
That part annoys me.
Just a tiny bit.
What's my gun looking at?
This door.
Oh,
he just smaller.
Moki-doki.
Let's leave here.
And we have his bike.
We do not have the police officer.
Maybe he's in the crypt.
Ooh!
Something's aiming at.
aiming at me.
What is that?
Is that a person?
Is it gonna shoot?
I better not touch it.
The clock.
Um.
Ah.
Hakiba Olaf.
Gravestone.
Solina.
1805.
1872.
Estelle.
1898, 1938.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to do that.
Solomon Weaselby.
1855, 1909.
Norbert Easley.
Okay, it's a drain.
Not working.
The whole place will probably be flooded soon.
Okay.
the notes said about this room.
Here lies Ophelia, tragically drowned.
Sister, daughter, sister, human.
Most efficient alarm clock.
Uh...
Small tank of gasoline?
I'll take it.
It's pointing the shotgun at me!
Is there anything else?
What's that?
Medkit, I'll take it.
Oh wait, what's this over here?
If any of the kids have trouble disabling the trap, you can
offer the advice.
When reading the gravestones, focus on the NAMS.
The birth dates and death dates aren't any use to you for
now.
Look at the center.
Look at the floor in the center of the room.
I wish we could just take the shotgun.
Is this supposed to be West?
Because he's Wish-O-B?
Or is it south?
Maybe.
Southwest?
Which one would be southwest?
That way.
You are.
I can't read it from the back.
Okay.
Mara, come on.
You're east.
Actually, that's perfect.
I'm gaming.
South.
Okay.
Northeast.
Oh,
I stopped it.
I don't think it's going to shoot me.
Maybe I could just...
Maybe I could use it.
Yoink.
It's stuck.
I'm going to rip off this guy's arm.
It broke!
I guess it was just a plastic decoration.
Oh, they're teasing us hardcore.
What if there's not a shot?
gun at all in this game.
Banana peel.
That does not look like a banana peel.
I'll say that.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say that was a fun puzzle!
Oh, my god.
Oh, shoot.
Ugh.
I do not like you.
Oh, my god.
Boss.
There's actual bosses in this game.
Wait, that was my exit.
It opened when I disabled the trap, but when the brick wall
was broken, it got pushed closed again.
Oh, it won't budge.
There must be something I can do.
Handle?
Pull it?
Oh, okay.
I broke it.
Interesting.
Mayamo.
Where are we?
Utility corridor.
Wait, but there's a save in here it seems.
Is this a safe room?
Oh, it is!
Staring into the flames, I feel something.
Yeah!
handwritten letter hey Ed what's been going on finally set
up the address you can use to send me the ore if you label
the contents as samples of geological interest we can pass
it off as an academic research thing I'll collect the
shipments once a week and take them back up into the mine
hold on to your hat we're about to become the luckiest gold
miners since 1848 Yorika!
Love Marv.
Our tips here.
I left the shotgun.
There is a shotgun.
I left the shotgun in the submarine.
Shark, shark, shark, shark, dolphin.
At least I think that's the quickest way.
I was never that good at math.
Wait.
Oh, I'm taking a photo of this.
Why do I keep dropping my phone today?
Shark.
a picture shark shark shark shark dolphin write that down
write that down except i can take a photo field trips gather
the kids in a group outside the haunted manor choose the
older kid get them to ring the doorbell nothing will happen
laughter ensues then choose a younger kid and have them try
quietly tell them them the secret so they can get the door
to open.
Impressed gasps ensue.
The secret is to ring the bell a specific number... Oh.
I'm too smart for your tricks, for your tips.
Glossy magazine.
My ultimate...
Oh, look at the ladies on the wall.
Barf.
No, thanks.
Mara doesn't know what's good.
Watch out for chandelier traps hanging from the ceiling.
So what?
I've never seen the gas one either.
This is the staff memos.
Okay.
I feel like we should probably go back over those a little
bit to see what I have missed.
I'm in the machine room.
They're just processing gold.
There's gold.
Oh my god.
There's a bunch of rocks in a funnel at the top.
Wait, it's...
No.
It's making fake gold ore.
Right?
Yeah, it's the reverse.
This is coming out.
Wait, what's this?
Small tank of gasoline, I'll take it.
And then they put in the pieces, and then they make it look
like gold ore.
Scared.
Come factory!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I think it's grinding up the golden tubes.
Kind of reminds me of a mortar and pestle.
That's fun.
That's very funny.
I like to resave after I've collected things.
So, um...
Down this hallway, there's another thing.
There's a room to the left.
And then this fatal error elevator.
And whatever's down here.
This sounds like...
I don't... I don't know.
A vent?
Is there something inside?
Wait, is it this door that's going?
The sound design in this game is a little awkward.
There's a book.
Tombstone.
Tom B.
Stone.
The year Solina died.
Looks very well read.
Is it some kind of clue?
Solina.
Didn't I say that name somewhere else just a minute ago?
I did.
Wasn't it in the crypt?
Wait, the year Solina died.
Oh.
Wait, this is the lady knocking, no?
No.
Wait.
Oh.
Yes, it is.
I thought it was a monster.
Hey, how did you get inside?
I went through the crypt.
There was this tombstone puzzle and a shotgun and a sticking
clock.
Okay, I didn't ask for your life story.
Sorry.
I'm just kidding.
You did get all right.
Now there's work to be done.
Oh, she's like judging.
Wait, the year Solina died.
So we gotta go back to the crypt, right?
Which one is Solina?
Oh!
1872, everybody.
I'm just taking pictures of everything.
1872.
I feel like I've seen another...
Hadlock somewhere.
We'll talk to her in a second.
A cell?
Why is there a jail cell in, though?
There's no question.
What's your usual Taco Bell order?
I'm planning on getting some tonight.
Golden Foxy.
Um, I pick between three things.
One, the five-layer burrito.
Two, the crunch wrap.
Or three, I get two hard shell tacos.
with beans instead of meat and sour cream yeah
those are my three orders
oh that I stretch okay it's a notebook Tolman's records
March 24th 1988 boss and I have to have the store room
converted into a holding cell Pike isn't happy about it he
says can't legally hold people here even if they've
committed a crime within the park i tell him it's not for
criminals oh my gosh you guys don't need to be doing your
business at the park
every taco bell is about to run out of crunch raft now no
they are they are they are pretty good though no boss brings
the guest up here locks it in the cell he wants to run some
tests.
He says it will be much quicker if he doesn't have to travel
down to the lab each time.
I think it is a very bad idea to bring the guest up to the
surface, especially while the park is still open.
So the elevator there goes to the lab, eh?
I see.
Almost immediately, I am proven right.
A girl named Elaine Marshall finds her way into the holding
cell and encourages the, oh no, sorry, encounters the guest.
She's encouraging him.
She's egging him on.
she's like the brecky crunch trap is pretty i've never had
that one
boss metal gear mentioned wait why is elaine up here in the
cell though that's what i have to wonder it sounds like she
is in an area that she shouldn't be in boss is forced to
close the park i fear this is not the end but the beginning
so that's what happened to her it can be unlocked the switch
under the under that floor panel what oh this one
the cell door unlocked simple as simple as simple as that
and that's oh oops sorry my bad uh let's do ouchy an
antidote uh anything oh i'll take that
It's a bed.
It smells strongly of bleach.
Oh, a large medkin.
It pays to explore.
Does the guests need to use the restroom?
Maybe it does.
All right, let's go talk to our friend over here.
What are you doing?
Miss Julie here.
Yeah, I think this is the best spot.
The best spot for what?
I assume he uses that elevator.
So he'll see it for sure.
Are you talking about Edward Crow?
Yeah.
Hey, would you help me out with something?
Sure.
What do you need me to do?
I need to clear off these tables and then lie out some
documents.
Are you asking me to take these naughty magazines?
Oh my gosh, are you asking me to like take them off your
hands and, you know, store them somewhere?
I think I could do...
Oh my gosh, it's a big ask, but, you know, I'll handle it.
I'll be the bigger person here, and I'll handle all these
dirty adult magazines.
No worries, these thin books?
I can take care of it.
Don't you worry.
Her music is so nice.
I need to clear off these tables and then lay out some of
the documents.
It won't take a minute.
Minto is so generous I know Where'd all the stuff go?
What'd we do with it, Julie?
Julie, what'd you do with it?
That'll do it.
Thanks for the help.
That takes care of that.
Hopefully he'll see it.
While I'm here, I'm going to take a look at the cell.
Did you go in it?
Yeah, there's not much to see.
Fair enough.
Well, catch you later.
Stay out of trouble, alright?
Is she really in there?
Oh, she is.
What do you think?
Well, here we are.
The incident that closed down Crow Country.
It happened right here.
The bite of 87.
Did you notice?
It's been deep cleaned.
Of course, that in itself is a form of evidence.
You mean the fact that they had this room cleaned?
The bite of 67.
It's proof that something happened?
thing they want to cover up right no smoke without fire as
they say no bleach without blood oh my gosh if you guys
bleach your clothes evidence oh that's good I'm gonna start
saying that it's okay you don't need to stay I'm sure you
have places to be right you're looking for Edward Crow
aren't you do you know where he is i want to get into his
office it's in the northeast corner of the park i think
northeast sounds like you need to pass through the haunted
manor right thanks julie which we did we're maybe we've gone
a little out of order i think it sounds like they wanted me
to go into the crypt oh before going into um into the
haunted manor we went a little backwards but
Bleach is so harsh on materials.
Yeah, it's a newspaper.
The Atlanta Globe.
Incident at the local theme park.
Oh my gosh.
How sassy are they going to be?
Parents, Luke and Patricia Marshall decided to take their
daughter Elaine to a local theme park for her 15th birthday.
She was 15!
Okay, I'm sorry.
She's old enough to know not to go into the back rooms of a
theme park.
15 I thought she was like six or seven
it's like come on you should know not to go oh my god I
didn't mean to say seven or eight I thought she was six or
eight you know what I let's take a break I'm gonna go get
some water I'll be right back I'll let you guys get it out
of your systems like your like your kindergarten children
i'll be right back
i'm back that.
I got a cough drop too.
These ones are crazy.
These cough drops are insane because they literally I didn't
know that you could get this over the counter.
They numb your throat.
they numb your mouth basically.
I was like is this allowed?
What What flavor?
Uh, their Vix Vapo Cool Severe Intense Pain Relief.
Soothes and Numb Sores Throats.
Icy Mint!
It's an icy mint flavor.
It has menthol and benzocaine in it.
Crazy.
First time I tried it, I didn't know that it would numb me.
Okay.
All right.
Curl Country, named for its owner, one Edward Curl, is a
small amusement park found only a few miles southeast of
Atlanta.
It's fair to say that it's been fairly popular with locals,
but never really drew in the big crowds of some of its
larger competitors.
This person is so shady.
Oh my gosh, how is that relevant?
The Marshall family were walking through the haunted hilltop
section of the park when Elaine became separated from her
parents.
Around half an hour later, Elaine reappeared.
She was visibly very upset and had a patch of blood marked.
And a patch of blood marked the front of her t-shirt.
It seems Elaine had wandered into a restricted section of
the park and encountered something or someone very
dangerous.
Yeah, a restricted section of the park where you should not
have been, 15-year-old Elaine.
Like, what the hell?
Why are we...
I'm sorry, we're supposed to protect her?
Rage-baiting.
I seriously feel like it.
Yesterday, Atlanta Central Radio got a direct quote from
Elaine herself speaking from her ward at Westview Hospital.
There was a man in a cage.
Okay, that does sound pretty bad.
I'm not going to lie.
She's so cute.
It's a photo.
She's cute.
La la la.
I'm Elaine.
I go into restricted areas.
Medical report.
Elaine Marshall.
Injuries.
Wound across the stomach and chest, not healing due to a
bacterial infection.
Attempts to identify the nature of the bacteria are still
ongoing.
Suspected cause of injury.
Attacked by a wild animal.
Unsubstantiated claim by the patient that she was attacked
by a person.
Are you enjoying this game more than expected, Minky?
enjoying it don't don't yeah I'm definitely enjoying it I
want to say more than expected I was always curious about
the plot I think it has a little more humor than I expected
which I always am I'm always a big fan of and gameplay wise
it doesn't seem it seems pretty forgiving so I'm so far I'm
not I'm not struggling or anything treatment ongoing
treatment of bacterial infection currently no improvement
shown notes patient also complains of ongoing headaches and
queasiness oh no she needs the she needs the antidote
further treatment pending legal agreement between Marshall
family and a third-party financier mm-hmm decent amount of
levity yeah
business card Julie Baron locally feared lawsuit attorney
better call Baron
404 555 0129 I'm going to change my phone number to that.
Wait, one second?
Uh, one second?
Okay.
404 numbers are a little hard to come by.
Are they?
Why is that?
Did they use them all up?
Uh, did I read this one?
Yeah, the chandelier traps.
Okay.
after.
404.
Oh, not found.
It's a bottle containing antidote.
Wait, I can't contain.
Oh, oh, I can't carry anymore.
What do I have?
Oh, I have five.
You can only carry five of each.
Okay.
The year Solina died.
Wait, there's a safe right here.
I just noticed this.
Hold on.
I'm gonna, I took a picture Dodd.
1872?
Oh.
I messed it up.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
There is a big red arrow, isn't there?
The crank handle!
What was this for?
Oh, took the crank handle.
Wait, what was it?
Hold on.
Let's go look at the staff memos again.
Wait.
Is there a memo here?
Do I need to get rid of this?
Wait, I think I can go around.
A reminder that the piano in the haunted manor is not to be
used for casual playing is wired up to the walls and the
whole system is pretty fragile.
If you're not haunted manor staff leave.
These are all stuff I think I really went in the wrong
order.
This has the staff memos.
Okay.
Oh, so to get to Tolman's office is the fairy pond.
So that's the area that I went to, maybe.
So we still have the Swan puzzle.
Dixite access is in that cute little house.
So there's a keyhole in the mailbox.
We did this one.
Uh...
Which wood has the trident?
Which we need to get in there.
We don't... We are not able to get in there yet.
Eggs are going missing.
We need a thing that looks like an egg.
Railway room.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the dungeon.
Oh, that's right!
The railway... Railway room and the dungeon.
Yes, yes.
We've seen both of those now.
I wonder if I read the book titles, I wonder what it is.
I think we can try the grenade, but I really don't think
it's a...
Game is meant to be pretty open, so playthrough looks pretty
different.
You can do a lot of puzzles out of order.
You are doing great.
Thank you, first time!
Thank you!
Here we go.
If you're doing maintenance in the haunted manner or trying
to access Ocean King you'll need the crank handle.
Which we got.
Maintenance in the haunted manner.
What did I need the crank handle in the haunted manner for?
Oh, wait.
Maybe that devil?
Trying to access Ocean Kingdom.
Oh, the clocks!
That's right!
They say don't touch the clocks unless you have the proper
stuff, which we do now, so...
Oh!
Hello.
Goodbye.
Oh!
Just gonna...
Sorry.
Oh my goodness.
345.
There's a hole in the middle of the clock face.
A crank can be turned left or right.
Was there a time I needed to crank it to?
240?
I don't know.
Ah, this one too!
Boy, I want to see what this is.
History is deadliest poisons.
Leave it.
History is deadliest po- Leave it!
A swift and sudden end.
I'm so curious.
Leave it.
OT Plegis.
Save and try it.
I know.
I did just save before I came in here.
Oh my god.
Eh.
I wanted to go.
go back to see the...
The what's it called?
Oh wait!
1020 and 1115.
This one definitely went to 1020.
1020.
There we go!
Eww!
Large gemstone.
This is for the swan!
Yeah!
We got it!
Okay, okay, nice.
Which, um, let's see.
If we...
We're at the haunted manor.
If we go through the theater...
We're at the haunted manor right there.
If we go through the theater, we can get to the swan boat.
I believe.
that way we avoid some stuff we'll go that way then well
actually I can't tell which would be faster actually they're
actually maybe about the same aren't they yeah fairy town is
kind of full of enemies I would be good cleaning up very
well.
Main halls are faster, but full of enemies.
We'll just go through here then.
Oh, just kidding.
Wrong way.
Good boy.
You say something?
Silly?
I wonder if there's still guys in here.
I do wonder, though, if, uh...
Let's see.
I go out.
I don't know.
It might have actually been...
Maybe we're okay.
Maybe it's fine.
We just gotta leave and go to the left.
To the left.
Oh my god.
I can't see.
Where am I?
Out!
Here?
Yes.
Oh my god.
There's things in here too though.
Okay, yeah, I gotta.
Oh, there we go.
Caution!
We're fine.
You're just stocking up on enemies for the maximum numbers
of fatalities you achieve for grenades.
Of course!
No shame and efficiency.
That's exactly what I've been doing.
Of course!
I feel like a grenade would have worked just for me.
perfectly fine for this puzzle.
Just saying.
The lay has turned green.
Turn the wheel.
I think I'm going the wrong way.
We needed to come to us, right?
So we can get the chain.
Let's get that grody chin off your neck.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I got the chin.
I did.
I hope there wasn't anything else in there that I needed.
The music sounds so funny.
It's like too whimsical.
Um, alright.
The hatchlings are motherless.
I think they'll be okay.
It still says that there's something in the theater we need
to do.
Interesting.
But, um...
Let's go to the train room.
And we shall save.
Holy cow.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I hate that it switches the camera on me when I exit a room.
I probably should have saved a different file, but that's
okay.
My condition is okay.
Now let's get the...
Thing.
No, no, not you.
The Book of Staff, Memo.
Hmm.
I have to father them now.
It's me.
I am the father.
Something about this chain.
Oh!
The machine chain.
Which machine chain, though?
I wish it would tell me where.
The machine chain for where, though.
was there anything else um which wood we still got to get
into there's a room you haven't been to yet I mean there's a
couple rooms that one right there the swan boat one
the one across from swan boat
I gotta go back up there
I guess I don't even think I tried it seem like i did all
right let's try
oh whoops wrong button i
hear more oh oh my gosh i keep pressing the wrong button so
sorry there we go all right so i go in here it's to the
right right
yes oh i did it again Oh my gosh, what's wrong with me?
I think I should...
Um, maybe...
Wait, uh, throw a grenade.
Oh, run away.
Oh, well I killed something.
Oh!
Ah!
Ouch!
Good.
I'm trying to...
zip around him.
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
Aim, don't go.
Hey, I'm on a controller, okay?
Give me some...
Give me some grace here.
Oh, here...
Little house.
It's locked.
There's no keyhole.
What about the post-op?
Oh, here we go.
Ah, okay, okay.
Okay.
Good thing I'm not getting any taller.
Oh, that's sick.
If you can't find the crank handle, it's because I borrowed
it.
I use it to hide that big egg-shaped ruby inside the haunted
manor.
Afterwards, I locked the crank handle in a safe in the
southeast utility corner.
I see.
Mounted weapon.
There's a valve on the top.
I see.
I think it's low on view.
It puts the lotion on its skin or else it gets the hauls
again!
Tolman's Records, June 3rd, 1986.
We hired a company to start excavating.
It didn't go to plan.
Problem one, they spent too long setting up the site.
Problem two, there was already a paper trail forming.
The whole point was to do this quickly and quietly.
Then the deal breaker.
They started asking questions about the roots.
Comfy mochi.
Welcome to a bamboo ship.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Welcome, welcome.
They wanted to know the full size and shape of the thing
they were excavating.
They wanted to know what it was made of.
They wanted to know how long it had been there.
Uh-oh.
They were asking questions.
questions.
No deal, obviously.
They had to go.
Okay.
Where do I put the crank in?
Oh, here?
There's a wheel?
The mechanism is incomplete.
That doesn't work.
Uh, oh.
This?
Ah!
Something is holding onto the chain.
Wishbone!
Welcome back, thank you!
your enemies have more health than smaller enemies.
Consider this when making decisions about which ones to
fight and which weapons to use.
Thank you.
I don't like you saying that.
I don't like you saying that at all.
Grenade in the hole!
I wish...
Oh.
I was gonna say I wish I could figure out how to aim the
grenades.
What's in here?
There's probably a grenade right in this in here.
Oh.
Oh, no.
There's more ammo.
I'll take that.
Smells like gasoline.
But it's almost...
We add gasoline.
We have some.
We have some gas tanks.
It's a good amount of gasoline inside.
Wait.
We don't have a flamethrower.
But...
It calmed down.
there okay what else did I need to be doing here large metal
tank wonder what's
inside the fury if we go talk to the little mushroom guy
again is he gonna be like you have a flamethrower now
there's a I think they do want to say use the grenade you
guys okay do you think this is far enough maybe maybe Okay,
here we go.
One more try.
Try examining the pipes.
It's missing the handle.
Oh, here we go.
The mask!
It's a large block of solid resin.
There's something trapped inside.
Come here.
Did you just give it the hose again?
I think so.
Something hanging.
Take it.
Woeful mask.
Sad guy.
Now we go...
You know, I wish this game had fast travel.
So now we go back to haunted hilltop.
This area is going to be hellish, though.
Yeah, this will get us into the woods, though.
This area is going to be hellish because...
There's, like, some guys over here that are...
That have the big hands.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Leave me alone.
I'm almost tempted to go get...
Ah!
Ew!
Okay, come on.
Ouch!
Oh my god, I'm poisoned.
Ugh.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright, let's put in the mask.
There's the item.
Yippee!
Or maybe, oh wait, let's go save!
Maybe not yippee.
Maybe we're not happy.
Maybe we don't want to go...
The 30th.
That's so strange.
I thought it was following the clock on my computer.
Oh, the camera doing that every time is very terrible.
Oh.
Oh, this seems hellish.
Okay, maybe I...
There's a symbol that looks like a swirl.
I'm not going to kick things just yet.
what the hell what the hell are they making here
oh there's a there's a health kit right behind you
um careful with the ceiling traps oh that's one of them
that's what it looks like I see if I shoot it whoa whoa whoa
Okay, it will only let me interact with this one.
Oh, and okay, so then the things that are eyes go down.
Interesting.
I will take that.
I think, I don't remember what this one was.
I guess it was a star.
The gas trap is what poison...
Yeah, the glowing gas.
trap yeah yeah yeah interesting let's see what's behind here
shotgun shells sure I guess I thought those were footprints
for a second and the I think they're leaves though Abel
yeah I thought these were like they look like see on the
ground they look like like dinosaur dinosaur footprints or
something?
Let's do the swirly again.
That almost got me.
What is that red thing right there?
That almost had me, folks.
Not the eye.
Let's do the star real quick so I can get the stuff in here.
More ammo?
I'll take it!
Oh, it's a bottle!
Oh, thank you.
Alrighty.
What's in there?
Maybe a gasoline tank?
Perhaps?
Oh, that's a grenade.
Are grenades that hard to come across in this game?
I can't imagine these areas being, like, actual theme park.
You know, and maybe that's what's taking me out a little
bit.
I'm like, there is no feasible way that this would work in a
theme park.
Witch's cauldron.
It's full of murky water.
It smells really bad.
It's weirdly warm.
Reach in further.
I can feel something at the bottom.
Grab it.
The Trident!
Oh.
Guys, I don't like that.
How's my health?
We're okay.
Oh my god, that scared me.
You know what?
We can save over.
It's fine.
The grenade.
Is she still in here?
She is.
Okay.
it's the same dialogue as before playing this game our
resident theme park expert is like actually okay let's see
so now I think that should allow us to go to the water area
we still have a thing in the dungeon to do we still have a
thing in the theater to do one second I'm I got
some new contacts lately, and I don't think my eyes like
them, so I will not be using them again.
Um...
The east side of the park.
I'm pretty far into the game.
No way, really?
Let's go.
Looks like it with how you've been...
Have I been squinting a lot?
I'm sorry.
Let's see.
Okay, I'm gonna...
read the things again this okay they were like hey I need um
uh cute little house okay we went in there um we did that
ocean kingdom restaurant trident without it we can't do the
birthday scene monster song so we okay so we got it yeah
find the crank handle we got dog egg in the system the
eggies are going missing with the dog we got to find the
come the security discs do ghosts need glasses yeah I mean I
died needing glasses so it's like the same exact I don't
just magically fix my prescription when I'm a ghost sadly
it's just you know kind of like you know you know how like
when someone dies in a great pain they come back as a ghost
and there's you hear them like you know you'll hear that
like the ghost stories being like and you hear him wailing
because he's reliving his pain like that except i'm not in
pain well sometimes but i'm just wailing because my eyes are
dry
same thing just mine's a little less dramatic
you don't want to be a ghost you guys it's overrated you can
die i mean you will eventually sorry to remind you of your
looming you know mortality but but you know um don't become
a ghost just like you know move onwards so your unfinished
business is not being able to see it could be
will you be there to greet us what do you who do you think i
am mori calliope i'm no grim reaper i'm like the bottom of
the barrel.
I'm a phantom.
I'm just a spirit out here.
I'm like on the lowest of the totem pole here.
Maybe.
If I become so consumed with rage, I could become a demon.
to play more rage games.
The books.
Okay, if you're doing maintenance in the haunted manor and
trying to access Ocean Kingdom, you'll need the crank
handle.
Ocean Kingdom.
So that's where we're trying to go, right?
Depiction of alcohol in the mermaid cage.
It's not an alcohol bottle.
It's a bottle of highly corrosive acid.
Power switch for the four periphery elevators is in
Tollman's office.
Okay, so the other...
Okay, that's what it means by the other side of the park.
Okay, cool.
Piano is a haunted...
Yeah.
I'm just going through all the things.
Clocks need regular winding.
Man, button behind the panel.
Yeah, the crow house.
Yeah, we did that.
Crow moved the electric battery charger to the southeast
underground there.
falling doors are now locked electronically yeah oh we can
get into the ophelia crypt if we can open it oh i did not
realize that okay i forgot about that actually that we had
read that earlier okay how many dang memos are there um this
could be an email varnish the ocean kingdom storage room
door i think we can shoot that Seven Seas, Mermaids use the
same kind of battery as the giant crow.
So I think we have to take the battery from them to them
give it to the crow.
Oh, we jumped from 25 to 34, though.
What was this?
Oh, the trap.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I think we can now go to the ocean area, I suppose, it
seems.
Why do I still have this thing?
Huh.
Oh, no email in 1980.
You know what?
You're so right.
Hayden!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much for the tank, Hampton!
Thank you!
Oh, yeah, I'm so nimble.
Oh, come on.
Where did you come from?
Ah, yeah, blah, blah.
What was that?
What?
Doesn't work?
The crank?
Oh.
This is terrible.
Oh, it's a good thing there's nobody here.
AAAAAAAA!
Go, go!
So it can.
This place is wild!
Why are the crows trying to kill me all of a sudden?
Storage staff only.
Handle is broken.
Won't budge.
Can't think of any way to open it.
Oh, we don't have a...
That's right, we don't have a...
Thing yet.
A map.
Was what the words I'm drawing to say.
Why is there a crow in here?
Are we not indoors?
The sub!
Okay.
This...
Stop it!
Don't let the door hit you on the way out!
For real though.
This place is crazy.
Trash can.
Soda can.
We haven't gotten anything from the trash cans in a bit, I
feel.
Not just me.
Why are there birds in here?
I noticed the acid bottle in the mermaid cage is pretty much
empty.
fill it from the acid tank but I heard Crow moved it down to
the underground level and no I don't know what he's using it
for I didn't ask
Come on give me something good Nothing
Come on why isn't it giving me anything I need more bandages
please Why do they have an acid tank at the theme park Look
Look It's what the kids expect nowadays oh I see those you
you were sneaky huh yeah why is there only trash in the
trash can can I smoke yet big metal door not budging okay
what's here control room golden keyhole the trident does not
work the bronze does not work.
Oh, a map!
Bee!
How many parts of the theme park are there?
There's three, and then like the other smaller areas, right?
Is that what it was?
Because we don't have cosmic future.
Destroy your lungs, Queen.
The Seven Seas.
It's a gas vent.
Fumes are flowing up from a vent in the ground.
Smells awful.
I don't want to go anywhere near it.
Wait, what is this?
It's a bottle containing an antidote.
Okay, look at that.
Sunk in treasure.
In arcade.
I want to find a save point first.
Before we do that.
Oh, come on!
What the hell?
How did you guys get here so fast?
Let's try the submarine.
Surely it's safe in here.
Yeah!
Okay.
We're good now.
Nice.
What else is in here?
Hey, Ed.
How's things?
Got your shipment.
Systems all up and running.
And the important part?
I've lined up a major buyer for the gold.
Is this Playmobile Resident Evil?
Yes.
actually
I had to put on a bit of a show while they visited the site
but I think I got away with it I had a thought about the
rocks you're using for the ore do you think anyone over on
my end would be able to tell it's not Brazilian like they
know it was from Georgia maybe I'm overthinking it I think
so I think they could tell that the rocks are from Georgia
I think they would be able to tell So I wonder if the So the
stuff they've been mining Is like this gold ore That they've
been digging up, right?
How interesting Staff memos Boy, I see you You thought you
were sneaky, eh?
What about this one?
Mid-kit Oh, I got you too Oh, I got you too Video game tips?
Oh, another one.
The shotgun!
The personal effects of Captain Nemo!
Don't bullshit me.
Come on, it won't budge.
Maybe there's a different way to open it.
This button here?
Rules of the sea.
Octopus?
Wait, press the red button to reset your score.
Oh, shark, shark, shark!
Wait.
Shark, shark, shark, shark, shark, dolphin.
Are they zombie rocks?
Because that's a dead giveaway.
We gotta do shark, shark, shark, shark.
I remember.
It's not displaying anything.
Nothing.
What about this one?
It's broken.
Oh, do I have to use my own bullets for this?
Alright.
Shark.
Four sharks and dolphin, I think.
One, two, three.
Okay, shoot the shark four times and then the dolphin.
Uh-oh.
If he'll come back down.
One.
I think the toidal got on the way.
Two.
Hold.
Hold!
Uh...
Oh.
Three!
Four!
And then the dolphin.
Uh, where's my...
Where's my... Oh, there it is.
Uh, uh, I don't trust it.
I can't see.
Uh, oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Hold!
It's like that game friend.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, oops.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Yay!
Shotty time.
There's a bunch of nautical trinkets in here.
And a shotgun.
It looks like a real one.
Oh, my gosh.
We got the shotgun!
Oh, it's showing the...
Some information about dolphins.
Bottle knows dolphins way.
An average of 660 pounds.
They can reach a length of 4 meters or 13 feet.
They can live for more than 40 years.
And finally, they can jump at a height of 20 feet up in the
air.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Okay, so I switch weapons.
How?
Like, oh.
Oh.
We'll stick with the handgun for now, though, since it's
what I'm used to.
All right.
Anything else in here?
I think we're good for now.
Let's go into that really horrible arcade.
Big boy.
Guys, I'm scared.
Guys, it's so...
Oh, there's a person over there!
Holy cow!
Q scared me so much.
Can't carry anymore.
No power.
What's to say?
Some of the kids were complaining that their high scores
weren't being saved.
I guess the machines reset their scores every time we turn
them off?
I don't know if that's supposed to happen.
But I'm not going to fix it.
It gives the kids a reason to keep coming back.
What the damn?
app girl looking pretty cute no power on any of these things
okay it's not that big of a room guys we're okay maybe
control box it's silver keyhole okay
claw machine out of order there's second note behind it what
on earth set the arcade game scores dolphin score should be
twice the mermaid Both score should be twice the dolphin
score.
Shark score should be twice...
I take a photo?
What does that mean?
Some kind of equation.
Please, game, I'm stupid.
You have to understand.
The Atlantic Globe.
August 1988.
Crow Country announces sudden closure.
While its popularity has been on something of a downturn
recently, it's so shady.
There were no public signs of an impending closure for local
theme park Crow Country.
However many angry guests were forcefully turned away as
they showed up to the park yesterday, only to find the gates
closed.
Speculation is rife that this sudden decision has something
to do with the Elaine Marshall incident reported in this
newspaper two weeks ago.
You heard it here first, folks.
In our newspaper two weeks ago.
statement it has nothing to do with the marshal incident
we're just closing for refurbishments but that doesn't line
up with the fact that people had tickets booked for a visit
to the park this week what's going on mr crow breaking news
breaking news
what's going on mr crow what's going on Who are you?
Weird guy.
Could you not point that light in my face?
Oh my god, he actually, like, is blinded.
I've got a wicked headache as it is.
Who are you?
Never seen you before.
I'm Mara.
You can tell she's a reporter because there's a card that
says press in her hat.
Yeah.
Agent Mara Forest.
no shit that's like a girl version of my name what's your
name mark marv i'm mark marvin mara marvin trumble why are
you here are you an employee no but i do work with ed we're
uh business partners
edward crow yeah do you know where he is i was about to ask
you the same question God, and done it, hasn't he?
Done what?
I mean, could we not tell that he has done something because
there are monsters all over the park?
Have you guys also noticed that there's no rides here?
What is this park without any rides?
Nothing.
Suspicious.
Partners?
Which one of them cooks?
Yeah, it's all themed.
They'll ride.
The sub is a ride, maybe.
Hey, so how old are you?
Old enough.
Nice gun, by the way.
What is that?
A browning?
A cult?
Uh, yeah, sure.
Marvin, what kind of work do you do with Crow?
I work overseas normally.
Just came back for a little visit.
been to the southern hemisphere perhaps only crows gone and
disappeared great timing it's a lot like enchanted forest in
Oregon where there's only like two or three rides don't get
me wrong I do love me an amusement park that doesn't have
that you know that doesn't I don't I don't need to go to an
amusement or theme park rather and it have to have rides but
I'm also just kind of like what are do here we had a theater
we had the duck thing the haunted manor you have the the
crypt where you only what like one person can go in at a
time and solve the puzzle it's just anyway pretty sure he's
around here somewhere see I wanted to use the northwest
elevator, but Tollman's prowling around back there.
Tollman?
Yeah, you know, Ed's root excavation guy.
Root, what?
Maybe I'll try the southwest elevator.
That could work.
Wait, the elevators are broken, aren't they?
Ha, that depends.
On what?
Yeah, I think I'd get, I'd better get going.
See you around, Mary.
So Tollman's back there?
Right now, we're in the games arcade.
Okay.
I mean, we've gone through everything that we could so far.
We just got to go forward, I suppose.
The backrooms!
This is the actual backrooms!
It's a photo?
Ooh!
Oh, she's the captain!
The phone.
Large wooden crate.
there open the gate i think we're good where's the phone at
oh here oh my god that thing almost got me look there's the
crow from the other side hello from the other side hello the
worst part is i never really wanted the gold i didn't really
care is this walter white it was my father who He made the
decision to buy the land.
Can't you shoot those boxes?
Yeah, but I want to see if I need to.
Or rather, I'm conserving my bullets.
Years later, when he died, he left all of Crow Country and
my care.
I had no choice but to come back.
Finish what he'd started.
Wait, the theme park originally belonged to your father?
No, that's the guy that stole the sunken tree.
My treasure from the fish and the amazing digital circus.
My treasure, my treasure, my life savings.
No, Crow Country is the name of the land, this land.
Just hung up.
Well now we have a shortcut.
Hold on, I'm gonna grab this map real quick.
Western utility corridors.
Okay, cool.
What we got here?
Staff hallway.
Look at that, you guys.
We've almost filled out the map, I feel.
Pretty cool.
Delivery garage down there, huh?
Okay.
Lounge?
What's the lounge?
Oh, Crow's lounge.
It won't budge.
There's no keyhole either.
There's a sign, but it's blank.
Kick the door!
Oh!
The sign dropped down.
Let the record show that I solved my problem with violence.
Silver keyhole.
Okay, we still don't have a silver key yet.
But, uh, wait.
It was, uh, over here, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, this part.
This...
Is now a shortcut!
Look at that!
Grenade.
Granade.
Can I?
You.
You sucker.
Don't turn your head on me.
There's so many poison things on the ground now.
I will disable this, at least.
Oh my god.
I just noticed the one on the ceiling, too.
No way.
They're evil.
Oh,
I thought something...
I thought I saw something there.
Alright, let's see.
What's our ammo look?
Oh, yeah, we got plenty.
Oh, yeah.
I can't carry anymore now.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm too...
I don't find enough things, maybe.
Okay.
So, staff hallway.
Crow's lounge.
Game.
our kid let's go to the lounge oh
I'm in the wall wait someone's in here wooden panel I can
see it through into the lounge Harrison James is sitting on
the couch he doesn't notice me this is kind of Mara is a
voyeur she said this is That's kind of fun.
Okay, that's enough of that.
The root excavation areas need to stay locked when you're
not using them.
If you need to access them, the switch that unlocks all the
gates is in the break room.
That's in the northwest area.
Northwest underground area.
Oh!
Wait.
Close.
What?
What's over here?
I have not finished my explorations.
Apple Corps.
What is this?
Oh my god.
Wait, there's a diagram!
Wait, this might be better for me, no?
Dude still didn't notice.
He has the survival skills of a rock.
Handwritten letter.
Hey, Ed.
What's up?
The mine has an inspection coming up.
National level.
scary shit I think I think these uh wait Marv yeah these
okay I thought that the letters were from Marv okay yeah
being maxed out on ammo in a survival horror game means
you're doing great I'm glad you're enjoying yeah I'm having
fun thank you someone told me they check the actual minerals
in the ore like they check it's if it's a match for the
local area then someone else told me they don't ever do that
but they will with me because they definitely suspect
something so I had to create so I had to create of rocks and
soil delivered.
Let me know when it gets to you.
I got the contents for free, obviously, but it costs an
absolute freaking fortune to send something so heavy.
But if it means we can fool the inspection, guys...
Marv.
They're doing illegal activities.
Hello.
Hi.
Well, well.
Look who it is.
Mara, you told me you were on your way out.
I got lost.
I'm not stupid, you know.
Did you find Natalie?
No, not yet.
I thought she might be in here, but...
What are you reading?
It's an old book about gold mining.
It's actually really...
Looks boring.
The music is so, like, whimsical.
It's so cute.
Mara, is there something I can help you with?
How are you feeling?
What do you mean?
You're not injured?
You haven't been attacked by anything?
them too.
Those creatures.
Did they attack you?
No, I ran.
Fast as I could.
I thought I was going crazy.
Mara, what are they?
What's going on here?
Do you know something?
Theme of Hymbo.
They look like creatures to you?
No, those, yeah, imagine if it's just like, they look like
creatures to you.
Those are just the, all I see are the patrons of the park.
Harrison, if you're you should probably leave.
Get out of here while you still can.
I can't do that.
I still need to find Natalie.
She might be in danger.
So you're still looking for Natalie?
Where have you looked?
Basically nowhere.
Everywhere I go, doors are locked.
Paths are blocked.
Always seems like I need some kind of weird key.
When you are not the survival horror game protagonist.
It's infuriating.
Oh yeah.
It's that kind of place.
You get the hang of it after a while.
I wish I had a soda vending machine in my room too.
Why?
I mean, I guess it's fun for the novelty, but you'd have to,
like, put in money.
I guess you'd get the money yourself, but you'd also have to
restock it.
Do they stay cold in there?
I don't know.
It says ice cold soda.
Who knows?
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
We could save in here.
Let's do this one.
He's looking really hard in that book.
Poor guy barely noticed me.
All right.
So we have to do something with the arcade.
There's still some other ways that we haven't gone to,
though, when we come back here.
Oh.
Oh, eyes!
Ah!
Oh,
he's gone!
That was fast.
I like how there's like little...
Now that I see them, I see them everywhere.
All these like little ores.
You see them?
All the rocks everywhere.
This is a...
This is not a boss fight, no?
We could try the shotgun, though.
It's big and heavy.
Apparently it belonged to Captain Nemo of the Nautilus
submarine.
one-handed I think she's insane
oh my god wait I don't know how to aim I don't know how to
aim all of a sudden wait hold on one second where is oh I
don't have a laser
squelch squelch squelch squelch squelch squelch how many did
that take though yeah all right right well well um
hey go through this apple four shots oh we looked at this
picture um okay now that the crate's not here my i'm all i'm
all scrambled a little bit okay uh we didn't go this way to
the restaurant this looks gassy wait wait it looks like five
nights of fridays wait before we do that though i will save
because we just killed that guy.
I'm save scumming like a tiny bit.
Wait, wasn't this on the thing outside?
But, well, you're not even looking at it.
It's kind of fun to run back and forth.
Oh!
Oh, nasty.
Oh my god.
I can't deal with you right now.
Wait a second.
Um.
I think we'll go with you.
Okay.
One moment please!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Ew.
One second please.
Please give me a moment.
Oh there's a here too.
Wait, where is the phone?
Are you the phone?
No.
Where's the phone?
Oh, here's the phone.
Hello?
Natalie, my daughter.
She's here, isn't she?
Yes, she's looking for you.
She filed a missing person's report with the police.
I told her not to.
I thought I'd convince her not to.
Listen, can you get her out of here?
Get her to leave now.
Mr. Crow, she's She got hurt.
She was attacked.
I see.
Oh my god.
I was trapped.
There we go.
What is... What are these things?
It's a statue.
Fruit are friends.
Good to know.
I love to hear it.
Oh, there's a little trap there.
I think I will grenade these guys.
Alright, let's do this.
Watch this guys.
Watch this.
Oh my god.
I didn't think you'd scream.
Ouch!
I didn't think I'd scream!
We're fine.
Karma!
Oh wait, this thing was lit up.
There's no keyhole.
Something is holding the lid shut.
not see the ceiling trap gamers don't look up oh my god
think you have more resources than i did at this point in
the game cup is empty oh luscious lime pineapple punch
groovy grape what do you guys want if i had my light on does
that help Lime!
Cup is full, but I don't want to drink it.
We have some Tolman's records here.
Marvin said that Tolman is monitoring the area.
I'm kind of scared.
If I run into him, is he friend or foe, you know?
March 30th.
Boss has begun experiments with the pool.
He attaches a key to a long chain and slowly the lowers it
in he waits 25 seconds and then pulls it out again it's
changed changed too long in some places too short in others
it's the wrong shape the pool the pool you this place is
nasty okay
this one is not the two one oh six probably Yeah, right.
Come in, we're open.
Locked.
But the sign says it's open.
Oh, right.
I'm looking at the back of the sign.
I'm kind of dumb, honestly.
Mara.
I understand her.
That's so funny.
Is this guy?
Oh, yeah, this guy also.
Oh, yeah.
I don't understand this one at all, I think.
Is this guy also?
Oh, wait, there's a memo here.
To management.
Can we get the code for the front door change, please?
It's far too easy to guess.
Is it the factory default or something?
This is a security concern.
Okay, hold on.
So it's 1-2-3-4?
No, why?
Wait, where does this lead to?
We're in...
kingdom
but before we do any of that well let's read this note here
neptune's palace birthdays oh that's right we need the
trident nice first try gamer thank you is mara forest a
peridium event oh my gosh we're both mfers wait this is
Crazy!
No!
Have parents place gifts inside the treasure chest.
During the meal, give the trident to the child.
The sea monsters will turn towards the trident.
When they're facing the trident, they'll sing.
As long as the trident isn't too far away.
If all four are singing, the chest will open.
The sea monsters often get stuck and don't rotate properly.
Just give them a tap and it should set them off.
Oh no.
Uh, I think I have to shoot this.
Oh, I see!
I- oh, uh, that's why it was green.
Okay.
There we go.
It sounds like two of them are going off, but it's only the
one.
How do I get them- all three of them to do it?
Uh.
Err?
Okay, I got two of them.
It sounds like this guy's going off but he's not right.
I think I gotta get them more looking at me.
There we go.
And then this guy gotta get you looking at me.
Turned a little bit more.
Oh!
Oh, that's so close!
Yeah!
Okay.
Is this the silver key?
No way!
We got the silver key!
All right.
There's a little X on the floor?
Oh, you're so right.
It's okay.
We didn't need it.
We're too smart.
We're too good.
I'm curious about this.
The soda machine.
Is it on the map?
There's like a question mark.
I think that's for the soda machine.
Interesting.
The game's arcade, we need power to it.
So we can do the puzzle there.
Fruits are our friends.
Whoa!
Wait, actually what was the order here?
Oh, grape?
Lines?
grape lime, pineapple, strawberry.
Grape, lime, pineapple, strawberry.
Okay, hold on.
Whoa!
Ticket pre-sale times are like- Oh!
Wait.
Mr. Crow keeps extra treasure maps in a wooden bureau in his
lounge.
The code is 8891.
one.
Oh, I think I remember seeing that.
Wait, one second!
I did say that the times would go up.
I don't remember what the times are myself, though.
Let's see.
Oh!
Pre-sale registration for the
um...
It ends January 1st.
Wait, you know what?
I'm just gonna put this up.
If you are interested in going to my 3D live jazz show, oh,
it's so big.
The pre-sale of registration ends on January 1st, and then
the ticket sales start January 2nd, 4 p.m.
Pacific.
are from the third!
I'll mark that down in your calendars!
Don't forget it!
Yes, yes, yes!
Let me retweet this real quick.
So, give me one second.
Retweet.
Okay.
I did too.
what about stream tickets they should be up let me double
check i got yelled at actually they were like um if you have
a question about something like why aren't you asking us and
i was like oh my god steiner tagged me he said at mint
phantom mint this is extremely important at your jazz show
you need to tell people you're really jazzed to be here why
is there a mint chord minus two emote.
What is that?
What is the mint cord minus two?
How often are you guys using that?
Not to me, right?
We use it all the time.
Why did he say that to me?
Why did he tag me?
that ignoring that um oh does is is pre wait no is general
wait wait is pre-sale or general tickets for streaming thank
you who snitched nobody snitched it's because two people
reacted to his to his message i confess i drew that emote
and the plus two version oh well they did not use the plus
two version on his thing.
He said, oof.
No streaming yet.
Okay.
No streaming tickets in the general, everybody.
Not yet.
So please be patient for the streaming tickets.
Thank you for your patience.
Let me say, thank you!
I'll even send Minto heart so that he doesn't feel so
bullied.
Okay, back to game.
8891 in the wooden bureau.
Wait, what was it?
Extra treasure maps.
What kind of treasure are we getting?
8891 everyone.
Is that in his lounge?
What the heck you are the-
It's this thing here.
Why did I sound like a grandma?
I was like, oh!
Map of secrets.
Find the secrets map.
Nothing has changed.
Oh, secrets!
oh there's one in the toilet there's two in a room that I
can't go into yet there's one in the staff parking I
saw that sometimes I would pick something up and it would
like yeah that little X it says like 2 out of 15 or whatever
oh what do you think's in the toilet I don't I don't know I
hope it's not Dookie.
Alright, we need to...
Um...
I wish I had a little bird to help me.
One of the hint birds.
I'm kind of... There's, like, a lot that I need to do, and
I'm kind of lost at what to...
How to... How to do them.
Oh, under the bones!
Yeah, probably.
I don't know where a hint machine...
Yeah,
that's what I'm asking for is a machine, but I don't know
where one is at.
What's this guy anyway?
Holy cow!
He's crazy!
Is there anything in the arcade now?
I sure hope not.
It seems quiet.
Oh!
Hintbird!
You have nine credits remaining.
Yes.
The data disk is hidden inside a change machine.
Like in here?
Wait, but I need... I need power in here.
Oh wait, I got the silver key!
I'm an idiot!
I forgot!
Vicky says six, seven.
Whoa!
Oh, it's so pink.
Okay, I took pictures of this room.
Bad, bad him.
And you know what?
Bad Vicky Roman at the same time.
Okay, my photos.
Mermaid 1 times 2.
Dolphin 2 times 2.
Boat 4.
Okay, dolphin.
Okay, so dolphin is 1.
No, sorry.
mermaid is one mermaid quiz arcade game what caused the
extinction of the dinosaurs
what well wait what what did they think back then
guys i say i say just not even an answer me why
are you guys saying me
volcano that's what i was thinking Correct!
Wait, I know that I only need one score here, but if it's
trivia, I'm curious.
I want to play!
Okay, now dolphin needs two.
Two score.
Jump to pop the balloons.
Oh, oops, okay.
We need a score of two.
Okay, we did it.
Alright, boat is four.
Plex stars.
Oh.
I died.
You have to like hold it.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm stupid.
Maybe.
I'm stupid maybe.
Okay.
We're fin- No!
I have to redo it.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Okay.
Stop game.
four and then so then gun should be eight suffering from
success i'm too good i'm too gaming aim and shoot the fish
one don't shoot the skulls oh i'm glad i read that oh wait
till i need eight here guys i need eight
Six?
Seven?
No, I said it.
I said the numbers.
Don't say it.
Something in the coin slot.
We got the security access.
What does this have to do?
Did it pop out?
Am I dumb?
Maybe it would have popped out.
Wait.
Can I do this too?
Move the claw.
Drop.
Oh, right.
Okay, we got this, guys.
What is this thing, anyway?
Now do the trivia.
You're so right.
This sucks.
Play again.
I'm trying to get this guy right here.
It's rigged.
You're so right.
Oh, that's perfect.
Even Bakadan.
Alright, guys.
What is the approximate population on Earth?
Billion?
Four?
Five billion?
Six billion?
Wrong.
What is the tallest building in the world?
Empire State Building.
What is the highest grossing film of all time?
Yeetie!
What kind of foods should he eat the most of every day?
Fruits and veg...
Bread, wait, isn't the bread cereal pasta at the bottom of
the...
The food?
Yeah!
Which area of the tongue is used for tasting sweet things?
The tippy tip?
I think it's the tippy tip.
How many countries are there in Europe?
I saw 32, 34, and 30 all in a row.
I'll go with 32.
Wrong.
Okay.
Um.
Is this one where...
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's our hint guy.
This one, too.
Alright, hold it.
charge.
Oh my!
I can't do it.
I can't play again.
I'm too good.
I'm literally too good.
I wanted to play that one too.
Alright.
What am I doing now?
Sorry, I forgot.
We got the disc.
The disc.
So, um, the dungeon and the, uh, what was the other place?
The dungeon had it And...
Oh!
The train room!
We could probably go to the train room first.
Whoa!
It's raining.
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait!
That's the restaurant.
I've messed up.
Ouch!
Oh my god!
Everything's trying to kill me.
For real though.
Uh...
I need, like, health bed.
Oh, I'm poisoned!
Okay, we're fine.
Saving the submarine?
We're already here.
It's okay.
Things are getting bad, you guys.
Things are getting bad, bad.
Holy cow.
Holy moly.
But you're caught in the bear trap.
fighting for your life.
Quiet, quiet.
Okay.
Slot for a disc.
A?
Wait, what is this?
Orion?
Oh, it's Orion's Odyssey!
Oh, shoot.
Um, where did we read about this?
Uh...
Okay, hold on.
No.
Orion's Odyssey.
Here!
Are Grandest Steam Engine elegantly combining all four
design styles?
Uh, okay, never mind.
Doesn't help much at all.
Uh...
I don't know at all.
What does it mean?
Oh, it doesn't look much different.
Here's a hint.
Start with the one that appears in both clues.
Find Steam Engine beautifully combining the Arabella and
Bernadette design.
line styles.
Arabella.
I see you guys saying things, but I also don't understand
how you're getting it, so I want to figure it out too.
So what is it?
Wait, also, let me see.
Did it have 1934, 1927.
So I think it's AD.
A, B.
Does it matter which one I press?
Wait.
Ew.
Let's see.
We're trying to get...
The yellow blue, right?
This is red blue.
Does it change?
I don't think it did, though, right?
No, it's not changing.
So the two trains tell you what A, B, D looks like.
And Orion tells you the order.
What?
I think I don't understand that.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
No, I think I'm still confused, though.
Wait.
This one's confusing.
I'm confused!
You gotta figure out which style name matches the style of
the car.
Yeah, but how am I supposed to tell?
I don't really get it.
I think I don't understand it.
Because one car is the same in both examples.
Oh, wait.
I remember Bella Bernadette.
So it would be...
the Arabella so a and then okay I think maybe I get it
what's this one this was Bernadette that would be the third
thing right Bernadette would be be here yeah be here and
then
Uh...
This one is...
The blue is what?
I think I get it.
The Lila, so D...
D, and then this one, it must be C.
But...
It didn't do anything.
Oh, wait.
I did D twice.
Wait, uh, wait.
I think I messed up.
Ah, wait.
Which one?
Wait.
I think I messed up!
Wait, I don't remember which it was!
Ah!
Oh no!
Wait.
Two was B.
Wait, this one was B.
Okay, okay, okay.
I messed it up.
A, D, B, C.
Uh.
Hmm?
Wait, but now I'm confused.
Was something supposed to happen or...
A is 3.
Wait, what?
How is A 3 when it was the engine?
I think you messed up which one is Arabella.
Wait.
Arabella...
Is the engine, no?
Arabella Delilah.
Oh, it is slightly different.
That one had square windows as the engine.
Okay, wait.
Wait, it's not the design, it's the color?
Just the colors.
So Arabella would be the orange.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I wish I could just take a picture of them.
The lilac is blue, right?
Blue.
So the second one is D.
Which I think I already have.
And then this one is Bernadette, which is yellow, which
would be V.
Which is the first one.
V.
Oh!
I heard something open.
Ah!
Oh my gosh, it's a flamethrower!
Wait, you mean we didn't have to do this?
Is that what you just said to me, game?
Where's my flamethrower?
What does it use?
Oh.
Yeah, well, I'll save.
okay cool um let's go to wait so the dungeon we definitely
have to do because it's circled
and then we got the secret here the toilet can i even get
the thing in the toilet i wonder what could i use the
trident to dig up the bones the bones?
I'm gonna...
Wait, I don't want to use my...
I'll go back to you.
Oh, my
bad.
Flamethrower!
Oh my gosh.
Get away from me.
Stinky.
Are there gonna be guys in here now too, right?
Oh my god, no.
There's just a trap on the ceiling.
Rude.
Oh no, there is a guy in here.
Oh my god.
Oh wow.
Oh, he was in here!
You nasty!
Covered in blood, it smells so bad!
Oh my god!
Limthrow is optional, but it's really good to help you skip
some puzzles.
Oh, fun!
Okay, bones.
Let's use the trident.
It doesn't work.
Let's use the crank handle.
Let's use...
The sad man!
It doesn't work!
No!
Okay, well...
We're Peronia, I guess.
I interrupted him.
All right, to the dungeon!
To the dungeon.
Out!
Holy!
Dungeon is in here.
We're jukeing?
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait!
Okay.
Shit.
Shit!
Critical!
Uh-oh.
Well, there's one more.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
I didn't...
Oh, he exploded himself.
I think there was one more.
Oops!
I didn't mean to do that.
I meant to turn my flashlight on, but it is on.
It's just really crappy.
this is fine this is okay this is fine everything is fine
poor guy had no chance I just took him out like that okay
give me my disc put it in legs arms head eyes okay I took a
picture I think of what we needed for.
The following doors are now locked electronically.
Dungeon...
Oh, wait.
They can be opened via the dungeon computer terminal.
Is it also...
Their gears, I suppose.
How many legs does a snake have?
But also how many legs does a mermaid have?
Or are we counting them?
them all together.
Wolf would be four.
Does the tail tail count as one?
Cyclops would be two.
Wait, but it only goes up to four.
Wait, I'm so confused.
Because the Cyclops would have two.
Maybe the legs are not four.
Maybe it's four.
overall.
It's total, right?
It has to be total.
Would be...
Wait, 2, 4.
Oh, it depends on which gate you want to open.
Is that how it works?
Oh, I see.
What's in there?
Antidote.
Do I need an antidote?
Maybe okay.
What's in here?
More shot.
Shotty.
Shotty, I'm here for you.
Legs.
Two.
Arms.
Heads.
One.
What?
Wait, did it open, right?
Okay.
Shotty.
Oh, and there's health in here too.
Okay, good.
Oh,
it's the acid!
Oh, you get the acid bottle!
What do I mean it that for?
I'll take the hand to do it.
Sure, I can't see you, thank you.
A more, more, more, more.
Snake.
Legs, zero.
Arms, zero.
Head, one, eyes, two?
Oh, I hear it.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Very cool.
I still have... what gun am I using?
Okay, my handgun.
I'm hearing something going I thought about the acid for the
bones You think it'll work Why not you know Why not Take a
crazy chance I hate the camera angle in this Oh my gosh I
hate that it I really hate I That it, like, flips my camera
around.
Acid!
Not enough acid in the bottle.
Wait, we can refill it, right?
That's what the guy said.
You can refill it.
Train room, my beloved.
I'm just gonna save...
Here.
It's not that it gives me motion sickness, it's just that
it's hard to see when I leave the room, you know.
Okay, something about acid.
Field trip.
High scores.
Have we been to the underground?
We haven't been to the underground area, have we?
Access them.
Switch that unlocks all the gates in the underground.
Did you get your free mushroom upgrade?
Yeah, I did it!
Yeah, there's some sort of acid tank somewhere.
Oh, you could refill it in the acid tank.
I heard from Crowe, moved it to the underground level.
I need to figure out how to...
I guess we need to get to a...
A elevator, I suppose.
Because I think the disc maybe opens the elevator, I think.
Seven Seas Mermaids use the same kind of battery as the
giant Crowe.
Oh, I forgot about this, too.
Good night, Mito, good night, Aibus.
Good night, one minute, Hiro!
Thank you for the summertime!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, the battery from the mermaids to give to the crawl.
I'm going...
I think there is a...
In the utility corridor that my head is blocking.
I think...
Was there...
Yes, there's an elevator right there.
I think that would be the easiest one.
to get to.
There's also still something in the theater we have to do.
Oh, gosh.
Now I can't see it at all.
Oh, my god.
Juke, juke, juke.
Juke, juke, juke, juke.
Oh, my god.
Little babies.
Is she still in here?
I sure hope not.
So now Fatal error.
Nothing happened.
Must be broken.
Uh.
What was in here?
Oh, this was the place where they were...
Oh, my God.
Wait a second.
What is that down there?
Wait, is this a secret?
No?
What is that?
What is that right there?
Can I kill this crow?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's an ammo box, but what is it?
It's a box of handgun ammo.
Wow.
In a useless room, nonetheless.
Okay, I should find maybe a bird.
Or I could go back to the theater.
How did I get to the theater anyway?
Everything is so overrun, I'm scared to go anywhere.
Let's go back to the haunted house.
little baby watch out baby watch out excuse me excuse me
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me the color was
different and that's oh my god wait this place is overrun
now too but my mushroom is my mushroom buddy okay oh I would
have to redo it oh wait oh no never mind
still just the one guy in there yeah really oh my god oh my
god Oh my god.
Oh, please, please.
Oh!
Stop!
You guys are the worst.
Another dude here.
Okay, to the theater.
They just, like, breathe.
Like, stop it.
Stop doing that.
This place is probably overrun now, too.
There's something I gotta do in here.
Oh, am I okay?
I'm injured.
I'm gonna run out of everything.
at this point.
I'm gonna run out of hell.
Varnish the ocean kingdom storage room door.
That's right, the storage room door.
As I was trying, I thought I could shoot it, but I couldn't
remember which one it was.
I think that guy is not alive.
I'm completely confused.
There's a valve here.
here.
Oh, no.
There isn't a live guy down there.
That's just... Unless he's dead.
Actually, I can't tell.
Oh, he's moving.
Just ignore him.
Oh, yeah.
This makes her kick and turn.
I already searched there.
I need a bird!
Oh, my God.
Big guy.
Wait.
I'll get me out of here, actually.
because if I go outside
the elevators aren't working though
mysterious oh I didn't mean to pause the game itself
I don't remember where another bird was I guess I could go
back to the to the arcade so far from here
hint doko I don't remember where the other ones were um very
ponded I didn't have one.
Oh, the crow...
The crow country area had one.
That's right.
That's where the other one was.
Yeah, by the crow house.
We could go to that one.
I'll just have to sneak out of here.
And sneak through all of the mbade area, too.
Wait, this is hellish now.
Oh my god, he saw me.
This is hell.
I hope I'm going the right way!
I think I am.
Cool.
Okay, don't trust the purple.
Tell me my fortune!
Yes, tell me my fortune.
The periphery elevator switch is in Tolman's office.
Which is where?
Toby's office!
Where is that?
Where is he?
Try to burn the storage door.
That's what I think, yeah, we have to do that.
Ouch!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm okay still.
What the?
Where did that come from?
Oh my god.
Wait, let's go into here real quick.
And then regret it?
and go back out, and then get my bearings, and...
Here?
Wait, no, that's the control room.
Um...
Leave me alone.
It was... Oh, shoot.
It was like...
I think it was on the other side.
All lost.
I want to use my flamethrower.
there's still a back door to open with the silver key there
is wait there was how did i get back there oh through the
arcade that's right which is over here no wait yes no wait
where's the arcade i'm so lost in this area here sunken
treasure why is the What happened to the...
I guess it's still pink.
It's just, like, a little darker.
I don't trust you.
You are not real.
It's so dark in here now.
Oh, God.
There's big guys.
Which one was it?
Was it the one that's the red blocks?
Thank you guys so much, also, for helping me.
I'm getting so lost.
Ah!
I'm, like, getting crazy lost, so it's like...
Oh!
I was like, messing me all up.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Holy cow.
There's, like, no health left.
I'm dying here.
It's the red square.
What?
Where is that?
What am I looking at?
Okay.
By the...
Ah!
I remember!
Every time, man.
Every time.
Get in.
there get in there get in there are you Tolman oh sorry for
barging in I should introduce myself I'm Mara forest I'm
looking for I like the purple what is that dyed must be
doesn't look like a wig when you're finished talking about
my hair I think I might need your help I'm looking for
Edward Crow yeah I bet you are You must be Tolman.
I must be.
What was it Marvin said?
You were the root excavation guy?
Correct.
He likes some boy purple.
What's root excavation?
No idea.
You know, you're not being very helpful.
I like his room.
This thing's pretty cool.
I'm jealous.
We could play some.
Okay.
Cool.
Metal cabinet.
Music note.
What's this?
Oh, this is for the elevators.
The lights are all red.
This is a little guy.
Piece of Tuesday.
Isolated for examination.
You have antidote, but no.
No, I don't need any more antidote.
I need health.
Oh, I need health, please.
Please.
Tollman's records Guests are appearing almost every day now
We can't save them They're too far gone But I want to know
where they've come from I found a number marked in blood on
the ground 2106 We've seen that twice now It's not a code
for any of our locks It's not a code at all Ha
The sound is horribly distorted Probably because the aerial
has been cut in half.
Yeah, that's terrible.
Alright, Tolman.
The park is closed.
Duh.
I know.
Search through garbage cans, even ones you've locked in
before.
You might find med kits.
Yeah, yeah.
So go home.
I can't go home.
Sure you could.
Just get in your little car and drive away.
I'm sure that guy you saved would appreciate it.
Arthur, you know about him.
the one who's been spying on us at least he had the good
sense to get injured once and give up just notice the total
number of keys on that such range yeah Tolman what are the
monsters the monsters don't pretend like you don't know what
I'm talking about no it's just trust me Mara you don't want
to know can I turn on the elevators from in here the
elevators are broken No, they're not.
They're just pretending to be broken.
So where's the switch?
Let's see if you can work it out on your own.
Fine.
You don't feel like helping me find the elevator switch?
I do not.
Right.
Showing static.
Examine the tapes.
Hindenburg?
Titanic?
Plague!
Hiroshima!
A small flyer broke out in the port.
Okay, the- oh, the dates over there are- wait.
Up, wait, I wasn't paying attention.
One way- blah blah blah blah blah.
The dates are the same ones on the side here.
What footage do we have of the plague?
F.
Oh, it's for the keyboard.
Okay, so...
So F is first.
F is first.
The 1912 Titanic.
What was that?
A.
F-A.
F-A-C?
Sorry, I'm not reading it.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I didn't mean to do the Titanic.
Sorry.
Okay.
37 was what?
Yeah, the Hidden Memory Witch was C, and then Hiroshima is
F-A-C-E Face!
Ooh.
Whoa, synth.
I solved your stupid puzzle.
Be honest.
You loved it.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, okay.
That's it.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Oh, wait.
There's one right outside.
That's right.
There's one right there.
We don't have to go.
I was thinking, oh my gosh, I'm going to have to go all the
way back to like the haunted area.
But no, we're okay.
We can go.
There's one in the delivery garage.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's heal before we...
I think I will do big.
Okay.
Mara, hold up.
What is it?
Don't go down there.
You'll regret it.
So be it.
Northwest.
You might want to start clearing up some monsters.
I think you're right, honestly.
Are there monsters?
I imagine there's probably some monsters.
sometimes.
Break room!
Oh, absolutely there are some big old monsters down here.
I wish I could aim well with this thing.
Oh, there's my pointer.
Oh,
there is a red can, you're right.
Let's just do that instead.
Oh,
come on.
Are you...
Are you made of steel?
No more new monster spawn now.
Oh yay!
Only the hardest bits left.
Uh...
Holy cow.
Wait, I think...
Oh.
I can't tell if he's dead dead or not.
Oh!
He sunk through the...
It's kind of gnarly.
Okay.
Uh, run!
What's going on here?
Metal gate to the root...
Root fry!
I want to go to the break room.
Oh, yeah.
Don't fail in the break room.
Gnarly.
Everything's gnarly.
Gnarly, gnarly, gnarly, gnarly.
Gnarly, gnarly, gnarly.
gnarly.
Everything's gnarly.
Break room.
You think it...
Wait, how many bullets?
You think I...
What is in here?
No way there's nothing.
That's so rude.
You think there's actually breaks happening in here or...
Please.
Health.
The game hates me.
I haven't gotten anything in the trash can in forever!
Stuck in my head now.
Sorry!
Oh, here's a health health.
I'll take that.
Root access.
Guess I'll turn that on.
Will I turn green?
I guess that's it.
Oh,
this looks like a boss.
Okay, I'm gonna fire him!
Is that getting him?
Oh my god.
He's wiping?
Oh, he's also pooping.
Ow, hold on.
Okay, this isn't working so well, I think maybe.
We're still okay though.
In terms of health, kind of, somehow.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, please, please, please look at him.
Ouch.
Okay.
Ouch to you.
Not to me.
And in the face.
Oh, I think I got him.
Okay, nice.
You don't have the flamethrower.
I know, I know I don't have the flamethrower upgrade.
I couldn't get it.
Wait, what's this?
It's an old license plate.
They are people.
Georgia 2663 Atlanta Falcons.
Good thing this didn't melt.
What do I mean by that?
I wasn't going to read this, the notice board.
I can't remember the code for the break room security gate.
I swear it has a 3, a 6, and a 2.
Another 6?
I can't remember the order.
I know we took the code from the old license plate, but it's
gone missing.
That timing!
is crazy.
Atlanta Falcons fan.
God help them.
Are they bad?
Is that a bad team?
A bunch of green metal tubes.
Looks like I'll have gold inside.
Wait, what do I need this for though?
2663?
Do I need it for this?
I didn't have to input a code.
Wait, what did they save it for?
Break room security gate.
I didn't have to put in anything.
You can watch five hours of YouTube about their tragic
history.
They're pretty meh.
Oh, here.
Oh, duh.
Okay, two...
There we go.
Ooh,
can I ride this?
Never.
Wee!
Okie dokie.
Well, I need a map of this area.
I'm gonna be so lost.
They've never won a Super Bowl!
Wait, that's pretty tragic.
Oops, oh my god.
Oh, oh my god.
Wait, I think I'm done for?
Goodbye!
noped out of existence.
Why didn't my hands hit him?
Okay, one more time.
So rude.
Okay, we got him this time.
Team, we got him.
Okay, my hits do not hit him.
It's time to leave.
Oh, wait.
Can I go?
Okay, good, good.
Okay, what's over here?
Northeast.
Oh, okay.
I think that's an elevator.
Uh, you?
Nope.
Leave me alone.
Ouch!
Oh, you sucker.
Root sun.
Okay, and I'm just going in a pipe.
I'm just going anywhere.
I wasted all those bullets on that guy.
little silly.
I'm gonna try it.
Oh thank goodness.
It's actual ammo.
Not the purple kind that trick you.
It's a hatch.
I can't get into the pipe.
It looks like some kind of high-tech lock.
The display changed.
I love that we're just going in here and like pushing
buttons like we don't know what we're doing at all we're
just like la la la big giant valve i don't know what it does
let me just push the buttons it truly doesn't do anything
like what i have to find a different way into the central
area
took you down Oh my gosh.
These, like, ceiling traps?
Why are they in here?
Why are they in these areas, huh?
Ah, buttons, buttons!
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, my God.
It's this spider guy.
Oh, he's so icky.
He has, like, his own BGM.
It's kind of crazy.
I think I can run past him.
Oh, ouch.
I can't get this over.
He's so bony.
Southwest.
I'm so lost.
Please, where's the map?
You know what?
I might have to just start going into one of these root
areas.
Oh.
Interesting.
It's a machine.
This is gross.
Why are you ignoring the roots?
I thought it was going to go into like a crazy area.
That's why.
What kind of machine is this anyway?
Maybe I could turn it on and see what it does.
Well there is a big old button.
Calibration Route 3 Tuesday, full of grace.
What did it do?
That was underwhelming.
Maybe if it's something in between the clamps.
Okay, I think I need to lower it a little bit.
Lower it?
Make it lower?
Oh!
What's this spell?
What comes up must come down.
Left lever?
No, this one controls the...
This one controls this thing.
We will come back.
I have a feeling I'm gonna have to, like, do this area.
I'm, like, worried about dying in here.
It's okay.
We'll go check out another real area and we can come back.
Health.
You are so mean.
The bird.
I'm just gonna shoot you too.
Wednesday.
Oh my god, it's a save point!
Let's go!
Uh...
Holy cow!
Okay.
A magazine.
Oh, here's all my tips and stuff.
My tips and tricks.
More ammo!
Is there any health in here?
Please!
Box of shotgun shells.
No health!
Why is the game so stingy all of a sudden?
Wait, is that a map?!
Where?
Oh my gosh, everything is coming up, Minto!
Okay.
Confusing.
Wednesday, save the day for real though.
What is this one?
Calibration Route 4, Wednesday, full of woe.
It's Friday, I'm in love!
Is that the...
Are these the roots?
Oh, that's how they harvest the gold!
The gold is, that's what fell earlier.
Gonna heal, by the way.
So these are the roots.
And they have the gold inside them like that.
Which way am I going?
South.
Oh, you're icky.
You're pretty creepy looking.
Wee!
Uh, no.
Little baby.
Oh my god, there's so many of you guys.
Wait!
Why is there a bicycle down here?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Please.
Underground is basically the fast travel area.
If you want to get rid of some of the enemies in the halls.
But do I need to go back upstairs?
Thank you, if it's not for your help.
The screen is cracked, but it still seems to work.
Slot for my disc.
Gas pressure.
Wait, I think this will get rid of the gas in...
The...
What's it called, area?
Thick, smelly fumes.
Pull it!
Oh.
Like, total gas pressure must be exactly 50 for successful
manual overdrive.
This will get it...
This will make it so that we can go into that one area.
That we couldn't in the mermaid zone.
Harrison, what are you doing?
It's not safe down here, you know?
Yeah, no, I know.
I got chased by some kind of creature, I think.
Did it touch you?
Did it?
No, no, I got away just about.
I ran in here to get out of the way, you know.
Right.
Good idea.
And there's this big gas vent, and I thought, okay, maybe I
could be of use.
Maybe I can turn this off.
Yeah, how's that going?
Bad.
I don't know how to do it.
I try, but it's too complicated.
don't get it it's okay I'm sure you can do it I'll help you
out okay I finally ran into Natalie oh my gosh where she
been how did that go weird she was acting
weird I think she might be ill she didn't seem to want to
talk to me oh she told me I should just go home Harrison
sorry but she's right you should I'm off to perform oh she
guides oh my gosh have fun how much more do I probably like
an hour ish of this game left probably hopefully if I can
get through these things you're not going to tell me what's
going on are you ideally no Mera I'm concerned for your for
your safety don't be
okay so we need a note on the gas levels to make the gas
wait it has to be 50 is that what it said okay guys lock in
all right okay I'm getting pulling out the calculator okay
I'm pulling out the calculator right now we're serious
business okay 18 plus 15 plus 4 wait plus 13 guys I I did it
first try.
Wait.
I was just kidding.
What was this one?
18?
15?
4?
13?
I was just kidding!
I was just picking numbers!
Now, outside, there is a elevator.
But I want to go to the root areas that I didn't go to
because I was, like, running away.
How did I do that?
Maji Tensai.
Yeah, I think so.
Tolman's records And she claims she can't math I can't
believe I just did that
Tenzai I am Tenzai I'm genius I finally turned off I finally
turned off the excavation machines Boss didn't give me
permission but didn't argue He's obsessed with the pool and
the guests He hasn't answered his phone in days She's done
it again Thank you guys I also think you do our good.
Not the first time you winged the puzzle first try.
Definitely the missed one was probably my most impressive
yet.
The missed one that I did first try, I don't think I will
ever top that.
The sheer number of possibilities.
It was like a 1 in 50 chance or something.
It was insane.
If you haven't watched the missed one, Yeah, I didn't even
know it was a puzzle.
I just clicked it.
One in 72.
My gosh.
There was an accident in the park.
Boss had to shut the place down.
I don't think he cares at all.
Friday, I'm in love.
Loving and giving.
How...
What is this?
A large tank.
dripping out of the pipe.
The smell is almost unbearable.
Wait, we can fill our... Yeah, we can fill our thing.
And without your smarty glasses, too.
You guys, my gotcha luck has been kind of crazy lately.
Like, I think my luck is really turning around.
Should we turn it off?
It was dripping on this thing.
Shouldn't we let it keep dripping?
It's gonna slip out.
ammo take that it's being real stingy on health recently
though the game hates me okay uh let's see so we hit friday
i went all the way around and i didn't that's so my bad
oh my god uh let's see
i'm gonna search the trash camera one more time.
Just kidding.
I've already searched it.
I think that's a corpse below the acid valve.
It may hops very well be.
Is this the guy that I couldn't shoot?
Game's encouraging you to go boom boom, so true.
But I couldn't kill this guy.
I wouldn't let me.
I must Maybe he goes better with him.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh my god.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Goodbye.
He deflects it.
Yeah, he sounds metallic.
Um.
How many grenades do I have left?
One.
I don't know if there's...
I feel like this game will have...
The flamethrower might work.
Let's try that.
We can try that one instead.
I have to get kind of close to him, though.
And he's got large hands.
I'm going to try the grenade.
Wait.
Hey, I definitely reloaded.
Nice.
Yeah!
Take that.
Route Saturday.
Oops.
Calibration Route 7 Saturday.
It works hard.
Another grenade!
I keep forgetting I have those these tanks, but I don't.
Oh, maybe the fuel tanks were for the flamethrower.
Now I think about it.
And not for like dropping on the ground.
Wait, I do!
They were magnum rounds.
The purple ones.
There's a revolver!
Wait, I We got another map?
Oh!
The top layer looks like it's supposed to be grass.
The bottom layer looks more like soil or rocks.
Wooden model.
Oh, whoops.
Good.
They really aren't giving me any health at all.
Do you even notice this?
Game says, nah.
You're done healing.
Is that supposed to...
Look!
There's little people!
Maybe that's the Oh, yeah.
And then the roots.
No heal, only shooty.
Truly.
That's what it's saying.
What's here?
What's this thing?
Oh, grenade.
Granade.
Okay, I do have to go back up to the mermaid area.
Which we don't quite know.
There's this other room here.
here I haven't gone into.
I don't quite know which...
Maybe southwest it would be.
That...
The southwest elevator.
Oh, whoops.
Gosh.
Please.
Look this way.
Where are you?
Uh...
Dookyo?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna switch to my shot.
Um...
Where are you?
Just start killing.
Time to start killing.
It does look like a slipknot member.
These guys are freaky.
These guys are pretty freaky.
I'm scared of taking this.
What if it explodes?
What if it explodes and I die?
I want to believe.
I want to believe that it's health.
Oh, oh my god.
not realize her hand.
I can't tell if it's bouncing off or not.
Risk it for the biscuit.
Woo!
I think I can only shoot it when it emerges.
I'm just going to run past.
Stop.
Was this Sunday?
What's going on in here?
Hey Ed, did she get my rock shipment?
Why don't you answer the phone?
What's going on over there?
Marv.
A real med kit.
We're okay!
We're okay for now.
It's a generator, it looks ancient.
I actually have no idea how to turn it off.
It looks fragile though, maybe I can just destroy it.
What was something...
Was there something that we needed to...
Turn the generator off for?
Preserved for posterity.
Route 1.
Yeah, surely that wasn't important.
I think Mara just thinks...
Or rather, she just does before she thinks.
She just...
She just does.
Check the map and look above.
Oh wait, I can!
Oh my god!
Oh gosh, I just realized that I can...
Wait, where are we now?
We're over there.
Crow's office.
Can we get in?
The electric door handle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's kind of dumb.
At least she admitted it.
Good night.
If you're heading to bed, I'm sorry.
That, uh...
That, the game is a little bit...
Oh, come on.
That's no, no, no.
That game is a little longer, but...
done, I think.
Okay, this is, this is, uh, okay, we have not gone in here
either.
So we need to go into this route.
Oh, oh, oh, the girls are fighting.
Um, don't mind me.
Is there health in there?
Nothing.
Mr. Trumble, what are you doing down here?
Hey, kiddo, what's shaking?
You still, I'm still looking for Edward Crow.
Ah, ain't we all, ain't we all why are you looking for him
oh well how should i put this i just needed a little help
with something i uh he's on the run from the brazilian
authorities there's
always the vibe i'm gonna sleep and catch back tomorrow of
course good night thanks for hanging around he came back
here to hide shut your trap tommen you self-righteous old
busybody why don't you make me tremble you loaded old gas
bag the girls are fighting so what happened in brazil the
question we're all asking what happened in brazil crow and i
were running a little operation see it was somewhat the
nature i guess you could say we were selling the gold right
the gold from the roots Oh, you've been reading up on me,
have you?
Close enough.
Like deceitful.
Okay, that's what I figured.
You can't pronounce it either?
I don't feel as bad then.
Why go all the way to Brazil to sell the gold?
It's like too much of a good thing.
You know what I mean?
No.
Well, you see, the gold we scooped out of the roots, right?
It's too pure.
And there's too much of it.
Why am I only thinking of breaking bad right now?
Do please sit us?
Do please sit on us?
Naughty!
My breaking brain rot right now.
Why is that a problem?
Crow didn't want anyone connecting the gold back to his
land.
He didn't want the U.S.
government and looking into where it was coming from.
I was telling the story, Tolman, you uppity old bastard.
Well, you were doing a shit job of it, Trumbull, you
worthless old junkie.
We gotta cook, Minto.
So at least before you got in trouble, you must have been
making a lot of money.
You and Crow?
You could say that.
Then why come back here at all?
Why not just go live on a desert island or something?
I wouldn't want to live on a desert island.
I would want to live on a deserted island.
You are wrong, this game's story is basically a breaking bad
tax evasion plot.
Yeah!
They yearn for the mines.
We be yearning here.
Bring back yearning and bring back mines.
Oh.
Let me tell you, I left stream early and never would have
expected the story to go to Brazil.
Okay, to be fair, though, Brazil was pretty early on.
How long have you been gone, huh?
They went and seized my assets, didn't they?
All of it.
It's all frozen unless I show my face in court.
Answer all their lovely questions.
You wanted to hide the gold in the vent in the babysitter?
I understand that.
It was too large.
But let me guess.
Crow kept his name off the paperwork.
So he gets to keep his share of the money.
Is that why you really came back to make sure Crow gets
dragged down with you?
She really sussed you out.
Only took her two minutes.
Quit your cackling, Tolman, you arrogant old snob.
I'll laugh at you all.
I like Trumble, you dopey old clown.
These guys are like an old married couple.
So, Mara, what do you make of them?
What do I make of what?
The roots.
The big green tubes?
Those are the roots?
Why are they called that?
That's just what Crow named them.
What are they made of?
The outer shell is mostly copper.
However, the inner core is 24 karat gold.
Pyrrhus there is.
Worst old divorced couple.
No!
May have been Phantom Secret number one.
She can't say prestigious.
I could say prestigious.
I could even say it with the accent.
Prestigious.
That's not a secret to have that fact at all.
That's not a real fact at all.
As you well know, well, no.
Trumble, you...
Leech.
Shut it, Tolman.
You traitorous old Cretan.
All the machinery, the big circular saw, it's for...
It's made of labooboo.
We call it root excavation.
My stutter has been so bad recently, you guys.
I don't know why.
Although harvesting might be more of an accurate term.
The roots are cut into shorter segments, which are lifted up
to the surface.
All this just to extract the gold?
Correct the moon, though.
She wasn't talking to you, Trumble, you heinous old
parasite.
The roots are green and yellow, like the Brazilian flag!
Wait, you're so right!
The roots belong in Brazil!
Fight me, Tolman, you pompous old jackass!
Mara, you should really get out of here.
I can't leave now, I'm so close!
Close to what exactly?
That's what I'm wondering, close to what?
Do you even know?
Listen, I know you wanna...
Don't bother with the pep talk, she doesn't care.
Quiet down, Trumble, you greasy old half-wit.
Don't talk to me like that, Tolman.
You cantankerous old...
See, a sponge!
Okay.
I think we got through it.
Um, okay.
Before we do that, though...
I think we want to go up.
Oh, wait.
There's a central...
That's right.
This central thing.
This guy.
There's a pain in my side.
Let's see, how can I get rid of him?
Just like that!
Look!
It's not even health anymore!
It's bullets!
Evil.
So we got rid of the gas.
And we got rid of the...
The door here.
So we can go in.
E.
L.
Crow owner.
It's locked.
There's a golden keyhole.
Shoot.
The throw-up is still there.
That's kind of crazy.
What can the acid be?
Oh, the acid is to be used...
Uh...
Oh, wait, what is this?
Oh, tank of gasoline!
I was like, wait a second, is that an item or no?
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I noticed that.
My eyes are so special.
Yeah, we refilled the acid bottle.
I guess we do use it on the bones, huh?
Let's get through here.
What would be the best way to get there then?
That gets us into the staff hallway.
I think the delivery garage is going to be where we want to
go because we want to get to the...
That gassy area.
That's... that's open now.
Yeah.
All these areas should be cleared out, which is pretty nice.
Run!
I have specialization.
eyes okay
oh yeah this is where oh yeah and the central thing here too
oh this is a baby i gotta be careful though uh
shoot the baby oh shoot oh okay he's hiding again peekaboo
all right I got rid of some of the annoying guys.
Hopefully there's not too many things in this garage room.
Because we haven't been in here before.
Was that thing moving?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, gosh.
I don't like that.
What do we got in here?
What the heck is this?
Battery?
Hi, battery.
Crow walk.
Some more bullets.
I saw that there was a sign over here, too, but I'm scared
to go by the box.
I'm scared to go by the box.
I wish I could have, I should have saved, honestly.
Is it too late?
Wait.
Oh, there's more bullets back there, too.
Trash can.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, lucky winner.
There's something in there, too.
Wait, this was not open before.
Like, it was...
It was shut.
The opposite of open.
I noticed there's an elevator behind the large crow.
Does it go anywhere?
Does anyone use it?
It always seems to be powered down.
I figured it was broken.
That's probably into the central area, no?
Someone said there's a switch in the crow's office that
turns it on.
Ah!
I see.
More shotgun shells, I'll take it.
Wait, this is not real, is it?
Is this real?
You think it's real?
Just a bunch of flickering numbers.
Can't make sense of it.
dumpster whatever's in there is on fire smells bad it's
giving me a headache
that's a tank of gasoline yeah it doesn't look real there's
a this thing at the bottom that it looks like wait it looks
like it's supposed to be a health kit right here oh thank
you game yeah okay alright let's hope this didn't bust open
i want to read this note okay i'm gonna be brave staff memo
bronze key okay i think i have a finger figured out bronze
key crank handle ruby chain mask trident silver key data
disk acid battery bottle fill sorry fill golden key large
battery charged.
What an ordeal.
It's all of our stuff that we've done.
Some kind of diagram that I'm taking a photo of.
It's from Brazil.
Check the box.
Maybe I shouldn't.
Julie!
Hey, kid.
Julie, what happened?
I'll tell you, if you help me out of this thing.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
She should have said something with her voice.
Thanks for the help.
How did you end up in the crate?
Some guy grabbed me from behind and threw me in there.
He came up behind you?
Some guy, who was it?
No idea, didn't see his face.
He had real sweaty hands, though.
Oh, no.
He's nervous.
Oh, gross.
Yeah, not an especially enjoyable experience, all told.
I wonder if it was Marvin.
He looked like he'd been kind of sweaty.
Marvin, who?
The Martian.
That's my favorite Looney Tunes character, you guys, is
Marvin the Martian.
I'm actually, I'm actually kind of really obsessed with him.
Oh, nothing.
Don't worry.
Just think it out loud.
He's probably one of the cutest things I've ever seen in my
entire afterlife.
I love him so much.
He's so cute.
I watched Space Jam just for him, but I'm afraid of the
Tasmanian devil, so I would close my eyes whenever he was on
the screen.
But if Marvin the Martian was on the screen...
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking!
I'm glad you're safe.
Yeah, listen, that's twice you've helped me out now.
Let me know if there's any way I can return the favor.
You could heal me.
Anything I can do for you?
All right, now.
Thanks, though.
Wait, no, that's not true at all.
You could get me health or something.
Okay.
Alright.
We came up here to go into...
Okay.
I want to save so bad.
Let's go into the submarine and save.
Is there anything in there?
No.
Alright.
We're going to do our best to save in the submarine.
What gun do I have?
This guy.
Oh.
Where are you going?
No, please.
Don't walk away from me.
Why is there an arrow pointing at the extinguisher?
I didn't see that.
He ran away so fast!
Okay, I think I can make it.
Okay.
Holy moly.
I'm looking to see if any health items respond.
Unfortunately, no.
But we can heal.
All right.
Save and that's all that matters to me.
Hey Minto and Aibus.
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello!
Okay, go up.
Yeah, we find safety in the submarine.
Oh my god.
Wait a second.
Don't do that.
Are you coming over here?
Oh, okay, I'm gonna go down.
All right, we're gonna- we're just gonna run for it.
Uh...
Where was it, though?
Oh, in here.
It's a...
No way!
No kidding, is this our first ride?
We found one!
We found a ride!
It's a wheel.
I could turn it left or right.
Doesn't do anything.
But it's a nice feeling.
Having the horizon stretching out in front of you.
She's...
She's reliving a past life.
life.
Is there a treasure in here?
It's fake.
Of course it doesn't open.
I'm feeling a very tangible sense of betrayal.
Yeah, I am too.
I wish there was a fourth one.
Okay.
Should we sit in the front row or should we sit in the back
row?
How intense do you think this is?
It looks like a dark ride, so probably not so intense.
Wait.
The water's flowing this way, so I guess the third row would
be the first row?
Well, you finally found a ride!
Marvin was a great character.
The shame is appearing apprentice Marcia only appeared once
in Tiny Toons.
Oh, you're... Wait, I don't know Marcia.
That's the end of your year.
It's turning out to be a relaxing one.
Thank you, Hal Roth.
You too!
Let's go...
Let's go for one...
Wait, definitely one is the last row, though.
So we have to ride three.
It's the boat.
If I'm going to sit in it, I should sit in the middle.
Wait, where's the...
How do we get up there?
How do I get up there?
I think there's a...
Oh my gosh.
We'll have a golden keyhole!
Dang it.
This game hates me, for real.
Oh, now you're coming this way, huh?
Oh, please.
Please.
Oh, my God.
They're pretty fast, these guys.
Oh, boy.
I forgot he explodes.
Oh, my God.
Some antidote, though.
I can't carry it.
Oh, the door!
They said, like...
I wonder if we can just...
No.
I don't have a key.
Let's go through here.
Maybe I ride the ride and see what happens.
It's not like I'm just trying to ride the ride or anything.
This is fun, but I can't operate the ride controls from
here.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm trying to think of
Okay, what are we working on?
We have this What is the theater?
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to think of everything that we did downstairs.
We turned off the...
We got the acid.
So we can go To the toilet And get that It's...
That's what I'm suiting.
The bones.
But the bones has nothing to do with the theater, I don't
think.
How do I fast travel to the theater?
Oh, um, we could do that.
Chow was saying about a gold key in the theater.
Oh, really?
Okay.
That door in Ocean Kingdom, I'm pretty sure that's the door
that they said was able to be, like, That they were like,
please fix it or whatever.
Tariya, welcome back.
Thank you.
Theater is most important right now.
Okay, okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Then I shout, where am I?
A mosh.
Oh, whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop.
Do I have everything to solve the theater?
Because I'm so confused by it.
Oh, I can talk to you.
Anything I can do?
Ask for help.
Is there something?
Oh, I need to get through the boat ride.
Oh!
Wait, I can ask her to help me!
The Seven Seas?
Yes, I can use your help to operate the controls.
Have you opened the door to the control room?
Not yet.
You'll need the golden key.
I remember reading a memo that mentioned it was over by the
fairy tale town theater.
Once you get the control door open, come back here and let
me know.
I'd be happy to help you.
Thanks, Julie.
I saw a certain other VTuber rotate gravestones for an hour
in this.
Totally understandable.
Oh, he's gone.
He didn't take his bike.
I think he's Mr. Sweaty.
Yeah, Julie was actually helpful.
It's a miracle to have a character that is actually helping
you.
Where does this one go to?
This one goes to...
The back rooms.
That's the other one.
With random.
This one.
I think I'm making time though.
I think basically...
I think how long to beat said that most people take about
six hours.
I think I'm making time.
Which is not so bad.
We run?
Wicked Wham!
Mint Phantom MF.
Flip it around.
Wicked Wham!
Okay, this thing...
I don't even know what I'm supposed to do here.
Yeah, the storage room door, I'm pretty sure, is this red
door in Ocean Kingdom on the right side.
But I haven't been able to get to it because of that big
guy.
Am I supposed to like fill this with acid and then it drips
on her?
That's the only thing I can think of.
Wait, isn't there another big guy in here?
Isn't there a big guy in here?
Hey, big guy.
Oh yeah, there he is.
Wait, don't go, don't leave.
Oh my god.
Ah, shoot.
Where'd he go?
Oh my god, please.
Got his butt.
It gets me every time.
I think there's a baby over here too.
There's a sound effect that I hear.
I'm going to turn it up.
I think it's these guys.
There's like this one TikTok of like this person that is
like in a class so basically okay i'm going to explain it
right now it's so funny there's a professor that it's like
back when there was um online school or whatever during the
pandemic and the professor was like is there does anyone
have any questions and the person has like this alien voice
filter on that goes as like and you can tell that they're
asking like a genuine question You know that one?
So funny.
And then he's like, yeah, I really understood that.
Wait, did I show you guys?
The sound effect that I'm hearing in my ear sounds exactly
like it.
Sounds exactly...
Okay.
Oh, maybe it went a little overboard.
It's so funny.
It gets me every time.
I think I have to put the acid in here.
So the bone acid is optional.
Oh my gosh, we're going to dissolve her.
Goodbye, giant fairy lady.
Oh, I'm...
Sure is taking her time.
Yeah, you can refill the acid.
The acid has no effect on the fairy's wooden head.
Maybe there's something else I need to do first.
No stinking way.
No way.
Did
I just waste the acid and I have to go get another one?
Flamethrower.
Oh, she's wooden.
Are you sad?
Yeah, she's basically the other way.
Yeah, she's magical.
What's happening?
Thought that would work.
Me too.
I thought so for sure.
I don't want to waste my flamethrower.
Oh my god, this game really hates me.
Oh, more bullets.
I will take that, though.
Definitely need that.
Little baby.
At this point, I'm just looking for more items that I hadn't
looted yet.
I'm not sure at all Why are you magical?
Why are you magical?
Nobody can Nobody Nobody can survive a headshot
Golden key
Wait, did that get all of it?
No, I don't think so
Keep going.
Actually, I think we're good.
Okay, no.
Yeah, we're fine.
We're fine.
That should be enough.
Take it.
Still stuck.
Golden key.
It's the fairy.
It's done.
I don't feel good about it.
Aw.
I know, because the fairy helped us earlier.
I don't want to hurt her.
Oh, I already checked this one.
I'm sorry.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Please.
Use item!
It's time.
The phone is ringing here, too.
No.
No way.
So many medkits.
I'll leave the rest of the people...
No.
No, it's not time to be...
There's like only us!
Moshi Moshi, you know, I never had a plan for all the gold.
In fact, it quickly became a problem.
We couldn't sell it, basically.
Not without arousing.
A lot of unwinted attention.
Oh, la la.
We had too much of it too quickly in the shape.
Those cylinders?
Well, it's not the normal process.
process, is it?
But then I had an idea.
What if it was the normal process?
Or what if we pretended it was?
What other people, Mara?
No!
So Marvin and I devised a plan.
We just needed a site.
A disused gold mine.
Mara found one in South America, in Brazil.
And you know what?
It worked.
For a while, at least.
He's gone.
No, Mara, please.
Mara, please.
You need them.
You.
You need it.
We got a big old door right here.
What's this?
Emory University in recognition of the completion of the
prescribed course of study, Edward L.
Crowe has been admitted to the degree of biochemistry.
This really is just breaking bad.
Breaking bad!
Hey Ed, we didn't pass the inspection.
They figured out the ore is homemade.
The Brazilian authorities want to know where the gold is
really coming from.
This is getting too dangerous.
I'm coming back to Georgia.
See you soon, Marv.
He's coming back home.
Control room elevator switch number code.
My first is in Gruner, but also in Goblin.
My second is in Guest, but not.
in puddle or spindle my third is in lumber and goblin but
not in puddle my fourth is notable but only its absence okay
I figured we have to turn this on to figure it out who the
heck is this she's quite beautiful it's made entirely of
gold he made a gold anime figure oh oh no it's his mom I
mean his wife Jacqueline crawl.
Beloved wife and mother.
But it moves.
Sorry.
There's something strange about the frame.
It's a photograph.
What's that in there, twitching?
Okay, hold on.
It's a television.
Every few moments, something flashes on the screen.
I wish it wouldn't.
Yeah, it's kind of creepy.
Did I search his trash?
A grenade in there!
Mr. What the heck?
Let's go behind here.
Oh, it's a little root.
Is this sun...
This must be Sunday, right?
I love a...
I would love a golden meen-tail figure.
He made a super We're a 24 karat gold waifu-fu.
Is that a grenade in the corner?
The cornerware.
There are some of the roots around, so it might be a little
tricky to tell if it's a grenade.
Or root.
Oh, wait!
Oh, my gosh.
Murphy, your eyes.
Crazy.
Whoa!
Where the hell did you come from?
218.
Woman jumpscare.
Squirming back and forth.
Is it alive?
Small notebook.
The Diary of Edward Crow.
Age ten and a half.
Saturday.
I am excited.
Tomorrow father and I are going camping in the Condor
country over the river.
Father says it's just a nickname, as there are no condors in
Georgia.
I am looking forward to the trip, nonetheless.
I love being outdoors at night.
Sunday.
Father and I found something strange while camping.
A green, shiny thing sticking out of the ground.
It is wriggling back and forth like a little bug.
But Father says it is not a bug, as it is made of metal.
Edward Crow, what is this made of?
Metal.
But there are condors in South America.
You got him there.
Monday.
We found a second wriggling metal thing.
A couple hundred feet south of the first one.
Father wanted to know what it is made of.
He cut off the tip with his camping knife.
Inside is a different metal.
It looks like gold.
Tuesday.
Two more shiny things.
Four in total.
Father says there may be more.
Wednesday.
Father bought Condor Country.
As well as a couple of acres on either side.
He said we could rename it if we wish.
Mm-hmm.
Oh!
Lucky.
Lucky, lucky.
My video game tips.
More antidote.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna save one more time.
Hi, Natalie.
Hold on.
I'm gonna spray my throat.
Sorry, I get tired of talking.
How are you feeling?
I can't believe I...
I have voiced two games for about six hours, two days in a
row.
Holy moly.
Did you have dinner yet?
No.
Well, I had like an early...
I had a late lunch, early dinner, so I'm okay.
How are you feeling?
Not great.
Yeah, me neither.
Is it your mother?
Yes.
She died some time ago.
I'm sorry it's a beautiful statue it's solid gold yeah it
must have been very expensive your dad really spared no
expense I guess did you find him yet mr.
crow no not yet I'm still looking for your father but I have
a pretty good idea where he is I just need to take the
central elevator Mara what are you going to do when you when
you find him I need to talk with him.
Are you going to kill him?
What?
No, of course not!
Don't think I don't see that gun in your hand.
Oh, I see it in your face too.
You've already made up your mind.
Natalie, I know he's done bad things, very bad things.
Perhaps he is beyond forgiveness.
Please don't kill him.
Bring him to me, okay?
Let me speak to him.
One way or another, today might be my last chance.
Please, Mara.
Okay.
Why don't you come with me?
No.
I don't want to know what's down there.
I'll wait here.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
Alright.
Oh.
So the 9218...
Is that this code?
Because that would be really funny.
Oh, there is no code.
The lighting.
is so cool sometimes like look at the chair you know like
that it's a video feed from a security camera wait a second
that's my car looks like arthur is still inside arthur can
you hear me it's even funnier he forgot to spread his code
spread my code mora is that you i can't see you where are
you i'm in a control A control room?
Is it cool?
Yeah, it's really cool.
I'm jealous.
You got to go on a real adventure.
Arthur, how are you feeling?
Not great.
Just stay there, okay?
Mara, are you coming back?
Are we going to leave?
This poor man needs a hospital!
Sure, yeah, I'll be back soon.
Okay, good.
Um...
Wait, what was it?
Nine, two, one.
Oh, I did it.
There's a lever inside.
Oh, I pulled it.
Oh, bad.
Oh, I activated the central one.
All five lights are green.
It's a video feed from a security camera.
There's nothing there.
What is this?
Nothing.
Happy,
happy birthday!
That scared that the heck get out of me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I gotta reload it, but...
Uh, oh, please, please, please.
Oh my god.
This room is tiny.
Wait, is that countdown?
No, I think it's just numbers.
Just numbers.
Defeat all four optional...
Optional!
How are they optional mini-bosses?
How is that optional?
I couldn't leave.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh, this thing?
Where is it?
What happened?
Is this green?
Where is it?
Wait.
Hmm?
My ammo is like... Oof!
Oof!
Wait, can I just leave through here?
Oh, I see!
Wait, there's... Oh, I'm sitting on a fort!
Okay, wait.
Uh... Where's one?
A one?
How do I reset it?
Okay, wait.
One.
Whoa!
Two.
Um, three.
I'm walking carefully.
Three.
There's also a trash can.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Oh!
Oh, that was the quietest door ever.
Shotgun ammo!
Thank goodness it's not seven digits.
Yeah.
How is that optional?
Oh, I guess if you do the code...
I don't know.
She's still here.
If you know how to do the code and you do it while...
Hmm, I don't know.
But what is this?
9218.
And also this whole puzzle here.
Goblin.
Emerged at around 55% root excavation.
Despite their small stature, I've concluded that they are
not in...
I've been calling it a baby.
On the contrary, they may be a senior variant of their
guests.
Their advanced age causing a weaker genetic makeup, which
has diminished their anatomy of what I've been...
gone in a baby.
Oh, my bad, sorry.
This guy is scary.
Spindle.
Much of their muscle and fat is missing, but their bones
have become elongated.
However, the bone mass is spread more thinly, and
consequently the bones are brittle.
Additionally, without sufficient flesh as cushioning, their
joints are weak.
Lumber.
Have I seen this guy?
Same time as spindles.
can be observed.
Lumbers are stiff and stout with excessive muscle and fat.
Perhaps this could explain why spindles have insufficient
flesh.
This guy, Grinner.
I don't like him.
70% root excavation.
Form is bipedal, but other similarities to a human body are
quickly disappearing.
In terms of anatomy, each specimen is vastly different from
the next.
Puddle.
They are quite literally melting.
And this is just guessed.
They largely retain a human-like appearance.
Most distressing, they are capable of a limited non-verbal
form of vocalization.
Yeah!
We hate puddle.
Yeah, puddle sucks.
So what is this?
Oh, wait.
Control room elevator switch number code.
My first is in Grinner, but also in Goblin.
My second...
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, this is going to be so annoying.
Okay, guys, we got this.
My first is in Grinner, but also in Goblin.
I'm wondering if this is the code that's on the bot, you
know, the back of here.
Wait, no, go back.
Oh, Grinner.
Bot.
5592.
But also in Goblin.
173.
They have nothing in common.
Oh, the nine!
Sorry.
They have nine!
Wait a second.
If this starts with a nine...
9-218.
You guys, we have it.
Alright.
So now...
Um...
What did I need to do?
Oh, we have the key?
Okay, the golden key went to the area in the mermaid place.
And also Crow's office.
Did it go anywhere else?
I don't... I think that room in Crow Country.
Maybe.
I can't remember.
Big man!
Did you solve the toilet bones?
No, I think we might have to abandon toilet bones.
We might not be toilet boning.
I hope things didn't respawn here.
Okay.
We have to go to We are at Sunday.
We must go to Thursday.
Seems like things didn't.
I think we're okay.
Perhaps things did not regenerate.
Will this ride be better than old reliable?
There's no way.
Old reliable is like number one for me.
Okay.
Toilet boning?
Ah, this house got good bones!
Are you still here?
Oh!
She's still here.
Okay, I'm gonna go unlock the door first.
Let's make sure there's nothing out here.
Alright, I think we're good.
The golden key.
I've got the golden ticket.
It is still ringing.
There's even pizza!
Old slices of pizza are still inside.
I'm not hungry enough to do it.
I'm not hungry enough.
You can't make me do it!
Hello?
You're still alive.
I know it's dangerous up there.
How were you calling here?
And then also calling me in your room, huh?
Hmm.
I know it's dangerous up there.
A lot of them got out into the open.
But I know you brought a gun.
Have you been killing them?
There are no shape to continue living.
The ones that emerged more recently, even more so.
As I continue the root excavation, the guests became even
less.
Well, some of them aren't even bipedal anymore.
It goes without saying that we cannot let them leave crow
country.
We cannot afford to let them infect anybody else.
What are they?
Who are they?
They are irreversible.
Infect.
What does that say?
Ride area?
It's a hat.
I wonder if sea captains really wear these hats.
Or have I been lied to by cartoons?
What's in here?
Wait, I don't really want to waste my ammo.
Game hates me!
Okay.
Alright, let's do the ride.
Anything I can do?
do for you?
Uh, the boat ride, the seven seas, use your help operate the
controls, have you opened the door?
Yeah, it's open.
Nice work.
I'll head to the control room and you can get, you go to the
boat boarding area.
See you there.
Okay.
Why do I feel like something's gonna chase me onto the boat,
you know?
I'm scared.
The seven seas.
Okay.
Number two.
I get it all to myself.
Nice.
Are you ready to go?
She's wearing the hat.
So cute.
I think so.
I can't guarantee this will be safe.
Should I start the ride?
Start.
Start the ride, Julie.
Here we go!
Okay, I can't shoot while on the ride.
I can't even look at my inventory.
Oh, there's, like, stuff around here, though.
Oh.
The white whale is blocking the boat.
If I remember it right, he's supposed to move out of the
way.
But I think it's done manually from the control panel.
I wonder why Julie didn't press the button!
Oh, that's fine.
Does this have something in there?
Control box.
Okay, one second.
Before then.
Can't see a way to open it.
The other one looked fake, though.
There was something over here, but it looks fake, you know?
Nah, it looks fake.
Dang it.
Press a button.
That's okay.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Oh, there's mermaids.
Oh my god, there's mermaids.
What is this?
to over here.
Oh wait, but there is this box I can break.
Medkit!
In a time where I need more ammo.
I guess I should go back to my car, maybe.
Oh, it's breaking up closer.
Ooh!
If she's close and then I lift her up, can I take her
battery?
Let's see.
Open her up!
There's nothing in there.
Oh, okay, okay.
Alright, we gotta try the other...
I think the second one gets close enough.
Maybe.
Or maybe they all get close enough.
Let's try it.
Oh, yeah, they all do.
Just kidding.
Okay.
There's a battery in here, but it's totally fried.
I can't use it, but I'll leave it alone.
Alright, third time's the charm, everybody.
This is the one.
Unless it's purple.
It would make sense as if it's purple because of her hair.
Is that a battery?
Wait, no.
It's a case of shotgun shells.
We take those.
You know what?
Awesome.
We take those, for real.
Lift!
It's a battery in fairly good condition.
What do I do here though now?
Can I tell her that I need to leave?
Why did it stop?
Oh, okay.
Um...
White whale.
To the last I grapple with thee.
From hell's heart I stab at thee.
For hate's sake I spit my last breath at thee.
He's black in the boat.
I can't continue the ride.
Biggest, most ornate switch I've ever seen.
What did it do?
Hey!
Uh-oh.
That's blood.
Something in the vent!
What, we're just gonna ignore that?
Wait.
It's the control panel.
There's blood on it.
That seems to have stopped working.
Did they eat the pizza?
The pizza is still safe.
Uh-oh.
Julie?
Okay.
Alright, we got the battery, so we have to go put it in.
in the crow.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
It's nighttime now.
Aw, man.
Yeah, the glass jar, I'm saving my ammo.
I don't want to quite get it.
Oh, that's not Julie.
Is it?
That's not Julie.
What is it?
Julie?
You good?
At least this is still working.
Julie!
Julie's not in here?
No.
Neptune's Palace.
Stop.
I think this is the room that...
The storage room.
Let's see if I can shoot it.
No.
Whoa, what the hell?
Where did that come from?
Ah!
Oh my god!
Someone's out here killing all these things.
Can I put you...
Can I put the battery?
I turn on the elevator behind you.
Can you move out of the way, please?
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Who's shooting at me?
Oh, that's right.
I have to turn him around, I think.
Oh no, that's right.
Out of power.
boss get down that's an enemy gun ship
it's kind of freaky how quiet it is now wait is this it's
not health kit no it's purple my fortune telling machine are
you good
i i feel like i should go investigate the gunshots but part
of me is also like well i could just do this oh the battery
suddenly is charging oh shoot I don't know how to charge it.
Can we take it?
It was 24 Fahrenheit with wind chill.
But the Oshikatsu is worth it!
Oh my gosh!
Why is it so cold?
Yeah, time to go investigate, I guess.
All these guys are down, too, so...
Wait, which way is it?
Also, can I go in here yet?
Locked on the other side.
Silver key.
Oh my gosh, I could have gone in here a million years ago!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, shoot.
Why am I doing this?
Um.
I only have, like, 20.
20 left.
Maybe I should ignore them.
Ignore them?
Ouch.
Ouch, bitch, oh.
something inside mushroom I'm a little mushroom boy I use my
mushroom magic to grant you a wish tell me what is it that
you wish you want to improve the capacity of your shotgun
yes to each their own wish granted oh shit
oh wait he's coming this way isn't he I think I'm in trouble
oh I'm looking around very carefully to see if there's
anything for me to grab.
I don't see anything.
Well, I'm just gonna leave!
Well, we got to check out that area.
That's kind of fun.
Oh my god, this scared me.
Hey!
I can't tell if these will hit me or not, you know?
Wait, what was that?
Something just flashed yellow.
Oh, it was a...
Never mind.
Soda can.
I wish I had filled my ass in.
I would have...
I would have boned.
I would have gotten the bones.
What's that?
Diagram of video game controller.
Oh, was that always there?
Literally finding part of the tutorial right now.
What was shooting at me?
Are you okay?
Did the...
Did a police call...
Can the officer come by here?
Yeah, he was on a bike.
Did he talk to him?
Wait, I can still use the acid.
I have enough in my inventory?
Wait, what do you mean I have enough?
What do you mean I have enough?
Is it only if I have zero?
That's so lame.
But I also know that there was, there's a secret here.
I just don't know how to find it.
It's so dark.
It's a car.
Mm-hmm.
Reload my handgun first.
There we go.
No!
It still hates me.
There's a secret here.
I saw it on the map.
See?
Eat El Crow.
Oh, silver!
Is it a mushroom man?
mushroom boy mushroom boy it's a shoe box to Natalie happy
17th dad running
shoes okay oh my god
who's shooting at me then we're zooming that's so funny it
looks so goofy I still have to be careful where I walk
though because of traps all right well I'm just gonna save
one more time.
Oh, the acid.
Let's see if the acid works.
Sorry, I forgot to check that too.
Hopefully there's nobody in here.
Oh, uh, oh, oh.
I think I...
There we go.
Oh, it did work!
I think the bones are melting.
It's a box of magnum ammo.
Oh.
I don't even have the revolver!
So lame!
Dang it.
It's very close.
There was still stuff in the shop.
Oh, there was?
Honestly, I was so scared.
I just wanted to get out.
Wait.
Oh, I forgot to open it from the other side.
Everyone's in gift shop for the revolver.
Do I even... I mean, I have six shots.
Six shots.
Maybe I don't need anymore.
The Crypt Ophelia riddle.
Oh, true.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
I'm not here to get every single thing.
I'm gonna go ask my crow friend for help on how to...
this battery there's a battery charger on the underground
level okay stop shooting at me please you're scaring me so
so straightforward I'd rather not thank you so much for the
for the thank you to thank you
So are things dead in here too?
Because if so, this whole area is basically like free roam
now.
Oh my god.
Good night.
I'll take it.
Okay.
I think we're all right.
I think I'm just gonna focus on getting...
Okay, this goes down to where...
Okay.
We are here.
This is gonna take us to Slenderman.
Oh, I could talk to the mushroom.
You're right.
Wait, what's going on?
What is this?
Are these lasers now?
Why do we have lasers?
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, wait.
Is that the battery charger?
I'm so ridiculous while running.
Oh my god, game!
Please be kind.
Let's go to...
Oh my gosh, I just nearly dodged that too.
I think there...
No, there's still things inside.
Yeah, it's okay.
It's just outside that is safe at the moment.
Is this not a battery charger?
Okay.
I guess not.
Oh, ouch!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
I was trying to see what was inside that jar.
I might caution.
Okay, we're fine.
Flame Thriller.
I know the crow told me where to go.
I'm...
I'm gathering stuff here now.
More gasoline.
Okay.
I'm hunting for items while it's safe.
Oh, but yeah, let's go back downstairs.
This is so stupid.
Where is it?
Where it is?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, I'm gonna save before we go downstairs.
Awesome.
Use the electrocution room to charge the battery.
I wonder...
Does he get electrocuted?
That'd be sick if real.
Your fragile bones, Mr.
Oh, here he comes.
Oh, shoot.
He's invincible?
Oh, no, he's not.
Alrighty, um...
It almost looks like it could pass under my head, but...
He does...
He looks so scary.
He acts so scary.
Battery charger, battery charger, battery charger.
Did you guys see anything like a battery charger in here?
Oh!
The Root Tuesday!
It said that I should put something in there.
I remember.
Yes, in here!
Electrocution machine.
Stick that in.
Press the button.
Oh, hold it.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah!
I think with that, every area will have been...
Like every map area will have had the circle gone.
Neat!
There's just two rooms that I didn't get into.
Well, I got into the gift shop in the end.
But that other room I didn't get into.
But that's okay!
Alright!
Let's go.
It's starting to get sleepy.
Almost there!
Yeah, we're almost there!
Save.
So I don't have to do it again.
Save scumming.
Wait, is this exit?
Nope.
That's the gold room.
That leads... it's over here.
This way, yeah.
I'm zooming, I'm zooming.
Alright, put the battery in.
What's happening?
Oh, oh my god!
Ah!
God, she like stopped and stared at something so I
thought...
Oh my god, I like got...
That was crazy.
I like got stuck on the thing and then when I moved it
looked like...
It looked like I got caught in a...
Caught in a cutscene.
Oh, nope, nope.
Alright, we're good.
Whoa, don't shoot me!
Turn you around.
Make you walk.
Caught seen.
Yeah, I got caught seen.
Just like that, he walked out of my life.
It's fun that he was like the final like kind of piece that
I needed.
Sorry, hold on.
Let's do that again.
Um...
Stop it!
Yeah, we must prepare emotionally.
Try to look for the person shooting you.
I went over there.
There's nobody over there.
Oh my god.
I
think now we can use this.
I'm the little guys left.
Like you.
Oops.
My aim, don't go.
Daya!
Thank you so much for the retarab!
Um.
I'm at the end of the game, so maybe spoilers.
Oh.
What's that?
Medkit.
Take that.
Alright cool, thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you, STM2, thank you for the gifted!
Thank you, thank you for the gifted!
Thank you guys, thank you!
Thank you for the level, thank you for the five gifted!
Wait, did I miss one?
I'd rather not, did I get you earlier?
I think so.
Thank you though.
Thank you so much!
Furby, thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Grubby old sports bag.
Rustin Glitchface, thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you!
There's nothing.
There's something in there.
Handgun there.
Um, where does this go to?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Okay, so these are like quick exits.
Preparing us for the final battle, it seems.
It's Harrison!
Rise now, thank you for the five gifted.
Jade, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you for the five, get the...
No, thank you so much for the tiny cat.
Thank you.
Harrison, he's dead!
He must have been attacked by those.
Wait, no, he was shot.
Harrison, I'm so sorry.
Harrison James, ID number 05061.
Date of birth, January 12th.
It was almost his birthday.
January 12th, 1965.
Firearms expert.
He was put on the Edward Crow missing persons case.
I tried to stop him coming to Crow country.
He really wanted to help.
Whoever called Harrison saying like a death flag earlier,
you definitely called it.
You definitely called it.
Whoa.
The mining lanterns are really old and need replacing.
Any kind of spark tends to set off the oil that's trapped
inside.
Check my ID.
Wait, what?
What?
It was his ID?
It's a staff memo.
Any kind of spark tends to set off the oil that's trapped
inside.
If that happens, just give it a whack to disperse.
the oil the flame should go out all right one last puzzle
guys but my brain is really oh gosh sorry i'm getting so
sleepy do i have to you think i have to shoot this
we stole his id when we broke into his car
is that a spark it needs a spark wait but
Oh, just use the flamethrower.
You were so right.
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
I'm just going to waste all my ammo otherwise.
Take that for sure.
Oh, wow.
I want this one too.
I'm being greedy right now.
I'm being absolutely greedy.
Give me my ammo.
Is it literally the one thing that I didn't like?
Is it the second one that I didn't get?
Oops.
Wait.
No, you were in my way.
Wait, no.
Oh wait, I had it, didn't I?
But wait, I wanted to not...
Oh, shoot.
I see.
Wait, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
It needs to be seven.
That needs to be two to go down.
Oh, no!
I would have to redo the whole thing.
I guess we make a do.
It's just pistol ammo.
I don't.
Wait, how do I get rid of it, though?
Okay, there we go.
Ah!
you Tolman I can't let you listen Harrison is dead Harrison
James the police detect I know who he is I'm sorry Mara he
shouldn't have come here it was only a matter of time before
one of those creatures he was shot with a gun shit oh he
came up behind me do you know who did it oh I think he
probably he's You probably got a good idea.
Marvin, you weasel...
Look kid, this is nothing personal, okay?
Put the gun down, Trumble.
And then what, huh?
Go home?
Forget this whole thing ever happened?
The feds will be kicking down my door within the week!
It's no surprise that it's Marvin, guys.
Nothing personal, kid.
I'm culpable for all this shit.
I know.
I am too.
but mara is not so leave her out of it she knows way too
much you think she won't rat us out i don't i don't think i
don't think harrison knew anything he's right by a vent i
noticed that too yeah completely conveniently placed vent
hell she already tried she was getting real chatty with that
pretty boy officer I tried to stop him from coming.
I kept telling him to leave.
Well, he didn't leave, did he?
And neither did you.
And now it's too late.
Who was that?
No idea.
If this is some sort of trick, I ain't...
Oh.
Julie?
Where am I?
Julie!
You need some help, girl.
Julie?
Hey.
What's going on?
What are you doing in there?
I'll tell you if you help me out of this thing.
Oh, gosh.
Sorry.
Is Julie like a secret double agent?
That would be crazy.
Tolman, would you give me a hand?
Sure.
Okay.
Julie, I thought you'd been...
I mean, I came out of the boat ride and you were gone.
There was blood.
Something grabbed me.
backwards into the vent what was it whatever it was there
are several more of them hiding out in the pipes it's pitch
black in there but I could hear them smell them and what
they tried to kill you no mostly they just shook me around
made a bunch of noise shouting weeping moaning whatever
you'd call it sounds about right what do you mean they're
angry but they don't want to kill us they're trying to
communicate I think they're trying to kill me mara you
haven't introduced me oh right sorry julie this is tolman he
works for edward crow are we the baddies nah why would they
come after me then and tolman this is julie baron she's a
lawyer she's like the most badass lawyer what is with
lawyers that always getting into stuff she was hired by the
marshall family elaine marshall's family I see what are you
two doing down here someone's been killed shot a police
officer goodness me better call Saul yeah maybe they hate
purple hair they're like traditionalists they're like never
dye your hair a funky color Tolman here was just about to go
deal with it weren't you I sorry kids so if you I'm still
sleeping now.
They're not trying to kill us.
They're trying to communicate us by killing us.
They're trying to communicate us by hitting us and stabbing
us.
I have experience with this kind of thing.
Julie, what do you mean by that?
Mara.
Something else.
Natalie Crowe is waiting in Edward Crowe's office.
Would you go see how she's doing?
Crowe's daughter?
Sure, of course.
I'd love a chance to talk to her, actually.
You're not...
One last thing, Arthur Mole.
He's out in the staff parking area in my white fiesta.
Would you check on him too?
I've left him alone way too long.
Of course, we can do that too.
Thank you.
Mara, what are you going to do?
I'm going to do what I came here to do.
We'll be waiting by your car, okay?
Fiesta!
Okay?
Thanks.
I don't think Mara thinks she's getting out of here.
I think, me thinks, um, Mr. Edward has been, uh, infected.
Aggressive form of ASL.
Come along, Mr. Tolman.
We've got lots to do.
You're at the end.
This is so fun.
Thank you for playing this.
One last favor.
After, after you get a piece of paper, check it as soon as
you get access to your inventory.
Good luck, Minto.
Thank you!
Is this the final battle?
It's held in place by two chains.
Iki-mash!
Is this the puddle that he likes or whatever?
It's a pool of water.
It looks so clean.
Is this a spring?
What?
Wash my face?
Why not?
That feels better.
I didn't realize how filthy I was.
Oh, maybe that healed me.
I wish I could save.
I don't want to have to go through all this again
what a thrill what is backwards with darkness and there's
darkness silence with the night what a thrill cute three
days in a row what are we talking about thank you for the
super that it went by so fast i could barely breathe it but
thank you
I could scroll up while I go down.
Yeah, be a coincidence.
Thanks for the long streams this week, Minto.
You've been keeping me company in the long nights when I
can't shut my brain off and nothing could help me more than
you.
Eric, I hope you get some good rest.
It's a pretty long...
I think we actually could have sung.
Snake user.
Look at how long that was.
Oh yeah.
They're loading us up, baby.
Oh, they're loading us up, baby.
Collection of staff.
So there is a place to save here.
Piece of paper.
Someone's written something here, but I can't make sense of
it.
It's nonsense.
Okay.
Photos taped up on the wall.
Natalie Crowe, Edward Crowe's daughter.
Tolman, engineer Crowe put in charge of route excavation.
of me.
When did they take this?
Julie Barron, the lawyer hired Arthur Mole, the teenager who
wanted to photograph the guests?
Marvin Trumbull, he was responsible for Crow's fake gold
mine.
Douglas Pike, he was in charge of building the actual theme
park.
And finally, Harrison James.
He was the police officer sent to look for Edward Crow.
It's been left off the hook.
No call, no, he doesn't want anybody to call him back.
Five glass vials, each with the same pale green liquid
inside.
I don't know what they're for.
I'll leave them alone.
A shower?
Wait, my hair...
Die.
The purple?
Oh my god.
More shotgun shells.
Okay.
I know what we're going in with then.
Intercom.
A curtain.
Ooh!
Oh, I thought that was a flesh suit.
Guys, I think this is breaking bad.
It's covered a fine layer of dust.
I guess he's not wearing it anymore.
The hazmat suit!
For Natalie, I won't open it.
A microwave.
With Medkit inside.
I think this is just breaking bad.
This must have been where Crow has been sleeping.
The sheets are stained with blood.
Oh, I think this guy is so infected.
Bunsen burner.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, can I save here?
Wait, that's crazy.
Fun!
Oh, that's so cool.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to get this handgun, Emma.
Oh!
It's an elevator.
way to get up to the surface.
It doesn't work anymore.
Because someone's driven a fire axe through the control
panel.
Alright, I think I got everything there is to get.
Um.
I think so.
Okay.
It always comes back to Breaking Bad.
Mr. Crowe, I'm here.
I'm in your lab.
Hello, Elaine.
open the door I will no way we're oh shoot but first please
pick up the glass vials I've laid out on the counter why
please fine I feel like I should have seen that coming I
don't know what first I need to free up some space to put
down the other objects I'm carrying The twist!
Glass vials.
All my stuff!
Left in their place all the other items I collected.
The police ID card I took from Harrison James.
The bronze key given to me by a fairy.
The crank handle I found in a safe.
This is so emotional!
I've never thought of, you know, like when you're done with
a game and you're getting rid of all your items you don't
need anymore, like...
You think of your journey and you're just like, Ah!
Refresh me, who was Elaine?
Elaine was the girl that was the girl who got attacked and
got the uh, the park closed down.
Wait a second.
So she's the idiot.
That's why she said she was stupid.
She actually is dumb.
The ruby gemstone that was hidden in a painting of a demon.
The chain I took from the neck of a mechanical swan.
The mask I excavated from a block of resin.
The trident I took out of a witch's.
cauldron the silver key that was hidden in Neptune's palace
the data disk I got from the change machine in an arcade the
acid bottle I took from a cell in a dungeon the golden key I
found trapped inside a fairy's head the battery I pulled
from the stomach of a robotic mermaid good times
all right I don't think there's anything else in here for me
to grab so I think we're good.
Oh, wait.
Mr. Crowe, I have the vials.
Open the door.
Stand back.
Check the paper?
This one?
Someone's written something here, but I can't make sense of
it.
It's nonsense.
Still won't let me.
I just have the glass vials now.
What do you mean, infected?
Don't say that!
Infected!
I'm confused.
There we go.
The health?
Oh, you're right.
Wait, when did that happen?
Wait, condition infected.
Oh, mister.
Elaine Marshall.
Edward Crow.
It happened...
it happened when we got attacked, no?
Yeah, she's been affected since she got attacked, I think.
How long has it been?
Two years?
We've never met before.
No, I mean, since you became infected.
Two years.
Yeah, two years since I shut the park.
I'm glad you came back.
Why would you give a shit?
I would offer you a drink, but what are you now, 18?
Not quite.
And yet, you made it all the way down here.
You're clearly very stubborn.
I see these I see these traps on the side.
That's good.
It gives me hope.
Tell me.
How are you feeling?
Bad.
Tired.
Oh, yeah, me too.
They can't get rid of my infection.
It's been getting worse.
Of course.
Hold on.
I must say, I'm relieved they let you out of the hospital
long enough to.
They didn't.
I see.
You really are determined.
And all this?
Because you want to kill me, I assume?
No.
I came because I want to tell you something face to face.
I need you to know.
Go on.
Mr. Crow, I'm going to die from this infection.
We tried everything.
Nothing works.
It's going to kill me.
But I didn't realize you have it too?
The same infection?
Of course.
Anyone who has been exposed to the guests will have it.
Oh no, that means our baddie lawyer.
Julie.
Naturally, I was the first.
When the first guest emerged from the pool, I tried to help
him.
I put him in a holding cell, up on the ground level, so he
could monitor him more easily.
A holding cell, that's where I was attacked.
Yes, bringing the guests up to the surface proved to be a
mistake.
But you, you look worse than I do.
am simply further along my continued exposure to the guests
has accelerated the process continued exposure your bloody
escapade today and may prove to have a similar effect for
you oh god it looks bad what's it like when it gets that bad
I shall not lie to you Elaine do you remember when your
family asked me to pay your medical fees oh no That's why
her hair is a picture.
Now her hair is like that blonde, but she had it as purple.
They're holding you accountable since I was injured in your
park.
Well, you never paid them.
My lawyer is trying to take you to court over it.
Yes, this was a deliberate decision on my part.
No, it was a deliberate decision.
Knowing the nature of your illness, I knew there could be no
cure found at the hospital.
Wait.
But there is a cure.
I made one.
You help.
I had to reverse-engineer it.
I've been studying the highly infectious bacteria on the
dead bodies of the guests.
New kinds of bacteria that nobody knows about yet.
That's been the problem.
It's no surprise your doctors were stumped.
Those vials from your lab?
Yes.
You have the cure on your person at this very moment.
Five vials.
Enough to cure five people.
Five.
Harrison and Marvin are dead.
So that leaves you, me, Natalie, Tolman, Julie, and Arthur.
That's six people.
You didn't make enough vials!
I don't think he's getting out, though.
You're wrong, Lair.
I shall not be taking the cure.
You understand where we are right now.
You call it the pool.
Ha ha ha ha.
are seven roots what's left of them after years of you
cutting them up harvesting them for gold exactly right
Elaine look at me listen the pool is a gay boy sorry and the
guests are human beings who are who attempted to travel
through it and emerged here why do they look so why are they
so messed up because I have spent the last ten years
dismantling the mechanism of that gateway I don't understand
you're making me yawn too I'm sorry no I don't say yawn the
pool still works technically but thanks to me it is severely
malfunctioning you see the roots are kind of a calibration
antenna necessary to accurate accurately and safely
transport those who travel through the pool Mr. Krill, where
are they coming from?
The guests.
What's on the other side of the pool?
You understand now how my excavations have been causing the
mutations of the guests.
And also understand the mutations have been getting worse as
I cut down more of the roots.
The beings that emerge from the pool now, they barely
resemble humans at all.
Most of them cannot walk, let alone speak.
from the pool all that time ago.
He was the least mutated.
No, yes, Elaine.
He could speak.
Just barely.
He told me who he was and why he had come.
He wrote it down word for word.
Oh, I wrote it down on a little piece of paper.
And then I went back to harvesting the roots.
No subsequent guests were capable of speech.
You may now understand why I'm choosing not to take the
cure.
My time is short.
Before I die, I must look upon what I have wrought.
You're going through the pool?
Hold out your hand.
What?
Take it.
It's a little piece of paper.
Now that it is in your hands, I am going through the pool.
He'll be mutated.
It'll kill you.
A fitting end.
I can't check it.
We're still in the dialogue, guys.
Perhaps if I am lucky, I may get a glimpse of what lies on
the other side.
I feel like he's going to mutate and we'll have to fight
him.
I have one more thing to ask of you, Elaine.
If for any reason I reemerge from the pool, I want you to
kill me.
Oh, that's what I literally just said.
But if I reemerge, I will be in no shape to continue living.
Do you understand?
Goodbye, Elaine.
I raise a glass to your future.
Whoa!
I still won't let me check my inventory.
Uh...
A small piece of paper given to me by Edward Crowe.
It's folded in half.
2106 uninhabitable.
ruined.
We come 1988, last chance, warn, stop, change.
So they're from the future?
And it's uninhabitable?
And so they came back to to warn everybody.
Yeah, the number on the wall was 2106.
Yeah.
Okay, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Wait, I need to shoot these real quick.
Sorry, you scared me.
Okay, now I'm good.
Wait, where's my...
Where is it, please?
Where is it?
There.
Oh my god.
Run?
The music is kind of crazy though.
What's he doing?
Eki!
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, please, where's my... Where's my... There we go.
Oh my god, my aim.
Oh,
it's getting real bloody.
Where is he?
Where is it?
There it is.
Oh!
You won't get me.
It's pretty nasty.
Okay, I gotta change my gun.
I wonder if I could flamethrower him.
I'm just gonna...
do a big big heal i can't take these at all so let's try and
flame throw them oh shoot we're running
oh uh i'm just chilling
was that it what
edward elade it's it's it's shut up i don't want to know
Lane, you...
Arrg.
You... you promise to kill.
Yeah, okay.
It's over.
There's only one thing left to do.
Wait.
We'll do it with the handgun, at least.
Oh!
But then I take the cure, and we're fine!
Yes.
Snake and boss I totally thought it too Everyone else is
drinking the potion
Crow country Four miles Staring into the flames I feel
something It's a curious mixture of hope and dread Oh yeah I
wonder what it tastes like Maybe everything will be okay
I did take her Natalie's shoes.
And maybe it won't.
I wish we had at least taken the letter for Natalie to give
to her, you know.
Yay!
We did it!
Curl Country!
Oh, wow!
That was so good!
I feel like I spent most of my time running away, but...
That is part of one of the...
That is...
That's part of the territory for these people.
types of games huh yay i feel like i faced a fear of of of
these survival horror types that i don't typically like so
yeah congrats on another w i hope this victory tastes super
sweet and the tippy tip of your tongue please get lots and
lots of rest oh dargo thank you so much for the pink thank
you thank you thank you thank you
Complete the game.
You played a great game.
Beat it on one stream, too.
Thank you for the long stream of Giggles.
Our game.
Thank you.
Now to play every Resident Evil game.
All I mean.
Oh, what's my results?
Kiel's use, 27.
Hint spent four.
Six out of 15.
I didn't die.
final rank B plus we take those we take those Wimsy thank
you so much for the five gift and thank you no deaths
actually these guys made snipper clips what seriously
bonus items crowbar you know I almost equipped my crowbar
today I'm was like maybe i'll maybe i'll i'll i'll have it
because i feel like this is the type of game where you get a
crowbar the potion by the way is mountain dew bah blast
which they didn't have in 1988 the whole game was secretly a
mountain dew advertisement crow quest crystal crows are
hiding around crow country can you find and shoot them all
wait that's so cute Do you have to play like the game to do
that?
Or can I just search for them?
I'm so sleepy now you guys!
I'm so sleepy.
But this is so great!
Time to add it to my list of games I've completed.
Here we go.
Crow Country.
Finally off my list.
Well, we'll say 29.
20, 25.
And that's just two more games until I have 50 games
completed this year.
Yippee!
Just two more.
So tomorrow and the day after.
Oh.
Yippee.
Yippee, yippee, yippee.
Oh, thank you guys for hanging out with me for so long.
Fake neat, thank you!
Congrats on for the stream, congrats on another game
completed!
Oh, it's a veto, it's a veto.
Ah, just two more.
Yippee, ha!
This one I enjoyed way more than I thought I would.
So I'm happy about that.
I do still want to play Resident Evil.
games so maybe this was a good little warm-up still trying
to get through my I mean I played stealth for Metal Gear I I
you know I I said I hate stealth games but I'll still play
it for Metal Gear so I can do it for for Resident Evil I
think I think so
my brain is like So dead.
So good.
Thanks for the stream.
Glad I could catch you on my day off.
Nah, well, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
48 out of 50!
James Cameron!
Couldn't watch for the entire stream, but I did listen to
the whole thing.
Thank you so much!
Ah, everybody who's been around the whole time.
Seven, almost seven and a half hours.
So...
Oh, I missed a 50 gifted!
I did?
I'm so sorry!
Oh yeah!
I'm sorry!
How did I miss that?
Oh my gosh, I must have been really locked in with the game.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, I'm sorry!
That's three seven-hour mintotons in a row.
And a collab.
You work longer than my work shifts.
Keep it up until the New Year's to 50 games of 2025.
Yeah!
I was so locked in.
I'm sorry.
Oh my goodness.
You got me through a long workday.
Thanks very much me though of course thank you next thank
you always thank you always always always it's a good game
though it is a good game I really enjoyed it I didn't know
what the storyline would be at all I was wondering if it was
like zombies or like what's that what's that guy that does
all the like serial killer type games with the name it's
like on the tip of my tongue
Puppet combo.
So I wasn't sure if it was like that kind of game or what.
It was Breaking Bad.
Turns out it was sci-fi.
That's so awesome.
What a fun twist at the end.
I love that.
Thank you everybody who helped me with the puzzles.
Or hinted me along.
Or helped me remember where to go.
Or helped me...
with with codes and things thank you i love that these types
of games ah sorry that these types of games can be a team
effort together so thank you everybody thank you thank you
moral support yeah good job i boo good job i boo
oh my gosh i know you guys didn't want to be Labubus, but
you can be I-Bubus.
I'm gonna have to make like a Labubu-type I-Bubu plushie.
No, please.
It'll be cute, I promise.
Vito, Vito.
Okay, Vito.
I-Boo.
I-Boo is fine.
Yes, I was just kidding.
I was just kidding!
I was just, I was just, I was just kidding with you.
This is the face of a, this is the face of a, of a kidder.
I boo, this is the face of a kidder.
I am the owner of the one and only 24 karat gold.
I boo boo.
You've always been a kidder, meen toe.
Oh no, back to harvest.
You do have two last games lined up.
Yeah, I do, I do.
Thank you, though, Lolly.
Thank you, thank you.
I do have the last two.
Tomorrow will be a collab.
Oh, I have my schedule.
Wait, I can show you guys.
But there's one last thing that's not finished.
It's not completed.
Specifically Saturday.
Oh, oops, sorry.
I was trying to.
So Crow Country, tomorrow will be Berrybug.
block battle bug finale and then freak retreat countdown for
new years it's a little less of a countdown because i'm
starting kind of early i'm thinking maybe i'll play it and
then like we can chat until until new year's est but then
also sloppy sister's new year's countdown and vr shot and
then finishing one one shot on thursday no sorry friday and
then starting alan wake finally On Saturday, the Den Setsu
Beasties collab.
I'm not sure if I'm streaming it yet or not.
The game that we chose, I don't...
I asked about it.
I've never played it before, so I don't know if it's like a
stream.
Everybody POV type thing or not.
And then Membou stream on Sunday.
We're Daminki Droge.
Yeah, yeah.
So, Denzetsu Beasties.
I think they responded actually.
Up to us.
The game works by one person.
Oh, ah.
Oh, it's like a jackbox game, but more wholesome.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I think what we are thinking about is doing one
Denzetsu POV and one Beasties POV.
So, that might work.
But yeah, that's the schedule.
It'll be up tomorrow.
Once we solidify stuff.
So, yeah.
Anyway, thank you guys again.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you.
I appreciate you guys so much.
I'm gonna go rest now.
And I think you guys should do that as well.
What's up, Mito?
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.